Previously on Movamex, der Internationalen Technologie-Gala.
Wir machen solche Sachen öfter mal, so über lange Zeit erst so über den grünen Klee loben und dann hinterher in den Boden stampfen, rammen. Hört euch mal die letzten 20 Folgen Movamex an.
Heute Movamex, wir sollten vielleicht mehr über Max reden, weil da ist ja, wie wir alle wissen, alles in Ordnung. Vor 20 Jahren, da war die Welt noch in Ordnung.
Ja, seinerzeit. Fünf Jahre nach Tschernobyl.
Ja, da hat man auch Tickets bekommen für die World Wide Developers Conference.
Die wurden einem nachgeschmissen.
War doch heute auch kein Problem.
Wie viele hast du denn gekauft?
Na, so viele wie ging.
Eins.
Ich hab mal einen kennengelernt.
Also jeder Einzelne konnte nur eins kaufen.
Jeder konnte nur eins kaufen. Aber über einen Firmen-Account konnte man auch mehrere kaufen. Allerdings nicht gleichzeitig in den Warenkorb legen.
Fährst du hin? Darf ich mal anfassen?
Jetzt bin ich da, aber er hat das Ticket noch nicht.
Wir sind so ein exklusiver Spitzen-Podcast. Wir haben sogar Leute, die zur World Wide Developers Conference gehen, weil sie ein Ticket gekriegt haben. Ja, wir andere müssen uns so ein bisschen kurz halten. Ich habe gedacht, wir könnten vielleicht eine MMDC starten, eine Mobile-Max-Developers-Konferenz.
Oh, das wäre cool.
Einfach mit Currywurst und Bierchen. Wer war das? Ich war das. Ach du warst das. Wer war?
Ich bin ganz raus.
Wir könnten unsere eigene Keynote halten.
Eine ganze Woche lang.
Die Keynote hält man nicht die ganze Woche.
Was?
Bei dir bombt es schon wieder.
Ja, ja, dieses Leiden.
Furchtbar.
Habt ihr die letzte ganze Sendung wieder darüber erzählt?
Dann brauchen wir es eh nicht mal zu machen.
Nicht die ganze.
Also die ganze letzte halbe Stunde oder so.
Ja. Ich weiß nicht.
MMDC willst du machen?
Ja, überhaupt nicht. Setzen wir uns hier einfach in die Mitter-Ebene und schauen uns dann, weiß ich nicht, Max hält einfach sein iPhone da in die Luft und gucken uns dann das ganze live an.
Letztes Jahr haben wir das gemacht. Das WLAN ist dann natürlich bloß zusammengebrochen relativ schnell. Aber die haben bei der Keynote die FaceTime angemacht und haben das dann so ein bisschen in den Saal gestrichen.
Relativ schnell heißt das, es geht 20 Sekunden gut.
Du war aber nicht.
Ich war nicht da, nein.
Warst du überhaupt schon mal auf einer WWDC? Du bist das erste Mal auf einer WWDC. Ja, aber mit oder ohne Steve.
Mit oder ohne Steve, ja. Das hab ich letztes Jahr gesagt.
Letztes Jahr hab ich gesagt so, wenn ich da mal hinfahre, dann ist er bestimmt schon tot.
Nee, das hab ich nicht gesagt, aber nächstes Jahr werden alle garantiert sagen, letztes Jahr hätte man dabei sein müssen. Und jetzt weiß ich auch warum.
Das werden sie sagen, ja.
Ja, das werden sie sagen. Naja, so ist das nun mal. Wie auch immer, erstmal begrüßen wir hier unsere Hörer, die schon die ersten Minuten fleißig durchgehalten haben. Wir beglückwünschen euch zur Teilnahme an Mobamex Nummer 86.
Bei uns kriegt man nämlich noch Tickets.
Genau.
Und begrenzt sozusagen. Mal gucken, wie viele wir schon verkauft haben.
Wir haben noch ein paar Stream-Channels frei. Was sagt eigentlich unser Hörer Meta?
Hörer Meta wird gerade mal gestartet. Das ist das einzige, was hier ist für eine Initialisierung. Erst mal zu gucken, ob man noch bis nach oben kann. So und jetzt muss man noch ein bisschen warten. So zehn Sekunden oder so und dann macht es Katsching.
Oh schick.
Und wie viele Tickets sind schon weggegangen? 430 oder so. 420. 420, 30.
Wer ist denn der alte Mann da in der Decke vom Bimmer?
Das ist der Kaiser.
Der Kaiser.
Ja, weil wir haben ja hier nebenbei, wenn wer auch begleitet, nicht wahr? Also anlässlich.
Auf dessen Dings war ich vor zwei Wochen.
Wir haben noch nicht genug Ablenkung.
Auf dessen, äh, ich war in äh, wie heißt das nein?
Häuflich, Max?
Bunga-Bunga-Party.
Max macht Bunga-Bunga mit dem Kaiser.
Ich war in Tangermünde und das war meine Kaiser-Residenz. Also da war der offensichtlich, dann hat die mal gehört.
Das war ein anderer Kaiser.
Ich glaub auch, du bist auseinander.
Das ist ja der Fußball-Kaiser.
Ja, ich dachte mir so, wenn die jetzt hier schon, also ich meine, die wären sicher die Zwischenstände von Movamex durchzusagen. Und man wollte zumindest wissen, wie es bei denen steht.
Wer spielt denn da und was?
Das ist geil, wir müssen über Fußball reden. Wir müssen wirklich über Fußball und die Computerszene oder die Twitterszene.
Ich hab da einen Experten da, der auch mal jetzt hier über Fußball-Apps dann berichtet.
Dennis, wie ist denn das mit dir und Fußball? Hast du schon mal Fußball gespielt? Viel? Gerne?
Das war auch schon mal gerne, ja.
Und dann bist du sechs geworden und dann war es vorbei.
Ich war mal im Fußballverein.
Ich war mal im Handballverein.
Welchem Fußballverein warst du denn, Roddy?
Ich weiß es noch mal. Kurz bevor ich es wieder gelassen hab, haben wir mal...
Dinkt ihr auch noch Sozialarbeit?
Haben wir mal ein Spiel bestritten, wo die andere Mannschaft in der Unterzahl war und wir haben es trotzdem 7 zu 0 verloren. Irgendwie, das war dann so der Punkt, wo ich mir langsam gedacht hab, das ist vielleicht doch nicht so was für mich.
Okay, hat dir nicht so gefallen?
Auf die Dauer war es mir zu stressig, ja.
Wie alt warst du, als du ausgestiegen bist, wann war deine Karriere beendet?
Ich glaube, da war ich 12.
Oder so.
Warum war das nichts für dich?
Keine Ahnung, das hat es nicht gebracht.
Also ich meine, was hat dich abgeworben? Was war sozusagen das Interesse, was stärker war? Ich meine, war das ein anderer Sport oder war es gar kein Sport mehr? Oder zumindest ein anderer Art von...
Nee, es war eher in Richtung gar kein Sport mehr.
Und dann gleich Computer. Haben dich die Computer abgeworben?
Das kann ich ehrlich gesagt nicht so genau sagen.
War ich mir meine kleine Rolls-Ball-Taste vielleicht?
Nee, ich glaube damals war Computer noch nicht. Aber ich bin mir nicht sicher. Der erste Rechner, den ich hatte, war ein C64. Das war irgendwie 1984.
Das ist nicht wieder die alten Kamellen, aber schweren sich die Leute schon.
Das war dann wahrscheinlich zwei oder drei Jahre später. Keine Ahnung.
Ich versuche jetzt herauszufinden, wie unser Verhältnis zu Fußball ist. Max, wie ist das mit dir mit Fußball?
Also meine Freundin war am Wochenende im Stadion und ich habe so lange gekocht.
Echt? Wie bei Hertha oder was?
Bei Lautern. Die ist Kaisers Lautern-Fan.
Ach so, na hat's ja Spaß gehabt.
Jaja, die haben wohl gebrüllt, wir steigen ab und nehmen euch mit.
Tja, ist aber komisch, ne? Nerds haben generell, glaube ich, nicht so eine Affinität zu Fußball. Ich weiß gar nicht warum. Also ich würde sagen, die Affinität ist in diesen Kreisen unterdurchschnittlich. Ist nicht da. Ein paar haben ja schon auf Twitter abgesagt und gesagt so, was? Moba Max parallel zum Champions League Halbfinale? Ihr habt es ja wohl nicht alle. Da gab aber auch genau das Gegenteil.
Champions League ist da, wo der Kaiser gerade redet.
Die besten der nationalen europäischen Ligen spielen so eine Art Parallel-Milli-Liga.
Also von unserer Bundesliga die ersten drei Plätze oder zwei gegen...
Mittlerweile sind die ersten drei fest und der vierte hat die Chance auch noch dazuzustoßen.
Und das dann gegen die englische Liga, Topplätze, spanische Liga, Topplätze, Italien?
Russland, alles Europa halt.
Echt?
Wobei die einzelnen nationalen Ligen... Das ist... Naja, ich meine die Mannschaften sind ja nicht so national sortiert, wie das jetzt bei Nationalmannschaften ist. Da musst du ja auch die entsprechende Staatsbürgerschaft vorweisen oder zumindest dir besorgen. Während die Club-Teams ja zusammengesetzt sind aus Spielern aus aller Welt.
Zusammengekauft, zusammengekauft.
Das sind ja alles Söldner. Und von daher ist es halt eigentlich... Champions League ist eigentlich so das Tafste überhaupt. Also das glaube ich, Champions League gewinnen ist einfach das Krasseste, weil du da einfach mit den besten Mannschaften gegen die besten Mannschaften spielst.
Die besten, der besten, der besten, Sir!
Genau.
Ja, aber so Bundesliga und Champions League ist irgendwie... Also ich gucke immer nur EM, WM und das war in den letzten Jahren eigentlich auch immer weniger, weiß ich auch nicht. Liegt auch da dann, weil... keine Ahnung. Ich merke das jetzt dann doch. Also die Berichterstattung ist vorher so groß, dass es dann immer denke, alles klar, das kommt ja dann irgendwann und kommt ja dann irgendwann und plötzlich war es dann schon da. Weil die schreiben mir nie, wann es ist. Die schreiben mir nie, wann es ist. Aber sagen irgendwie, es steht ja nicht mehr da, so jetzt morgen geht es wirklich los. Und dann hab ich es immer schon verpasst.
Dennis, ich kann Push-Notification machen für dich.
So spannend, dass es jetzt auch nicht wieder rauskommt. Und ich meine, wenn Deutschland wieder im Halbfinale ist oder im Finale, wenn sie da mal hinkommt, dann merkt man es ja schon und dann kann man auch mal gucken.
Aber ich sehe das genauso wie du. Also mich tangiert zum Beispiel auch Champions League und so weiter alles herzlich wenig. Das ist einfach total uninteressant.
Dafür kennst du dich aber gut aus.
Ja, komisch, ne? Aber ich war ja auch mal im Fußballverein.
Erzähl.
Ich war Torwart, klar war ich Torwart.
Weil sie dich sonst haben nichts anderes machen lassen, weil du nicht schnell genug rennen konntest?
Nee, ich hab zwei Spieler als Mittelstürmer gemacht. Da hab ich vier Tore geschossen und hatte aber keine Lust auf den Job.
Ich war alle ganz ein paar unruhig.
Und ich wollte immer Torwart werden. Ja, weil der Torwart, der war ja anders als die anderen, ne?
Der hatte die coolen Handschuhe.
Ja, da konnte man andere Farben, da konnte man die Farben tragen, die man wollte. Also mir war sozusagen meine individuelle Ausprägung damals schon sehr wichtig. Also für mich wäre es niemals in Frage gekommen, in so einem Feldspieler einer von zehn zu sein.
Du hast deine Position auf dem Platz gewählt, nach der Kleidung, die du dafür tragen konntest?
Auf dem Freiheitsgrad, den ich sozusagen da entwickeln konnte. Ich wollte auch vor allem das machen, was die anderen nicht machen. Ich kann dir das nicht weiter psychologisch aufschlüsseln, warum das jetzt bei mir so war, aber es wird seine Gründe gehabt haben. Aber ich fand halt einfach so die Rolle gefiel mir irgendwie am besten. Aber ich bin dann auch so an meinem Nervstum gescheitert. Du darfst nicht immer irgendwelche Sachen kommentieren, die kein Hörer sehen kann. Das hilft niemandem weiter.
Ich hab auf dem Bild schon gesagt, dass der Stream ruckelt, weil das Fernsehbild ruckelt.
Dieses Fernsehbild kommt nicht aus dem Internet, deswegen ruckelt es. Ja, früher war das andersrum, da ruckelt das Internet. Mittlerweile kommt das Internet wirklich knallhart, nackt, metallisch geradezu, eher in den Computer rein, während die Fernsehübertragung seitdem echt abgenommen hat.
Das heißt, YouTube kommt nicht übers Internet?
Na ja, gut, das ist ein anderes Thema. Da sind wir jetzt wieder allein. Aber wir wollen unsere Hörer nicht weiter nerven mit Fußball. Das war jetzt einfach nur, um euch ein bisschen Angst zu machen. Aber ich weiß, manche von euch mögen es trotzdem. Und vielleicht sollten wir mal über, es geht auf die EM zu, wir sollten über Fußball-Ups reden und so. Und wir haben jetzt keine Empfehlungen auf dem Tisch. Aber wenn ihr Tipps habt, geile Software und sonstige Tipps zum Mac und Fußball, wir nehmen das auf und wir werden auf jeden Fall eine EM spezial machen.
Hier hat ja jemand gerade gefordert, wir sollen über Eishockey reden. Also ich habe als Kind Eishockey gespielt.
Ja, dann sag mal was Gutes über Eishockey.
Dann hat ein Freund von mir einen Schläger ans Auge geklegt. Und der sah echt fertig aus danach.
Der brutalste Sport ist übrigens Handball.
Handball?
Das hab ich auch mal ein bisschen gemacht.
Handball führt auf jeden Fall alle Hitlisten an, was so Verletzungen betrifft.
Aber man hat nicht so viele Waffen dabei, als auch seinen Pfosten.
Ja, aber du hast auch keinerlei Verteidigung dabei. Ich meine, bei Eishockey redest du mit so einem Helm rum und mit dicker Panzerung.
Ja, eine Theorie, nicht in Russland.
Wieso hast du in Russland Eishockey gespielt?
Na ja, weil ich da gewohnt hab. Und weil alle Eishockey gespielt haben, hab ich auch Eishockey gespielt.
Ah, wo hast du denn da gewohnt? In Dubna, das ist in der Nähe von Moskau.
Das ist so ein kleines www.dubna.ru Das ist ein physikalisches Forschungsinstitut.
Du bist gezüchtet worden, oder was?
Glaubst du, so was Tolles wie ich kommt aus die Tweet-Maschine? Wir zeugen den Twitteros-Hunguculus!
Genau.
Der wird irgendwann mal großartige Tweets in die Welt setzen.
Genau, das war's.
Ich war die Entwaffe gegen die Amerikaner. Aber dann haben die Amerikaner erst einen Katscher gezüchtet und dann hat sich die Sowjetunion aufgegeben. Genau, da ist das auf Google Maps. Da ist ein physikalisches Forschungsinstitut. Mein Vater ist ja Physiker.
Ach, wie romantisch. Und dann hast du da in der russischen Tundra mit deiner Sowjetunion in der Hand die russische Weise gesungen.
Genau so.
Ich war da im Kindergarten und in der Schule. Also dreieinhalb Jahre hab ich da gewohnt.
Wie exotisch!
Toll, oder?
Unglaublich.
Hab ich das ja noch nie erzählt.
Nein, ich wusste nichts. Es ist auch nicht so, dass du jetzt einen besonders russisch klingenden Namen hättest.
Ich bin ja da auch nicht geboren. Ich bin ja auch kein Russe und meine Eltern sind auch keine Russen. Nur gewohnt, drei Jahre lang von 1987.
Ja, hier kommen ja noch die wundersamsten Dinge hoch. Aber vielleicht sollten wir mehr über Max reden. Bleiben wir noch mal kurz bei dem Thema, was wir schon hatten, nämlich die WWDC. Gibt es ja jetzt nicht so viel zu erzählen. Wurde angekündigt und in San Francisco haben sie jetzt alle einen Hals.
Ja, weil die keine Tickets abgekriegt haben. Das ist schon krass, oder?
Die haben es. Ortszeit 7 Uhr?
Ja, fast noch früher. Aber so in der Gegend.
Also für die Deutschen war es eigentlich relativ convenient.
Echte Entwickler noch schlafen. Oder noch nicht schlafen.
Für uns war das wirklich... Ich kam irgendwann in die Nachricht rein, okay, jetzt geht's los. WWDC-Tickets, alle Mann an die Maschinen und dann jeweils aufgerufen. Und dann zuerst mal geguckt, ob man das alle über eine Kreditkarte buchen kann. Und das ging dann aber nicht. Oder über einen Account. Und dann hat da jeder sein Ticket gebucht. Das war echt entspannt. Also es war...
Zwei Stunden später, an der hat es wahrscheinlich keine Chance gehabt.
Die haben auch echt... Letztes Jahr konnte man ja weiterverkaufen. Auf TechCrunch gab es einen Artikel darüber, dass letztes Jahr das bekloppteste, teuerste Ticket für die WWDC ging für 3000 Dollar weg.
Was kostet das denn normal?
1,6 dieses Jahr.
Oder für dreieinhalbtausend Dollar oder sowas. Das ging an Rob von Soundcloud.
Der hatte verpeilt, sich ein Ticket zu kaufen und dann sagt er, auf eBay hat es viel nachspeigert.
Und diesmal ist er aber schon ein bisschen früher dabei. Also jetzt hat er auch ein Ticket.
Ja, der Typ, der da dieses ZFS macht, dieses Cevo, der hatte getwittert, dass er irgendwie bis so spät in die Nacht noch debugged hätte, dass er irgendwie es dann verschlafen hätte.
Der machte einen Call, der hat vorher bei Apple gearbeitet. Also der wird es ja wohl hinkriegen.
Manchmal hat er wenigstens 1600 Dollar gespart.
Der müsste so viele Connections da in der Bude haben. Der sollte ja kein Problem haben, da wieder reinzukommen.
Also die WWDC ist am 11. bis zum 15. Juni, sei ich das richtig? Und du bist vor Ort? Ich gehe davon aus.
Wir haben unseren Reporter vor Ort.
Also wenn unser Terminplan so bleibt, haben wir eine Sendung vorher und eine Sendung nachher.
Harry Hirsch hier live von der WWDC. So ist das immer.
Wir müssen ja mal überlegen, ob wir da irgendwas hinkriegen, Max. Oder meinst du, das geht jetzt so sehr ans Fleisch?
Wir können mal gucken. Also ich meine, versuchen kann man es ja mal, ne? Gut, wir fassen das an.
Das soll wohl letztes Jahr ganz fantastisch gewesen sein. Also das ist kein Problem. Direkt aus der Keynote oder sowas, ich glaube, das können wir total knicken, falls sich überhaupt ein Platz hat.
Nee, nicht so ein Keynote Drama. Überhaupt nichts, was zeitkritisch ist, sondern eher nur so, vielleicht während du noch so halt vor Ort bist und wir auch, sagen wir mal noch, spezifisch Dinge erfragen können, die du dann uns mitbringen kannst. Ich hände gerne noch ein iPhone.
Und noch ein iPhone und noch ein iPhone.
Und guck auf jeden Fall unter deinen Sitz, ne? Weil, wenn du Glück hast, ist da wieder ein iPhone 5 unter den Sitz geklebt.
Die Zeit von der Altszeitkamera.
Da muss man zum Humorhilf machen.
Man tut doch nicht alle Hoffnung kaputt.
Also jetzt, Tim, mach das wieder. Tim wird wieder spendabler.
Haben wir eigentlich schon das Team vorgestellt? Nee, ne?
Ja, hier, Tim ist heute mal wieder mit dabei zu meiner Rechten.
Ja, ausnahmsweise.
Hallo, Tim.
Hallo.
Dann hier zu meiner Linken haben wir den Max.
Hallo. Aus Russland.
Und dann noch ein bisschen weiter links oder auf mir gegenüber sitzt der Roddy. Hallo. Und ich selber hier bin der Dennis. Ja, Darth Vader. Das ist Dennis.
Dennis Vader.
Are you Mr. Stevens?
Darth Ahrens.
Ja, das ist die Runde, das heißt, mit oder ohne Huckel hat sich freigenommen.
Huckel ist beim Erlang-Meeting heute. Weil dieses Erlang ist ja heißer Scheiß.
Er hat da einen schönen Artikel drüber geschrieben.
Ich wurde auch gefragt, ob wir nicht über Erlang reden können.
Ja, wir können jetzt über Erlang reden.
Ich bin voll Huckel.
Du liest es dir gerade an?
Ich hab die letzten zwei Tage mich da mal eingearbeitet, volles Rohr. Und, äh, einfach so. Also eigentlich, wir haben ja hier diesen als CCC, wir betreiben ja da so einen Träger. Der ist ja von einem CCC-Member geschrieben und der ballert ja Pakete raus, was das Zeug hält. Aber der Ansatz war halt, dass der halt Single-Threaded ist, weil der Programmierer gesagt hat, Single-Threaded hat halt den Vorteil, dass man sich dann das Locking spart für die anderen Prozesse. Und Locking kostet schon so, sagen wir mal, ich schätze es jetzt mal so 10-20% Overhead, wenn man das macht.
Je nachdem, was man lockt.
Wie intelligent man das macht, schon richtig. Aber 10% oder 20% wäre auch nicht so schlimm. Selbst 50% wäre nicht so schlimm, wenn du eine zweite CPU raufwürfst, weil dann hast du ja 100% mehr. Oder heutzutage 4, 8, sonst wie viele CPUs. Und das lief ganz lange gut. Aber in letzter Zeit haben wir da so ein bisschen Probleme, weil wir uns auch nie wirklich gekümmert haben, weil es ja so gut lief. Also wir inzwischen kümmern uns gerade ein bisschen. Aber jedenfalls mal hinter der Huckel so, weil der ist jetzt in Erlang so ein bisschen warm, meint auch so ein Trecker, der macht ja eigentlich nicht so viel. Und hat den mal in Erlang angefangen. Und jetzt gibt es da so einen kleinen Battle zwischen, oder wird es demnächst geben, zwischen C-Code und Erlang-Code. Und da hab ich halt mit dem Huckel mal so ein bisschen installiert und gemacht und getan. Und es alles nur so, funktioniert noch gar nicht richtig, aber es hat mich sozusagen ein bisschen heiß gemacht. Und jetzt gucke ich mir das Erlang halt auch mal so ein bisschen an. Mit dem Trecker? Er meinte, er hat das schon mal geschafft, dass sich zwei Kleines gegenseitig finden, aber als wir den dann mal kurz eingesetzt haben, live auf unsere, keine Ahnung, 10 Millionen User. Ich mach das immer so. Da lief das Ding schon, es ist zumindest nicht zusammengebrochen, die Maschine auch nicht, das ging schon, aber ich glaube die Antworten, die waren irgendwie noch nicht so richtig, die da raus kamen für die Weile. Aber da muss man jetzt halt noch so ein bisschen feintunen. Aber, ja.
Da gibt es ja auch viele spezifische Unterschiede bei manchen Kleins und wie die das verpacken und so.
Der Hucke hat erst mal nur mit UDP angefangen, da gibt es eigentlich, da ist alles ziemlich festgenagelt. Da gibt es halt auch gerade dafür in Erlang schön diese Binary-Geschichten, wo man halt sagen kann, diese 32-Bit hätte ich jetzt gerne hier in diese Variable rein und diese 14-Bit, die hätte ich gerne da hin so ungefähr. Das ist alles schon ganz schick.
Bitfield-Parsing und Bitfield-Pattern-Matching.
Genau, und dann kannst du sogar auf Bit-Ebene sogar hier Comprehension machen und so was. Das ist alles eigentlich ganz schick. Und da müsste man halt noch mal ein bisschen nachdrehen und der Hucke hat natürlich auch noch ein bisschen geschummelt bei bestimmten Sachen, die er einfach mal so fixt irgendwie gesetzt hat. Da könnte man noch ein bisschen drehen. Und ich find's halt spannend, mal so zwei verschiedene Technologien gegeneinander antreten zu lassen.
Da bin ich auch sehr gespannt, was das Ergebnis ist. Zumal es da ja auch... Also wie weit wollt ihr das treiben?
Ich find das ja auch ein bisschen so, dass halt, wenn der Hucke das in Erlang macht und Erdgeist heißt der, der den Open Tracker geschrieben hat, werden die sich gegenseitig mit ihren beiden Sprachen und Ansätzen so ein bisschen battlen. Das kann ja am Ende nur einen Gewinner geben. Nämlich der User, der unseren Tracker benutzt. Also den schnellen. Konkurrenz ist immer gut, finde ich.
Auf jeden Fall.
Weil sonst drohen sich die Leute auf ihren Lorbeeren aus.
Haben wir hier eigentlich schon bei Erlang schon mal gesprochen? Ich bin mir gerade geizt.
Nur am Rande, glaube ich.
Der Hucke hat ja diesen Artikel geschrieben. Der Artikel macht einen so ein bisschen warm, aber der erklärt jetzt da drin irgendwie keinen Erlang. Auf smück.org hat er halt einen Artikel über Erlang geschrieben, warum es halb so irgendwie cool ist. Fängt ein bisschen mit irgendwie Ruby an zu erzählen, warum sie bei Ruby so ein bisschen Schwierigkeiten haben oder was ihre Ansätze so für, was war es, Concurrency heißt es so, ja, sind.
Gleichhaltigkeit.
Genau.
Nebenläufigkeit.
Und erzählt halt ein bisschen, was er dann halt da so macht und das inzwischen, wo er sich halt Erlang angeguckt, dass er es nicht bereut und dass er es eher bereut, dass er, weil ich es richtig verstanden habe, dann hat er es irgendwann mal zur Seite geschoben, weil er auch diese Syntax irgendwie, da hat er auch wohl eine Krise bekommen am Anfang und eigentlich...
Findest du die so furchtbar?
Die ist furchtbar, ich find die auch.
Das ist echt alles eine Gewöhnungsfrage.
Nicht so furchtbar, aber sie ist gewöhnungsbedürftig.
Die ist halt komplett anders.
Sie ist anders, das ist das Ding.
Also ein guter Tipp von mir wäre jetzt, dass man Erlang muss man als einen Satz begreifen. Und die kleinste Einheit sind halt Kotzeilen, die werden halt mit Komma getrennt, wie halt Wörter im Satz. Und zwischen den Funktionen, also gleiche Funktionen werden durch einen Semikolon getrennt, sowie Teilsätze und alle Funktionen zusammen, bevor dann die nächste kommt, die werden dann halt mit einem Punkt beendet. Weil dann ist der Satz nämlich zu Ende und dann kommt nämlich eine neue Art von Funktionen. Und so könnte man es ein bisschen erklären, weil so machen die das nämlich da. Ich denke mal damit hat es zu tun mit den Satzzeichen.
Keine Klammern?
Also so wie bei C und ähnliche Sprachen hast du nicht so Blöcke, die du mit einer Klammer aufmachst, dann mit einer Klammer wieder zu.
Mit einer geschweiften Klammer meinst du?
Sondern du hast halt diese Kommas und diese Semikolons und diese Punkte, die an verschiedenen Stellen sind. Am Anfang ist es ein bisschen verwirrend.
Aber wenn du dir das jetzt als den Aufbau als Satz vorstellst, dann sind die Zeilen einzelne Wörter, die Funktionen sind einzelne Teilsätze und das Gesamte ist ein Satz und der wird mit einem Punkt beendet. Das macht dann schon so Sinn.
Ich kompiliere immer und gucke, wo der Fehler ist. Fertig. Und dann muss da irgendwie ein anderes Satzzeichen hin, dann passt das schon. Also das ist irgendwie...
Also es ist auf jeden Fall vom Konzept an, es ist ja auch eine funktionale Programmiersprache. Das heißt, du hast auch Schleifen und so, hast du erst mal nicht so richtig. Du musst es halt mit Rekursion machen. Und dann kommt es auf an, wie du deine Rekursion, wenn du nicht als letztes aufrufst, die Rekursion, sondern vorher und danach noch einen Operator drin hast, dann geht auch dein Stack irgendwie hoch, wie es auch haben wir gestern mal probiert, so haben wir eine Endlostlut erzeugt. Und dachten, naja, okay, du musst jetzt zwar ewig rennen, aber die Rekursion sollte nicht irgendwie ihre Rücksprungadresse auf den Stacker blieben. Aber weil man es halt bei was falsch rumgemacht hat, hat die das doch gemacht. Und dann ist der Speicher halt hochgerast wie blöd.
Sind die Fachausdrücke.
Ach, was davon muss man machen?
Wenn du als aller Letzter...
Deine Rekursion muss das Letzter sein. Dann legt das nicht auf den Stock Stack, sondern dann ruft das einfach nochmal auf.
Dann springt der direkt rein, okay.
Dafür ist dann die Runtime aber auch wirklich optimiert. Und da performt das dann auch einfach enorm.
Ja, ich hab ja über Erlang schon... Ich hab ja früher mal bei Nugget gearbeitet. Diese Werbetargeting-Bude. Und die haben, glaube ich, im Backend alles über Erlang geregelt. Also die konnten dann auch allergut Erlang, die dann waren natürlich dementsprechend. Ich nicht. Ich hab ein bisschen JavaScript-Scheiße gemacht. Aber da ging da irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, 5 Milliarden PIs im Monat drüber oder über deren Server. Das waren auch allerdings einige Server, muss man auch sagen.
Erlang ist schon was für Feinschmecker. Und für Leute, die sich nicht am anschein abstoßen lassen, am ersten zumindest nicht. Und wenn man so ein paar, wenn man so seine Erfahrungen gesammelt hat im Programmieren, dann stößt man, es gibt immer wieder so Bereiche, da lässt man oder es gilt jetzt für viele, nicht alle, aber ich denke eine Menge Leute werden das nachvollziehen können. Es gibt so bestimmte Dinge, da lässt man irgendwie gerne auch die Finger von, weil das ist eklig. Und so Multiprocessing gehört definitiv dazu.
Das macht man nicht gerne.
Ja, weil da hast du es dann erstmal schnell mit Betriebssystemeigenschaften zu tun, da sind die auch sehr unterschiedlich, da sind dann deine Frameworks sehr unterschiedlich. Da hast du dann auch schnell so den Fall, dass dir irgendwelche bekloppten Libraries, die du dir angewohnt hast zu benutzen, dann dir einfach völlig in die Quere kommen, weil sie einfach für diese Gleichzeitigkeit nicht gemacht sind und irgendwann kotzst du, weil du einfach feststellst, wenn dein Environment nicht von vornherein dafür optimiert ist, dann funktioniert das irgendwie nicht wirklich richtig gut und schon gar nicht aus einem Guss. Und dann kommt irgendwie so Erlang, was einfach zu einer extrem interessanten Zeit geboren wurde an einem extrem interessanten Ort. Nämlich wohl zum Zeitpunkt, als diese Unix-Prägung zwar schon sehr fortgeschritten war, aber es auch durchaus noch mal andere Gedanken geben konnte und vor allem mit dieser Anforderung, eine Telefonanlage zu steuern.
86, ne? Ist die Geburtstunde von Erlang.
Und eine Telefonanlage, wenn man sich das halt mal überlegt, was man dafür realisieren muss, das ist halt permanent passiert irgendwas. Du hast so ein Event getrommelt, was dir auf dich einbricht und du musst einfach eine hohe Gleichzeitigkeit haben und vor allem auch eine hohe Unterbrechbarkeit haben. Leute legen Telefonhörer auf und so weiter. Du musst halt irgendwie, wenn der Hörer hochgerissen wird, dann musst du ihm einfach ein Freizeichen spielen. Ein Telefon, wo du ein Hörer abhebst und wo das Freizeichen nach zwei Sekunden kommt, das ist einfach kein Telefon. Die Erwartungshaltung damals zumindest. Mittlerweile ändert sich das ja auch.
Frag mal Cisco und den Voice-over-Epiphone.
Da ist es halt schlimm. Aber wenn auch mit so guten Analogen oder später die ESDN-Welt hat das ja auch noch relativ hochgehalten. Diese Response-Zeiten. Wenn man das gewohnt ist und sowas implementieren will, dann stellst du halt schnell fest, deine Software kommt irgendwie nicht mit. Und vor allem auch Fail-Safety ist auch so ein Ding. Also viel Software funktioniert gut, solange alles okay ist. Und kaum ist dann mal was schlimm, dann ist es auch immer gleich richtig schlimm. Das ist auch so ein wiederkehrendes Ding. Dann ist es immer richtig eklig. Und die Programme sagen dann so, ja, irgendwas ist schiefgegangen. Scheiß drauf, schick mir ne Mail. Ja, so, hier ist mein erkotztes Core-Dump, kack. Mach doch irgendwas da mit und vielleicht gibt es irgendwann mal Hilfe. Aber keine Software ist wirklich darauf ausgelegt, einfach mit dem Fehler zu leben. Und das sind genau die Sachen, die bei Erlang irgendwie drin sind. Diese Gleichzeitigkeit, diese hohe Responsiveness auf irgendwelche Events, diese Fähigkeit, einfach mit vielen parallel zu arbeiten und dabei eben auch diese ganzen Spezifika der Betriebssysteme auszublenden.
Ja, was ich so spannend finde an Erlang ist, dass diese Herangehensweise ja eine komplett andere ist. Du hast in so einer objektorientierten Programmiersprache immer eine Datenstruktur und an der Datenstruktur hängen Funktionen dran, die du benutzt, um die Datenstruktur zu manipulieren. Und in Erlang hast du aber nicht eine Datenstruktur und Funktionen, sondern du hast einen Prozess. Und dieser Prozess hat Funktionen, die er benutzt, um seinen internen State zu modifizieren. Und alles, was du tun kannst, ist, diesen Prozess Messages zu schicken und von diesem Prozess Messages zu bekommen. Das heißt, du hast also in diesem Prozess komplett den State des Prozesses gekapselt und du hast keine Datenstrukturen, die bei mehreren Threads oder Prozessen irgendwie geshared werden. Und da muss man das Hirn erstmal außen rum kriegen um dieses Konzept. Aber es ist schon sehr, sehr spannend, finde ich.
Ich finde, man kann es ganz gut vergleichen. Also diese Anforderungen von Telefonanlagen sind eigentlich die Anforderungen des Internets heutzutage.
Wenn man sich anschaut zu Twitter, etc.
Doch.
Ja, man würde diese Anforderungen liebend gerne an das Internet stellen, aber es wird ihm nicht gerecht.
Die Telefonswitches da, die brauchten zum Beispiel keine Strings. Ich brauche heutzutage schon Strings und man merkt schon, das haben die in Erlang alles später dran geklebt. Und dieses Erlang ist schon ganz schön. Also es hat anscheinend dieses Concurrency-Feature, das ist schon wohl ganz cool. Sonst hätten sie die schreckliche Sprache nicht so aufgeputscht. Aber ich glaube, irgendwann kommt eine Sprache, die das richtig macht mit modernen Ansprüchen und dann wird dieses Erlang weggepustet.
Ja gut, aber die Belastbarkeit und Stabilität von dem Erlang-Könnel, die muss auch erstmal kommen. Und Erlang hat im Prinzip in den letzten Jahren enorme Aufmerksamkeit dazu bekommen. Also da geht es gerade erst richtig los. Aber sie starten halt von robust stabiler Körner und jetzt kommen irgendwie die Features dazu.
Manche merken schon, dass es ganz schön rangepappt ist. Also es wäre schon schön, wenn sie Strings gleich von Anfang an so mit drin gehabt hätten. Also es ist ganz schön, wie sagt man, gewachsen.
Das stimmt. Ich meine, es ist auch nicht die Sprache, die man jetzt für alles empfehlen würde. Aber was ich meine mit dem Vergleich mit Internet, das Freizeichen ist heutzutage die erreichbare Webseite. Wenn du irgendwie www.tralala.return eingibst, google.com, was auch immer, dann erwartest du einfach, dass das Ding da ist. Wenn es drei Sekunden braucht, um irgendwie zu antworten, dann ist der Mensch schon wieder weiter. Das gleiche gilt auch für viele andere Anfragen. Du willst es einfach responsive haben. Und du willst es vor allem failsafe haben. Und du willst es vor allem auch verteilbar haben. Und diese ganze Distribution ist halt bei Erlang von vornherein mit reingedacht.
Ja, das ist eigentlich genial. Dass viele Konzepte, die dann interessant werden, wenn du so ein Problem hast, wo du sagst, failsafe ist nur dann, wenn du mindestens doppelt oder dreifacher Hardware hast. Weil auch deine Hardware kann runterfallen. Dann hast du auf einmal ein verteiltes System und musst ein Software-System bauen, was in der Lage ist, dieses verteilte System zu benutzen. Sodass wenn einer flöten geht, dass die anderen den State behalten. Und Erlang ist so das einzige Konzept, das ich bisher gesehen habe, was das quasi built-in hat. Mir doch egal, auf welcher Hardware, auf welcher Node dieser Prozess läuft, ich schicke dem eine Message. Und solche Sachen. Das ist schon ganz cool. Auch so Sachen wie, dass ein Prozess einen anderen Prozess watchen kann. Und wenn der gewatchte Prozess tot geht, dann geht der andere Prozess mit tot. Erst denkt man sich, was ist das für ein Konzept, dass ein ganzer Baum von Prozessen gleichzeitig stirbt. Aber wenn man sich überlegt...
Das ist wie Unix.
Wenn man sich überlegt, ja, das ist sinnvoll, weil manche Dinge, wenn die tot gehen, will ich das andere Dinge auch mit tot gehen. Ich will mich nicht drum kümmern. Es soll einfach weg sein. Ich mach's neu. Und das geht dann aber auch über Notgrenzen hinweg. Und solche Sachen. Also das ist wirklich so Sachen...
Erlang, ich liebe den Fehler. Also es ist wirklich so, man designt um die Fehler herum. Fehler ist was vollkommen Normales. Das findet einfach permanent statt. Und wenn der Fehler kommt, dann hast du einfach schon deine Software so modular auf Mini-Prozesse runtergemacht, dass es überhaupt gar keinen Schaden nimmt, dass der Prozess dann einfach stirbt. Weil die Stats der anderen Prozesse ändern sich dadurch nicht. Schon wirklich großartig.
Man muss aber schon sein Gehirn ganz schön einmal umdrehen, wenn man da so reinhüpft.
Ja, aber es ist so ein bisschen wie Systemadministration. Also wenn du jetzt so ein System, so ein ganzes Unix aufsetzt mit all seinen Prozessen, dann denkst du doch eigentlich genauso darüber. Ja, der Trecker und so, und was ist, wenn mir der Trecker stirbt, dann muss der ja wieder neu hochfahren und so. Also eigentlich baut man bisher, um schlecht mit Fehler umgehende Programme, baut man eine Systemadministration herum, die versucht diese Fehler wieder auszuhebeln. Und bei Erlang wird man eigentlich ermutigt, von vornherein seine Software genauso schon so zu bauen, dass sie diese ganzen Restarts gleich mit drin hat und eben mit dem Fehler klarkommt. Das ist an der Stelle sehr modern, weil man ist dann eben doch dem System sehr nah und kann eben Multiprocessing etc. die ganzen Sachen dabei noch nutzen. Also ich kann eben nur raten, mal in Erlang, also wenn ihr irgendwie sowieso mal wieder, wenn ihr eure Programmiersprache für dieses Jahr, eure Neue noch nicht gelernt habt, ja dann nehmt doch einfach mal Erlang. Das läuft auch wunderbar, kann man sich auf dem Mac problemlos zusammen compilen.
Runterladen bei Erlang, irgendwie auspacken, Configure, Make, Make.
Also man kann Erlang, die Grundbegriffe, die Sprache als solche, ist nicht übermäßig groß, die kann man an einem Wochenende lernen, würde ich sagen. Also das ist so nicht so umfangreich. Allerdings zu lernen, wirklich damit was Sinnvolles zu tun.
Da man diesen funktionalen Dreh im Kopf hinkriegt, da braucht man wahrscheinlich länger.
Das ist relativ anspruchsvoll.
Gibt's da so brauchbare HTTP-Stacks?
Genau, da gibt's ne Menge Build-in-Functions und da ist schon ne Menge am Start. Was ich halt sagen wollte, ist, über den Blog-Antrag von Huckel, da steht halt drin, das war seine Empfehlung, dass eigentlich das beste Buch ist kein Buch, sondern ist halt ne Webseite. Das heißt Learn New Sam Erlang, hat der Huckel auch letztens gepostet.
Was es jetzt übrigens auch als Buch gibt.
Ja, kann man auch kaufen, aber...
Echt?
Wurde gerade angekündigt. Weiß nicht, ob es schon in Freak Show ist.
Jedenfalls da ist es irgendwie prima, super erklärt alles und mit Beispielen auch immer gleich.
Und mit absurden Zeichnungen dabei.
Und das Schöne bei Erlang ist, man hat halt im Gegensatz, das fehlt mir ja bei Objective-C teilweise so ein bisschen, man hat halt wie bei Python so eine Erlang-Shell. Und du kannst in der Erlang-Shell halt gleich alles, was der auch in seinem Buch da, in seinem Learn New Sam Erlang, was er halt immer so zeigt, kann man auch immer gleich ausprobieren. Und das finde ich eigentlich ganz gut, dass man live so immer ein bisschen was probieren kann.
Es gibt aber irgendwie so ein Programm, wo man das mit Objective-C auch machen kann. Weiß ich jetzt allerdings nicht den Namen. Also vielleicht hat der Chat da eine Idee. Aber es gibt so ein Ding, wo du auch so ein Fenster hast, dann kannst du kurz Objective-C-Code rein tippen und dann macht er das.
Und es gibt auch, mein Kumpel hat hier noch was gefunden, mit dem ich das mache, Erlang Shell in einem Webbrowser. Ich weiß jetzt leider die Adresse nicht, aber ich denke mal, ihr kriegt das rausgefunden, wenn ihr danach sucht. Gibt es auf jeden Fall, da hat jemand irgendwie ein Interface zu einer Erlang Shell im Webbrowser und dann kann man da die Shell benutzen. Das ist auch, glaube ich, Werbung für irgendeinen anderes O'Reilly Buch oder so. Aber kann man auch machen, wenn man jetzt erstmal keinen Erlang sich aufsetzen will, wobei das unter Open Mac zumindest ganz easy geht. Also man lädt das Paket hier runter, Release 15, Update 1 oder wie das Ding heißt.
Also ich hab das über Homebrew installiert und das geht ohne Homebrew.
Ja, braucht man nicht mal. Das kann man direkt so entdecken.
Ja, aber Homebrew hat man ja sowieso.
Ich benutze nur noch Homebrew.
Ja, ich mach auch Homebrew, aber mein Home...
Brew install Erlang fertig.
Ja, wie gesagt, für Leute, die kein Homebrew haben, das geht auch ohne.
Ja, aber einfach Brew installieren und dann Brew install Erlang, Sackretörden und alles ist fertig.
Du hast das Boom vergessen.
Da hat im Chat jemand gefragt, nach dem Editor, den man am besten benutzt. Da bin ich ehrlich gesagt auch noch nicht so richtig.
Ich glaube, das ist auch eine Frage, die man gar nicht beantworten soll, weil das ist halt einfach Geschmackssache. Also manche machen es in Xcode, manche machen es in Eclipse.
Hat Xcode überhaupt ordentlich das Hintags-Highlighting für Erlang?
Weiß ich gar nicht.
Also ich hab jetzt mal dieses Chocolate angeprobiert. Und das hat irgendwie ganz schöne Makros, um so Zeug hinschreiben zu lassen.
So ein Case-Statement.
Hast du das Blimetext mal ausprobiert? Nee, hab ich noch nicht. Das ist im Augenblick der Editor der Wahl.
Der mit dieser Mini-Ansicht an der Seite?
Ja, der mit dieser Mini-Ansicht. Hab ich jetzt auch gekauft, nachdem ich das Sublime... Also da gibt es einen Package-Manager, so einen Standardisierten. Den installierst du dir einmal und dann kannst du so Pakete nachinstallieren. Und die haben wirklich für jeden Scheißdruck. Da gibt es eine C-Lang-Unterstützung, Klang mit Auto-Completion. Den gibt es für Windows, für Linux und für Mac. Fühlt sich aber erstaunlich nativ an. Also ist nicht nativ, aber ist sehr gut. Ist stabil, hat alle Features, die man so braucht. Chocolate und Textmaid 2, wie sie nicht alle heißen, ist ja alles ganz putzig, aber das ist schon noch ein Zacken besser. Da gibt es dann auch so Sachen, weil bei Textmaid 2 gibt es ja so Armaid. Das ist so ein Skript, das installiert man sich auf dem Server. Wenn man eine SSH-Verbindung offen hat, dann kann man auf dem Server so Armaid und dann macht das die auf der lokalen Maschine auf, die Datei. Und das macht dann alles die Community. Also da gibt es dann eher Sub-Eben und das ist wirklich... Kann man eigentlich beliebig lange ohne zu bezahlen nutzen. Er nervt dann hin und wieder mal. Und neulich hab ich dann gesagt, ok, das ist erstmal der Editor, den ich will.
Ja, also Editor ist echt nochmal ein riesen Thema zu Erlang. Weiß ich nicht, also wenn man Bock hat, mal wirklich Software zu schreiben, die geil skaliert, die einfach... Ich meine, ich hab hier meinen iMac hier stehen, der hat irgendwie mal gefühlt 16 Cores am Start.
Wieso nur gefühlt?
Naja, mit halber Aspelling, also acht native Cores. Gefühlt hat er eigentlich zwei Cores, weil halt diese Software das einfach wenig nutzt. Ich kenne nur zwei Programme, die wirklich hier diese Prozessoren richtig fordern. Ja, es gibt wahrscheinlich noch mehr.
Make minus J12 würde ich nutzen.
Handbrake.
Naja, Xcode benutzt eigentlich immer alle Cores.
Gut, benutze ich jetzt nicht so viel, aber Handbrake und Final Cut Pro X.
Ja, Handbrake, das kennen wir auch.
Final Cut Pro X ist auch amazing.
Aber das Problem an Handbrake ist, 16 Cores kann er doch gar nicht auslasten. Also bei mir hat er bei 8 Cores ja schon nicht geschafft, die auszulasten.
Wieso?
Erstens das und zweitens kann er bestimmte Jobs gar nicht kleiner aufteilen. Das geht ja dann irgendwann nicht mehr. Also er kann ja nur auf Frames runterbrechen und ich glaube, dann...
Also wenn ich hier irgendwelche...
Ja, den Film einfach in 16 Teilen untersteigen...
.Avis in ein ordentliches Format bringen will, dann... Wie auch immer, der nutzt auf jeden Fall was und Final Cut Pro X ist so, man startet das und lässt ihm irgendwas rechnen und dann steht er da irgendwie mit 1600 Prozent CPU-Auslastung.
Das ist schon... So muss das sein.
Sachhaltig. Will sagen, es ist eben schwierig, ein Environment zu finden, wo es einfach ist, Multi-Core-Entwicklung zu machen und wo es vor allem auch sehr einfach ist, mal eben nicht nur auf einen anderen Core zu hopsen, sondern auch noch mal auf einen anderen Rechner zu hopsen, wo man eben auch mal die ganze Tätigkeit schnell im Netz verteilen kann. Das bei Erlang halt schnell gemacht, weil man einfach denselben Code auf einen Rechner installiert und dann schickt man da eben seine Messages hin. Und es geht nicht innerhalb des Rechners, sondern eben über das Netz. Und davon merkt man in seiner Software genau nichts.
Und wie gut dieses Verteilfeature sein muss, merkt man ja daran, wie finde ich schon jetzt über den ersten Blick. Also muss ich erstmal noch ein bisschen mehr gucken, aber wie schlecht gewisse andere Sachen in Erlang sind. Und da kann man schon sehen, dass dieses Verteilen so richtig, richtig gut sein muss, weil damit nur an alle anderen kleinen Problemchen irgendwie in Kauf. Und ja, also wie gesagt, Syntax ist erstmal ein bisschen gewöhnungsbedürftig, schwierig und teilweise vielleicht auch nicht so konsistent, wie man es so sagen würde. Aber ja, da gewöhnt man sich auch dran. Und das gibt es ja auch in allen Sprachen so ein bisschen.
Was mich total nervt, ist der Debugger. Also der nervt mich echt, weil keine Ahnung, vielleicht ist es jetzt besser geworden mit der R15, aber der ist mir immer abgestürzt, wenn ich da irgendwie Fenster vergrößert hab. Also das ist irgendwie, der ist so ganz schick und was halt so geil ist, er macht für jeden Prozess ein neues Fenster auf. Das ist irgendwann ist wirklich, es sind da nur noch Fenster. Da sind da nur noch Fenster, weil du so viele Prozesse hast. Also ja, aber eigentlich ist er ganz schick, aber der nervt mich.
Haben wir das durch? Wollen wir mal über Apple reden?
Ich hab ja ne App jetzt. Das ist ja nicht meine.
Zu Apps kommen wir später. Über das Weltgeschehen.
Weltgeschehen?
Also reden über AppLE und nicht AppS. Die kommen später.
Lass uns über AAPL reden. Ja, keine Ahnung, was es da viel zu erzählen gibt, aber ich wollte es zumindest mal erwähnen hier. Sagen wir mal, wieder das Quartalsgewitter über uns hereingebrochen.
Das war ja total enttäuschend.
Ja, total.
Nur, wie viele iPads die Sekunde?
Pro Sekunde habe ich es nie ausgerechnet.
Viele.
Naja, pro Sekunde nicht.
Aber Apple generiert 6,4 Millionen Dollar Cash pro Stunde.
Pro Stunde?
Pro Stunde.
Millionen Dollar pro Stunde.
6, ja, so 120 Millionen Dollar am Tag.
Naja, weil sie ja da so Milliarden.
Also wenn es 6,4 sind, dann eher 153 pro Tag. Ja, aber jetzt brauchen wir nicht auf die eine oder andere Million achten.
Ach guck einer an. Also siehst du, da bin ich ja wieder ein bisschen beruhigt. Die Laune steigt, sehr schön. Wenn man sich hier den Abwehrkurs anguckt, da war er gestern noch runtergesackt bis 420 Euro sind das jetzt hier. Weil die haben ja alle Schiss gehabt, dass jetzt die Zahlen so was von schlecht sind, weil Wolfsburg hat ja gesagt, oh Gott, das können die alles nicht erfüllen. Und dann kamen die Zahlen und schwupp ist der Kurs wieder hoch auf 465. Das heißt, das sind 10% Gewinn hätte man von gestern zu heute machen können.
Ist geil, die haben immer so viel Angst, da wäre das mal die Gelegenheit, Aktien zu kaufen und gleich wieder zu verkaufen. Immer wenn sie alle so Angst haben, oh Gott, wird das Apple weiterhin gut gehen? Denn wir wissen ja, Apple wird es immer besser gehen.
Man gibt ja auch peak Apple. Ja, also übrigens auch die Leute, die sich immer so, weil wir ja irgendwie vom Klondack erzählen und von unseren Zeiten, als wir noch irgendwie 8N1 einstellen mussten und so, ihnen müssen auch immer nicht alles ganz so ernst sein, wir müssen ja auch mal ein bisschen ins Westnetz stechen, damit irgendwie mal Leute sich provoziert und gefordert fühlen und mal ein bisschen Themen aufgekratzt werden, damit da mal was bei rauskommt.
Genau, dass der Arsch nicht mal so zugekniffen ist.
Genau, also wenn ihr euch ein bisschen über uns aufregt, dann finde ich, haben wir alles richtig gemacht. Ja, ich meine sonst könnt ihr euch auch das Wetter von morgen angucken, wenn ihr es spannend haben wollt.
Oder Fußball.
Ja, was ist denn jetzt Fußball hier?
Ich weiß nicht, irgendwie ist ja...
Die Bayern, da hab ich jetzt richtig verstanden, dass die Dortmunder jetzt den Pokal gewonnen haben, bevor die Saison zu Ende ist. Ja, die Bundesliga. Ist das nicht der Pokal?
Das ist die erste Bundesliga-Pokal.
Aber was ist denn das, was die kriegen, wenn die erste Bundesliga gewinnen?
Die Schale.
Schale?
Noch mal ein kurzer Einwurf. Fußball. Es gibt im Wesentlichen drei Dinge, die man so gewinnen kann pro Saison. Die Meisterschaft, den Pokal.
Was ist der Pokal?
Der Pokal ist ein K.O.-System. Alle Mannschaften der ersten, zweiten und dritten Bundesliga treten gegeneinander an. Wer am Schluss alle Spiele gewonnen hat, kriegt den Cup. Meisterschaft ist Ligasystem.
Das heißt, jeder gegen jeden.
In der Bundesliga 18 Mannschaften, jeder gegen jeden zweimal.
Und was gewinnt man da?
Scheibe.
Scheibe? Was gewinnt eine Scheibe?
Wie heißt das offiziell?
Kennt ihr diese IT-Crowd-Folge?
Schale, weiß nicht, Teller?
Schale, keine Ahnung.
Halt so ein Brett da, so ein Teil.
So ein riesiges rundes Teil, was wahrscheinlich total schwer ist, weil relativ viele Silber drin sind.
Kennt ihr diese IT-Crowd-Folge, wo sich der eine Typ beliebt macht, indem er so dreieinhalb Sprüche über Fußball auswendig lernt und plötzlich bei allen anerkannt ist? Das eine an dieser Sprüche ist, der Pokal hat seine eigenen Regeln. Das kannst du immer sagen.
Wenn irgendjemand was zum Pokal sagt, sagst du, du wirst uns alle werden nicken. Das stimmt, das kann ich bestätigen.
Das ist dann in der übersetzten IT-Crowd, oder wie?
Nee, das ist mir so aufgefallen, dass man immer so, der Pokal hat seine eigenen. Ich hab keine Ahnung, was bedeutet.
Für den gemeinen Nerd ist das wirklich ein wichtiges Rüstzeug, um einfach auch in etwas nerdfeindlichen Umgebung zu überleben. Du kannst einfach immer so einen generellen Kommentar machen, der sich irgendwie auf Fußball bezieht. Und alle werden sofort Ja sagen. Das ist geil.
Kann man das nicht den Fußball-Fans auch empfehlen? So, Junix hat seine eigenen Regeln.
Erlang auch.
Erlang hat seine eigenen Regeln.
Er ist ja auch nicht mehr das, was man war. Keine Ahnung, was müsste man denn da so sagen, wo Nerds immer sofort nicken?
Wahrscheinlich geht das auch umgekehrt. Ja, stimmt.
Aber was wäre das?
Die Regeln so für...
Was ist so das Allgemeinste vom Allgemeinen? Ich meine, wenn ihr jetzt das eine oder andere basht, dann hängt es ja davon ab, an wen du gräst. Aber wo sagen wir auch, der gemeine Windows-Nerd? Ah, ich weiß einen. Platten sind sowieso immer voll.
Ja, RAM kann man nie genug haben.
Ich sag ja mal, viel RAM, viel gut.
Don't touch a running system.
Über Lebensstrategien für Non-Nerds.
Die Linux-Community ist ja sehr heterogen.
Das wäre jetzt hier ein Podcast, der sich ausschließlich an so Nerds wendet. Hier gibt es auch aktive Lebenshilfe für Leute, die eben jetzt nicht als kleiner Junge oder Mädchen in den Topf gefallen sind.
Da gab es ja auch diesen Artikel, den ich leider nicht gelesen habe, von dem Typen, der sich bei den Piraten eingeschleicht hat und mal so einen Insider-Bericht von den Piraten. Das war eigentlich ganz lustig, weil er meinte, dass es unglaublich ist, welche Tools man alle bedienen können muss, um bei den Piraten überhaupt akzeptiert zu werden. Und überhaupt dieses Liquid-Feedback kann ja keiner bedienen und weiß ja teufel was. Und dass das schon alles technisch relativ herausfordernd ist für so den normalen Menschen. Also an der Usability müssen sie offensichtlich ja arbeiten, die Piraten.
Ja, auch unabhängig davon ist einfach die ganze Komplexität, was greift in was ein und so. Na gut, lasst uns bitte nicht über Piraten reden. Ich hab das Thema irgendwie in jedem Podcast.
Gibt es da irgendwas noch zu berichten?
Über die Quartalzahlen? Ich weiß nicht. Es ist eigentlich irgendwie alles so, wie es in den letzten Quartalen auch war.
Also das Einzige, was ich interessant fand, war, was Cook zum Thema MacBook Air und iPad gesagt hat. Nämlich so viel wie On merging the iPad and Mac, anything can be forced to converge Cookset, but products are trade-offs. You can converge a toaster and a refrigerator, but those things are probably not going to be pleasing to the user. Und das, finde ich, ist einfach mal eine Ansage.
Das stimmt. Da ist er auch wirklich auf eine interessante Art und Weise in die Fußstapfen von Ola Steve gestapft.
Ja, also und das zeigt halt auch, dass irgendwie Apple wirklich das iOS und das Mac OS als zwei unterschiedliche Paar Schuhe sieht. Und ja, ich finde das positiv.
Braucht sich nur, was das bedeutet für den Mac.
Also irgendwo war hier auch...
Im Chat hatten, glaube ich, ein paar Angst, dass das bedeutet, dass sie nie 3G kriegen werden. Ich glaube, damit hat das so jetzt nicht direkt was zu tun.
Also irgendwo war so eine Torte aufgemalt, womit sie denn jetzt ihren Umsatz oder Gewinn, weiß ich nicht mehr, genau gemacht haben. Und da war das iPhone-Stück schon bedenklich groß. Das war fast die halbe Torte von dem, was sie so gemacht haben. Und das ist natürlich was, wo man dann sagt so, dass ob das dann negativ sich auf den Mac auswirkt.
Na also, nunmal wahrscheinlich die Grafik von Asymko. Die ist ja immer...
Ja, was soll sich da negativ auswirken? Ich meine, ohne Mac geht es auch mit dem iPhone nicht so richtig. Wer schreibt die Programme zum Beispiel?
Jetzt gibt es ja das erste Spiel fürs iPad, das auf dem iPad geschrieben ist. Habe ich auch noch nicht immer ausprobiert. Aber ganz schön sein.
Ich weiß, was du meinst, das iPhone ist im Wesentlichen das, was dazu führt, dass der Zuwachs von Gewinn und Umsatz so irre groß ist. Obwohl das iPad da sich anstellt, das sozusagen noch zu übertreffen. Also es ist durchaus davon auszugehen, dass das iPad in zwei, drei Jahren noch sehr viel mehr diese Accelerationen befördert, als es das iPhone jetzt schon tut.
Ja, Tim hat ja wohl irgendwie auch gemeint, ja ja, wir hoffen, dass wir in den nächsten Wochen endlich mal unsere Lieferengpässe in den Griff kriegen.
Ja, sie können die Scheiße einfach nicht so schnell bauen.
Nicht so schnell bauen, wie sie es aus den Händen gerissen bekommen.
Ich hoffe, das würde ich gerne mal bei den Macs hören. Ich finde ja immer noch, naja, wir sind Außenseiter, wir sind isoliert.
Wahrscheinlich sind wir inzwischen Außenseiter, aber trotzdem ist da irgendwie so dieses Auf- oder Unter-den-Tisch-Stellen-Rechner, den ich nicht mitnehme, so irgendwas, da fehlt irgendwie was. Da ist so...
Ob es so eine Renaissance von Desktop-Rechnern geben wird, weil die Leute wandern in Richtung iPad ab? Vielleicht brauchen sie dann auch gar keinen Laptop mehr und stellen sich zu Hause das Fest das hin.
Ja, aber warum sollten wir das machen?
So weil es rock'n'roll ist. Also hast du schon mal auf einem Mac Pro irgendwie gearbeitet? Also dagegen kannst du diese schnellsten Laptops hier in die Tonne treten.
Schon lange nicht mehr, da hieß er noch G5.
Ja, also Desktop sind immer noch mal reichlich schneller als hier so eine Kiste. Und wenn man halt anspruchsvolle Sachen macht...
Ja, aber Leute wollen nicht schneller, sondern schnell genug.
Ich will schneller immer.
Und sie wollen auch anfassen und so. Das iPad wird gewinnen. Also das iPad hat eigentlich schon längst gewonnen. Also sie verkaufen mehr iPads als HP Computer verkaufen.
Also mein Kumpel ist über unglückliche Zustände... Zufälle, Zufälle, was, wie? Egal. Es ist jedenfalls so ein alter Mac Pro irgendwie. Ist zu ihm gekommen von 2008. Und das Ding rockt sowas von fett, also es ist unglaublich.
Ich hab hier auch meinen 2009er.
Und der geht doch ab und zu, oder nicht?
Der ist frisch gepimpt. Ja, ich bin nicht in der Lage, das Teil auszureizen mit irgendwas.
Aber ist doch cool.
Ich hab jetzt hier, ich hab so eine RAM-Spende bekommen. Aber da lag so RAM rum.
RAM kann man ja nie genug haben.
Genau das dachte ich mir auch! Kannst du meine Gedanken lesen? So, und dann rieselt mal so eben hier so 8-4-Gigabyte-Module irgendwie in diese Büchse rein.
8-4-Gigabyte?
Das müsst ihr euch jetzt mal auf der Zunge zergehen lassen. Dieser Computer hat 32 Gigabyte RAM.
Gülb.
Und ich dachte mir so, das muss ich mir jetzt visualisieren. Wie viel ist denn das jetzt eigentlich? Weil ich habe jeglichen Bezug...
18 Fußballfelder...
.irgendwie dazu verlor...
Um mir jetzt den Bezug zu Fußballfeldern zu stellen.
Aber sag mal mal ehrlich, was hast du das 4x8 jetzt? Wie viel würde denn ein Achter überhaupt kosten? Also davon abgesehen, dass du das ja jetzt ja anscheinend auch irgendwie...
Ein Achter? Nee, 8x4 habe ich.
8 oder 8x4. Was würde denn ein Vierer kosten überhaupt? 10 Euro? 20?
Was, ein Riegel?
Kostet doch nichts mehr.
Oh, das ist ECC...
Du gehst heutzutage in den Bäcker, kaufst so wie vier Brötchen und die geben dir einen Viererriegel mit.
Das wechselt gilt als Ramm.
Nee, nee, nee, das kostet mehr. Ich guck mal kurz.
Ja, so ein bisschen was kostet es schon noch, also ich mein...
Aber nicht wirklich.
Arbeitsspaliger...
Jokel hat doch letztens erzählt, dass irgendwie auch 16 GB für das Laptop jetzt auch nur so circa 100 Euro kosten für beide Riegel. Also im Laptop 16 GB, ich kriege ja die 8 hier nicht mal voll.
Das ist ja das Eigentliche, dass ich hier echt vermisse, mehr RAM im MacBook Air. Na, das ist ähm...
Wie viel hast du denn drin?
4, aber es geht halt.
Mach mal 8 rein, was geht?
Kannste keine 8 rein machen.
Also man kann gar nichts rein machen, weil... Ah, keine Module, verstehe. Weil sonst, Apple sagt ja mal hier, gehen 8 rein, weil gibt es gerade 8, aber wenn es halt die größeren Module gibt, dann gehen die da auch rein und dann passt es auch.
Guck mal, wie soll denn hier so ein RAM-Modul reinpassen, dieses dünne Ding?
Ja, meistens geht das bei dem aktuellen Mac Pro oder ich glaube sogar bei dem hier sogar noch, da ist nachgewiesen worden, dass hier sogar 128 GB reingeht. Das haben sie dadurch festgestellt, dass sie das mit Windows gefahren haben. Weil da würden die auch 128 auch erkannt. Mac OS X erkennt nur 96.
Aber Windows schafft doch nur, wie war das, 128 GB bei einer Platte? Das war doch auch mal so eine Grenze.
Die hatten öfters mal so eine Grenze.
Wahrscheinlich hätten sie jetzt mehr RAM auch nicht erkannt, weil sie den RAM und Festplatte genauso benutzen. Sagen wir mal nicht ganz so. Ich versage gerade da drin, hier mal den Speicher zu gucken. Also hier ECC DDR3 PC3 RAM. 32 Euro. Na wie auch immer. 32 GB RAM. Das ist die ganze Zeit, hier Das die, hier Das die hier habe Das die Zeit hier habe Das die Zeit hier habe Das die Zeit hier habe. Und der Safari-Web-Content, der reißt mal hier so 3 GB gerade hier auf dieser Büchse.
Oh, ist tatsächlich nix grün, sondern irgendwie 60-70% ist blau, was heißt Plattencache.
Inactive. Na ja gut, ich meine, das ist ja...
So muss es sein.
Das heißt, der läuft auch schon eine Weile, ne?
Ja, das finde ich auch eine gute Anwendung. Also mal so, wie Plattencache zu haben, wie man bis vor kurzem noch nicht mal Platten hatte, die so groß waren.
Ich habe hier 256 GB, das ist allerdings auch eine SSD.
Ja, das ist hier auch drin.
256 GB SSD?
Ne, 320. Also ich kann hier sozusagen ein Zehntel meiner Platte cashen.
Was hast du denn drin, so eine Intel 310er Serie?
20er. Also dieser Rechner idelt. Das ist, ich kann gar nicht so viel tun.
Ja, schnell Erlang lernen.
Ja, aber der ist ja auch drei Jahre alt mittlerweile.
Rockt wie Sau, oder? Stell dir vor, du, Apple würde jetzt mal einen aktuellen rausbringen. Also ich würde, weil ich ja einen Laptop hab, wenn ich irgendwie bei einer dicken Bude anfangen würde und die sagen, was willst du für einen Rechner zum Arbeiten haben, dann würde ich sagen, hier stellt mir so ein Mac Pro hin.
Ok, gut, aber wir waren ja eigentlich bei dieser ganzen iOS- und Mac-Geschichte und diesem Konferenz-Crawl. Gab es da eigentlich sonst noch interessante Feststellungen?
Ja, das halt wieder so...
Das mit dem Toaster wäre natürlich auch lustig, ne? Auf Twitter gab es dann auch gleich ToasterFrench irgendwie als Account, der dann irgendwie anfing zu plappern.
Gegen Tim Cook?
Nicht unbedingt gegen, aber die Idee wurde einfach mal lustig aufgegriffen. Nicht, dass das jetzt...
There is a very good market for the MacBook Air and we continue to innovate in that product. Kannst dir Hoffnung machen. Vielleicht kriegst du da doch noch...
Ja, das wird ein 5.02 mit 3G, 4G, 5G. Chip.
Ja, ich meine, wenn sie irgendwie Nachhilfe brauchen beim Innovaten...
Sollen sie einfach mal anrufen, ne?
Brauchen sie sich nur unsere letzten Sendungen durchzuhören, da ist eigentlich alles drin.
Na, MacBook Pro Air sag ich nur.
Ich meine, was sollen sie jetzt außer läuft länger? Also da könnten sie auf jeden Fall was reißen. Also mal so eine Akkuleistung, Verdoppelungen, fänd ich jetzt schon mal ganz angemessen. Ich will auch 10 Stunden mal arbeiten. Aber ich weiß, so viel Akku wie sie ins iPad reinpacken, kriegen sie ja gar nicht rein, ne? Mit der Tastatur.
Also ich bin mit der Akku-Laufzeit von dem Ding extrem zufrieden.
Wenn sie den nicht dicker machen...
Hältst du eine Sendung hier problemlos durch?
Eine Sendung. Echt? Drei Stunden. Das ist doch nix, drei Stunden.
Aber es ist wirklich problemlos. Danach ist er nicht leer, sondern...
Also meiner ist immer nach drei Stunden leer.
Nee, meiner nicht.
Also der ist jetzt halb voll, wobei ich jetzt auch gerade Erlang installiert habe, was ein paar Minuten gebildet hat. Also das saugt natürlich dann immer ganz schön, wenn man den Prozess auch auslastet, aber so im ganz normalen Eidl. Krass war es gestern, also ich hab gestern auch hier mit Johnny von Spreeblick haben wir einen Podcast gemacht, WMR zusammen, als Gast. Und da lief der nebenbei und ich hab hin und her mal drauf geguckt und wir haben dreieinhalb Stunden Sendung gemacht und danach war der noch bei 95% Akku.
Warst du so ein Wunderer?
Ich hab den auch nicht viel genutzt. Ich hab den halt so, der stand offen da, war nur im Sleep, also nicht im Sleep-Modus, sondern halt so im Stand-By. Und das Display war auch sehr lange aus und immer wenn ich ihn mal brauchte, so ein bisschen rumsurfen, hab ich ihn rausgeholt.
Dreieinhalb Stunden und dann 95%? Das ist ja auch komisch.
Ich hab den halt nicht viel gebraucht, aber so als Stand-By gerät.
Vielleicht ist deine Akku-Anzeige kaputt.
Ja, meine Akku-Anzeige kaputt, aber er hat danach noch lange durchgehalten, das fand ich schon ganz okay.
Du hast auch die 13 Zoll Version und du die kleinere, aber ja, die 11 Zoll.
Ja gut, die hat natürlich auch noch ein bisschen weniger Akku. Aber ich will da einfach 3G.
Also 4G wäre toll.
5G ist mir egal, Hauptsache G.
G mit Gott, aber G.
Noch was Nettes fand ich, was Tim gesagt hat, nämlich, dass ihm diese ganze Patentscheiß auf den Sack geht. Also es ist jetzt sehr paraphrasiert, aber dass er gesagt hat, also eigentlich würde er sich lieber mit den anderen jetzt gütlich einigen statt hier ständig irgendwie vor das Gericht zu ziehen. Aber die sollen verdammt noch mal ihr eigenes Zeug erfinden. Das fand ich irgendwie auch cool.
Steht ja so in der Tradition eigentlich der Aussagen, wie sie auch früher mal getroffen wurden, außer dass jetzt nicht mehr von Thermonuclear War ist so. Das schenkt er sich.
Damals auch nicht der Fall.
Ich hab so das Gefühl, also ich weiß nicht, dass so Tim Cook mehr so sagt, was er denkt. Also wenn der das so sagt, dann kann man ihm das so direkt glauben. Bei Steve habe ich immer so das Gefühl, wenn er was sagt, dann ist da immer ein Spin dabei. Der sagt nur etwas, um irgendwas zu erreichen. Hat man bei Steve immer das Gefühl gehabt. Und bei Tim hat man so das Gefühl, wenn der das so sagt, dann denkt er das halt so. Und wenn der was nicht sagen will, dann hält er halt den Mund. Aber wenn er was sagt, dann ist das so.
Wobei allein sein Kommentar jetzt mit dem Toaster Fridge, dürfte wahrscheinlich die Erwartungshaltung in Windows...
Ach stimmt, das war die Ansage gegen...
Na er hat über Windows geredet.
Ach so, er hat sogar über Windows geredet.
Nein, nein, er hat nicht über Windows geredet.
Ja, ja, es ist mir jetzt erst gerade bewusst geworden.
Ja klar, das ist das, wovon er redet.
Hier steht noch, on converging the Mac and the iPad cook said, we are not going to that party, others might.
Genau, das ist...
Also es geht schon.
Klar, natürlich ist es ein Heap auf Windows 8. Und natürlich legt er auch den Finger genau in die Wunde, dass du da zwei Oberflächen hast, die eines toucht, die andere maus. Und dann packst du beides in ein Gerät und hinterher ist niemand mehr zufrieden. Weil er hat dann weder einen Kühlschrank, noch einen Toaster, sondern nur noch ein Ding, was Strom verbraucht, aber nichts mehr tut, nichts Sinnvolles mehr.
Ich frage mich wirklich, was... was der Impact sein wird von Windows 8. Ich habe so eine Vermutung. Ich weiß bloß nicht, ob die realistisch ist.
Out of existence?
Siegler hat ja bei TechCrunch einen Artikel dazu geschrieben, den ich ganz schlau fand. Er meinte, dass Microsoft jetzt zu einer reinen Enterprise-Firma, die sich an Geschäftskunden wendet, nach und nach muttieren wird. Weil in dem Bereich sind sie nach wie vor sehr, sehr stark.
Im Sinne von, dass das das ist, was sie wollen? Oder im Sinne von, das ist das Einzige, was ihnen übrig bleibt?
Na wahrscheinlich eher Letzteres. Der PC-Markt wird aufhören, wird an Bedeutung weiter verlieren. Also der Endanwender-Markt sozusagen, der Endkunden-Markt, Unterhaltungsmarkt. Aber in diesem ganzen Firmenkundenbereich sind sie ja nach wie vor stark. Klar, da ist iPad und iPhone als Gerät schon da. Aber die Leute werden halt an irgendwelche Billig-PCs gesetzt. Und da wird auch Windows 8 möglicherweise mal deployt oder Windows 9 drauf. Also ich glaube, Windows 8 wird es eher nicht so werden, weil dem gebe ich echt keine große Zukunft. Und da werden sie auch noch eine Weile in der Tür bleiben. Und wenn du da einmal drin bist, dann steigst du auch nicht so schnell um. Insofern...
Ja, aber auf der anderen Seite, ich meine, dieses Windows 8, das können sie doch nur an Endkunden loswerden. So die Leute, die gerade verfügbar an all die PC kaufen und da ist halt drauf, was da drauf ist und fertig.
Ja, das ist glaube ich auch die letzte Chance nochmal. Oder ist dann vielleicht der Versuch nochmal in den Commissionermarkt mit Gewalt reinzudrücken. Aber wenn das schief geht, dann wird das wahrscheinlich... Was bleibt denen da ein Groß anderes übrig?
Das klingt aber so ein bisschen nach RIM, die ja auch gesagt haben, sie wollen sich jetzt auf den...
Er hat es mit IBM verglichen und IBM verdient... die waren früher auch mal im Endkundenbereich tätig ein Stück weit und haben sich dann irgendwann komplett auf dieses Corporate zurückgezogen und verdienen da gutes Geld und sind glücklich und weiß der Teufel was und hat ja auch niemand was dagegen und dass es Microsoft dann ähnlich gehen wird. Fand ich nicht so abwegig.
Bei dem Ausblick waren wir ja auch schon vor zwei Jahren schon mal.
Ja und das ist witzig und das geht näher dran.
Ja ich glaube auch, also ich frage mich nur, wie wird dieser Impact sein? Wann wollen Sie das jetzt vorstellen? Kommt das noch dieses Jahr?
Oktober soll es wohl rauskommen, oder?
Oktober, also nächstes Jahr.
Ja, irgendwie in ein paar Monaten wollen Sie irgendwie die Final Preview Beta irgendwas bringen.
Anfang Juni oder wann war das?
So, und dann wird wahrscheinlich einfach gar nichts passieren. Also das ist so ein bisschen meine Erwartung.
Die Grillen, Zirpen, Tangleweed.
Die Pandits und Fanboys, die werden das natürlich erstmal, oh das beste Windows ever, lalalala. Weil, keine Ahnung, unten ein Button jetzt anders aussieht. Und dann wird das irgendwie verhallen.
Das erste, was passieren wird, ist folgendes. Sobald Windows 8 fertig ist und auf die Geräte soll, wird Microsoft für alle anderen Lizenzen den Preis erhöhen und den für Windows 8 den Preis beibehalten, sodass die Integrator, die PC's schon immer verkauft haben, diese Büchsen-Schieber, Windows 8 drauf machen, weil alle anderen Windows-Versionen nämlich teurer sind. Dann wird es sechs Wochen lang, oder vielleicht nicht mal so lange, vier Wochen lang passieren, dass diese neuen Windows-PCs dann ausgeliefert werden, bis ein Riesenaufschrei kommt. Das kann man ja alles gar nicht benutzen. Und dann wird Microsoft zurückrudern, so nach der Art, wenn man eine Windows-8-Lizenz hat, kann auch Windows 7 installieren oder ein Downgrade für irgendeinen Preis oder so.
Wie das mit Vista und XP war.
Ich sehe schon ein Computerbild.
Genau das wird passieren.
So machen Sie Windows 8 zu Windows 7. Die besten Tipps, wie man das Startmenü wieder zurückbekommt.
Natürlich wird das passieren. Natürlich wird Microsoft versuchen, allen Kisten-Schiebern dieses Zeug überzuhelfen, dass das aus der Tür kommt, dass sie da Stückzahlen raushaben.
Das wollen die Kisten-Schieber ja auch, weil die wollen ja mit Windows 8 werben. Weil es ja schon so hot news hängen und Leute, die einen Rechner neu kaufen, haben ja eh erstmal höchstwahrscheinlich keine Ahnung, weil sie kaufen ja gerade einen Rechner neu.
Also wer kauft heutzutage das erste Mal einen Rechner noch? Nee, ich kenne total viele Leute, die sagen, Windows 7, Windows Vista kommt mir nicht aufs Gerät. Ich nehme mein XP weiter, da kenne ich alle Probleme, die da auftreten, ich will nicht upgraden, da muss ich alles wieder neu lernen. Ich kann es auch verstehen, wenn man diesen Schmerz-XP erstmal internalisiert hat und damit irgendwie gelernt hat, umzugehen und zu leben, dann hat man natürlich Angst vor dem nächsten Schmerz. Das ist irgendwie so, ja, das sind halt alles Gewaltverbrechensauffahrt.
Im Chat melden sich gerade die XP-Nutzer und andere, die XP-Nutzer als Ignoranten beschimpfen. Wobei ich, also Windows 7 ist okay, kann man mitarbeiten. Also wenn man Windows mag, dann kommt man mit Windows 7, glaube ich, gut klar. Dennis, du hattest ja auch hier schon mal irgendwie von deinem...
Ich hab zu Hause ein Windows 7, das läuft.
Also ich halte es auch für das bessere Windows und ich empfehle auch jedem, nimm Windows 7. Also, ich meine, was soll das? Aber klar, die Leute haben halt Angst davor.
Ja, wollen wir mal, also gucken wir erst mal, was da so kommt. Vielleicht ist Windows 8 ja voll toll, wurde da gerade ein Tor geschossen, seh ich das richtig?
Naja, das zweite schon. Bayern ist schon so gut wie draußen. Real Madrid.
Naja, es wird schon noch.
Nein, sind raus.
Nicht?
Keine Chance.
Doch, Klose kommt gleich und ballert erst mal ein paar Tore rein.
Klose?
Ist ja noch bei Bayern.
Spaltechnisch wärst du echt XP.
Naja, es ist mir auch so ein bisschen egal, da muss ich sagen.
Naja, wir haben ja eigentlich keine Ahnung. Was ich ganz interessant fand, ist, dass sie immer wieder so eine richtig schön komplizierte Matrix rausgebracht haben, was sie jetzt alle so für Windows rausbringen wollen. Das war ja dann irgendwie Windows.
Ja, es ist weniger geworden, ne?
Es gibt jetzt drei, aber die gibt es bestimmt dann auch nochmal in zehn verschiedenen Aufsplitterungen.
Ja, aber Vista waren doch sieben, oder? Habe ich das richtig in Erinnerung? Brauchen wir noch sieben Stück.
Oder 50.
Also wenigstens das haben sie gelernt.
Setvans, Multi, Extra, Pro, Plus, Extended Package.
Naja klar, sie wollen den Markt segmentieren und die wollen natürlich die Professionals, wollen sie halt mehr melken und dem User, dem Heim-User, wollen sie es trotzdem überhelfen.
Ja, aber jetzt haben sie auch dieses obskure Windows RT.
Ja, was ist das denn?
Das ist das, was auf ARM läuft.
Windows 8 für ARM?
Und warum heißt das RT?
Das hab ich auch noch nicht verstanden.
Wegen Realtime wahrscheinlich.
Und das andere hakelt so sehr, dass das so geht?
Ja, ich meine, Windows auf ARM ist doch schon ewig alt und das hieß, glaube ich, auch schon mal Windows RT oder so. Also das ist irgendwie, vielleicht ist das auch ein anderer Kernel, wer weiß.
Es hieß schon mal Windows RT?
Nein, es hieß mal Pen Windows, dann hieß es irgendwie, wie hieß es denn dann? Pocket Windows, dann hieß es whatever, also dieses kleine Windows halt. Keine Ahnung, ich kenn mich ja da auch nicht so aus, aber...
Ja, aber was soll das, wofür steht dieses RT? Das klingt auch so technoid.
Rippen total, was weiß ich.
Real Tablet.
Randgruppentablet Windows.
Ja, ich mein die einzige Qualität ist, dass es sich dabei um das Windows 8 handelt, wo was für arm ist, aber wo sie dann doch noch irgendwie diese Desktop Apps mit dabei haben oder wie?
Na die haben halt zwei verschiedene User Interfaces. Das hab ich ja schon mal erzählt, nämlich diese Teils und das wollten sie eigentlich zuerst machen, dann haben sie festgestellt, dass sie mit den Teils das nicht so richtig hinkriegen.
Aero, ja.
Und dann haben sie so dieses, ne Aero ist schon lange, das ist jetzt schon wirkt.
Metro, das mit den Teils heißt Metro. Aero ist doch der Nachfolger von Luna, oder?
Ja, was auch immer.
Genau.
Und dann haben sie festgestellt, dass sie da hier ihr Office, dass sie das darauf nicht zum Laufen kriegen. Und was wäre ein Microsoft-Gerät ohne Office drauf? Wahrscheinlich läuft Office sogar auf der Xbox.
Ein Sägen wäre das.
Und darum haben sie dann eben noch zusätzlich diesen Desktop-Modus drin gelassen, wo dann eben das Office drin läuft.
Aber wo man nicht andere Programme installieren kann, sondern wohl nur ihr eigener Scheiß läuft.
Genau.
Was für ein beklopptes Konzept.
Nein, du kannst auf Metro anderen Scheiß installieren.
Nee, du kannst auf Metro, aber nicht auf dem Desktop. Also nicht auf dem Tablet-Desktop.
Bei dem RT jetzt?
Ja, wenn du ein Tablet hast, dann hast du da diesen Desktop-Modus. Da läuft aber nur Office und, ich glaube, der Internet Explorer in diesem Modus und noch der Windows Explorer, also dieser File Manager. Und das war's. Der Rest ist Metro. Und du kannst auch keine Apps nachinstallieren. Dieses Vertrauen, dass sie damit in den... Als die Entscheidung gefallen ist bei Microsoft, da muss irgendjemand am Abend wirklich in seinen Kissen geschrien haben. Weil ich kann mir das so vorstellen, wie die probiert haben, dieses Office-Team zu überzeugen. Und mach doch mal nativ und mach doch mal Metro. Ich bin ja schon die ganze Zeit damit beschäftigt, das für Abend zu kompilieren. Wer soll jetzt da noch ein neues User-Interface drauf packen? Und irgendwann haben sie dann halt so, okay, wir stimmen jetzt ab. Und dabei ist dann rausgekommen, ja, wir machen Desktop. Und so ungefähr stelle ich mir das vor, so ein Langmachtkampf. Und wie viel Vertrauen beweist Microsoft denn in diese eigene Plattform, wenn sie es selber nicht schaffen, ihre eigene Software darauf zu laufen?
Also Office muss ich einfach nochmal sagen. Das sind halt alles Programme, die möchte ich nicht von innen sehen. Und ich glaube auch nicht, dass du die mal eben portiert bekommst.
Ja, sondern das ist halt wegschmeißen und neu machen.
Wenn du dir anguckst, wie lange Apple gebraucht hat, Numbers und Keynote und so weiter auf iOS zu kriegen. Und du kannst mir nicht sagen, dass die da irgendwie nur ein Jahr dran gearbeitet haben. Und dann sind das abgespeckte Versionen. Und klar, die haben da sehr viel Arbeit investiert, aber trotzdem war das ein langer Weg.
Dabei gibt es doch ein Model-View-Controller. Sie müssen halt nur das View so ein bisschen anpassen.
Ja, aber so ein Word, das ist doch so ein Feature-Bloat. Das kannst du doch vergessen. Das kriegst du doch nie mal so eben portiert. Das ist völlig klar. Und wahrscheinlich hat sich das Office-Team auch noch hingestellt. Ey Leute, wir portieren doch jetzt unser Word nicht für so eine Mode, die irgendwie nicht bis Windows 9 durchhält. Und wahrscheinlich haben sie sogar recht damit.
Klar, ich glaube, das wird so ein interner Kampf sein zwischen den einzelnen Teams. Wer hat den...
Wahrscheinlich haben sie sogar recht damit. Hier dieses Metro, das schafft es doch nicht bis Windows 9. Soll ich wetten? Wer hält eine Mate dagegen?
Die haben ja gerade ihr Interface bei Office hier komplett mit diesen Ribbons und so umgedreht. Das ist ja auch noch nicht so lange her. Also insofern sollten sie es vielleicht doch hinkriegen. Da haben sie schon mal alles angefasst. Aber kann ich jetzt auch verstehen...
Da interessiert sich doch einfach kein Mensch mehr dafür. Dieses iPad wird das einfach komplett überrollen. Ich denke, dass sie wirklich keine Chance mehr haben, in diesem Konsumerbereich irgendwelche größeren Fortschritte zu erzielen. Also sie können natürlich noch eine ganze Weile von so einer Installed Base zehren, aber die gewinnen doch keinen neuen User mehr. Also nicht in nennenswerten Zahlen.
Das einzige, wo sie wirklich was reißen konnten, noch war halt die Xbox.
Ja, aber das ist auch alles schon Vergangenheit. Also, das ist absurd, ja?
Ja gut, aber man muss natürlich sagen, dass man von weit voraus. Von 95% Marktanteil geht es halt nur noch einen Berg ab. Wir haben uns geirrt genossen, aber jetzt geht es wieder einen Berg ab.
Ja, und ich glaube auch nicht, dass dieser Enterprise-Markt dann halt... Also ich meine, was mich daran so freut, ist, dass die Zeiten sind ja nun schon eine Weile vorbei. Das ist ja glaube ich auch so der Urgrund für diese ganze Antipathie, diese 90er Jahre. Also von Mitte der 90er Jahre bis Mitte 2000. Diese Dekade, diese verlorene Dekade, wo es einfach keinen nennenswerten technologischen Fortschritt mehr gab im Computerbereich, weil einfach Microsoft überall auf der Bremse stand. Weil einfach alles immer nur noch so zu Microsoft guckte und ja, was machen die? Ah, die machen das, dann machen wir das auch. Wir machen das andere nicht und so und nichts wollte sich mal ordentlich durchsetzen.
Ja, aber davor war ja eine Dekade, wo Microsoft eigentlich alles, was an, wie soll ich sagen, Innovationen kam, aufgekauft oder mit einem Konkurrenzprodukt plattgemacht haben.
Oder mit Vaporware.
Ja, oder mit, ja, jetzt mal.
Das war aber diese Dekade.
Jetzt mal weit, also Konkurrenzprodukt mal weit gespannt bis in die Vaporware hinein. Also das war ja der Punkt, dass irgendwann war der Punkt erreicht, wo alle, weiß ich nicht, alle Firmen, die irgendwie dachten, da ist eine Marktlücke, da können wir irgendwie was reißen. Und dann kommt Microsoft daher und baut das ein oder kündigt das auch an. Und dann sind sie weg. Und dann hat einfach irgendwie überhaupt keiner mehr Bock, sich an der Stelle mit Microsoft anzulegen. Die haben alle nur noch Dinge gemacht, wo sie genau wussten, da wird uns Microsoft nicht gefährlich. Und deswegen ist es natürlich eine verlorene Dekade.
Klar.
Und das vorbei.
Gut, dann gab es da diese Wahnsinnigen aus Hamburg, die irgendwie ihr eigenes Office gemacht haben. Dann die Wahnsinnigen, die ihren eigenen Browser gemacht haben.
Aber...
Star Division und KHTML. Leute, die hinterher in Safari geendet sind.
Mozilla.
Mozilla. Na gut, die gab es vorher schon.
Aber...
Aber im Prinzip war halt so... Auf dem Windows-Markt ja gut Spiele und dann halt so Riesen-Apps.
So, der Chat meint natürlich hier schon wieder gleich, ja, jetzt kommt das Apple-Monopol.
Ja, das ist auch nicht zu begrüßen. Also Konkurrenz brauchen wir schon. Das ist wie mit dem Trecker.
Ja, aber es hat sich einfach auch nichts dran geändert, dass das einfach darauf hinausläuft. Und da ist nicht Apple dran schuld.
Da sind die total dran schuld. Die hätten einfach nicht so gut sein sollen. Aber der Untergang von Apple, jetzt haben wir ja wieder zu viel die anderen schlecht gemacht, jetzt können wir auch wieder ein bisschen auf Apple einprügeln. Also wir haben ja immer alles im Programm. Und mit Apple geht es jetzt bergab, weil jetzt kommt ja das Virenproblem. Also bei Apple geht es jetzt auch nur noch abwärts.
Oh ja, wir sollten noch mal ein bisschen den Nachtrag zu Flashback bringen.
Flashback zu Flashback.
Komisch fand ich, dass dieser Flashback, der das tatsächlich entdeckt haben will, keine Ahnung, haben soll.
Dr. Web, oder was?
Dr. Web, dass der behauptet hat, nö, also er sieht da an seinen Command- und Konkur, wollte ich schon sagen, Servern, also seinen kommand-Servern, gar nicht, dass da irgendwie die Infektionen zurückgehen und das wären immer noch 600.000.
Ja, das hab ich jetzt auch mitbekommen.
Also klar, man könnte jetzt auch sagen, ich bin wieder nur ein Fanboy und will das alles wegreden, weil wir wollen ja gar keine Viren, wir wollen das ja gar nicht aufnehmen in unserem Kopf, dass auch Viren möglich sind, aber am Ende muss ich mir ja auch schon überlegen, dass halt Dr. Web und diese ganzen Virusbuden so, deren einziges Business ist halt wie möglichst irgendwie auch die MEX, und die sind ja nun mal auch im Kommen, irgendwie ihre Virenprogramme auf die MEK-Plattformen zu kriegen. Und wenn die halt keiner kauft, also die gibt's ja schon, die Programme, ne? Ist ja nicht so, dass man die nicht schon kaufen könnte, aber die kauft halt noch keiner.
Die gab's ja immer.
Aber die kauft halt noch keiner. Natürlich wollen die jetzt erzählen, da sind Viren und das ist alles ganz schlimm und irgendwie so. Und am Ende sagen sie natürlich, ja, kauft auch unsere Programme und dann seid ihr sicher noch. Der MEK-User hat den Überblick und sagt sich, ja, nee, da gibt's ja was von Apple und das Ding ist ja weg und ich kann ja gucken, dass ich irgendwie den nicht hab. Aber in ein, zwei Jahren natürlich, wenn es immer mehr von den Dingern gibt, dann blickt keiner mehr durch und dann fangen die Leute schon an, dieses Virenzeug zu kaufen. Und ich bin da ja nicht so. Ich find das ja nicht toll.
Das hätte aber in diesem Fall überhaupt nichts gebracht.
Nee, in anderen Fällen bringt das ja nichts. Außer du hast halt uralte Viren auf deinem Rechner und hast sie halt nicht gekümmert. Aber diese User haben wir halt inzwischen auf der MEK-Plattform. Ist ja nicht mehr irgendwie so übersichtlich, sondern die Leute blicken halt, die Webseiten werden auch immer schlimmer. Das ist schon noch der Unterschied an Downloadqualität, die ich so feststelle. Wenn ich was für ein MEK runterlade, dann lande ich meistens auf irgendwelchen schicken Seiten. Da gibt es irgendwie einen Download-Link, da klicke ich drauf und dann kann ich da irgendwie was downloaden und dann kommt es. Bei Windows, da suche ich irgendeine Software und dann sind da irgendwie auf der Seite 20-30 Download-Button, weil die Werbung hat in ihren Bildchen auch ein Download-Button drin, der noch viel größer ist als der eigentliche Download, den ich klicken sollte. Das ist so unübersichtlich, dass selbst ich, wo ich denke, ich kenne mich ein bisschen aus, irgendwie erstmal genau gucken muss, was ist denn jetzt auf dieser Scheißseite, der richtige Download-Button, dass ich nicht bei irgendeiner Werbung mit irgendeinem komischen Download oder irgendeinem Zeug lande. Also da blickst du gar nicht mehr durch, was du da runterlädst. Und das haben wir auf dem Mac noch nicht so richtig, aber die Leute kommen natürlich auch, die irgendwie versuchen uns zu verarschen und mit ihrer Werbung und ihrem ganzen Zeug da irgendwie uns auf andere Seiten zu locken, wo man sonst wo landet. Das ist schon ein Problem.
Du hast bei Google, wenn du nach dem Zeug suchst, auch gerne mal so eine komische Download-Seite als allererstes drin. Das ist Soft Tonic und wie sie alle heißen.
Genau, da sollte man eigentlich gar kein Zeug verhunteren. Man sollte immer versuchen, möglichst zur Quelle zu gehen. Und das ist halt, aber noch ist es übersichtlich mit Mac. Jetzt hier ist ein Panzer losgefahren. Timme hat hier Koffeinmangel und da ihm die Mate nicht reicht und die intravenösen Möglichkeiten geradeaus.
Das bringt mich jetzt richtig in Fahrt.
Hey, da solltest du noch einen Toaster drin einbauen. Oh Gott, da geht es in der Kuhdrucksohre.
Nichts mehr an rumzupröhlen.
Da will ich vorher noch mal ein bisschen hier von...
Ich hab auch noch einen Nachsatz zu diesen...
Die Conclusion muss jetzt ja noch kommen.
Ja, ich hab auch noch mal was... Also ich hab ja so, erstens diese Zahl jetzt mit 600.000, die ja schon letztes Mal relativ schnell fiel. Ich hab mich immer gefragt, wo kommt diese Zahl her?
Ja, Dr. Webb hat die lange lanciert.
So, also wie generiert man so eine Zahl?
Na die haben, das können sie ja relativ deutlich sagen, woher sie die haben.
Die haben halt den Server, wo der Virus inkonnektiert. Die haben sich den Domain geholt. Die haben halt den Code...
Dieses Teil rechnet sich seine Domains irgendwie stündlich neu aus.
Ja, das können die ja auch machen.
Und die haben sich einfach hinreichend viele Domains geholt. Und die stehen dann unter ihrer Kontrolle. Und dann können sie da ihren eigenen Scheiß draufsetzen und können auf die anderen Server offensichtlich drauf.
Das hat der Symantec auch gemacht, oder diese andere Brude. Nur hat halt Dr. Webb wohl den Richtigen erwischt.
Ja, aber wir behaupten, wir sind nicht gegenseitig dazwischen.
Was heißt das, dass sie das ganze Botnetz jetzt übernommen haben, weil sie die nächsten Domains, irgendwelche Domains, werden sie ja wohl auch sicherlich nicht haben?
Ja, aber der connectet sich anscheinend in einer Reihenfolge. Und Dr. Webb hat wohl den, wo das Ding sich zuerst hinconnectet. Deswegen meint Symantec jetzt auch, weil es kann natürlich auch sein, dass die ihren Partner zureden, weil die ja insgesamt, die müssen ja eigentlich zusammenkämpfen. Die sind zwar Konkurrenten, aber für den Virenmarkt auf dem Max etablieren, müssen ja zusammen kämpfen. Und Symantec sagt, ach ja, stimmt, unsere niedrigen Zahlen, naja, wir haben jetzt nochmal nachgedacht und wir haben jetzt auch gesehen, dass bei uns weniger connecten, aber nur deswegen, weil die Viren ja jetzt wieder zu Dr. Webb irgendwie connecten. Irgendwie so ist jetzt die Story gerade. Ich weiß nicht, was ich davon halten soll. Man kann das halt glauben oder auch nicht, aber...
Wahrscheinlich rechnen sie alle irgendwie hoch.
Also ich halte das für ein Stück weit halte ich das jetzt auch plausibel. Ja, bloß ich fand die Zahl jetzt erstmal irgendwie... Ja, weil da sind Rechner in ein Botnetz. Ja, also Leute übernehmen so ein Ding. Und dann kurze Zeit später können die irgendwie auf die letzte Stelle genau ausrechnen, wie viele Rechner das sind. Ja, haben die das jetzt komplett übernommen? Weil das hab ich so nicht gelesen.
Ich weiß ja nicht, warum der da hinconnectet und wie der da was macht.
Ja, aber hätten sie jetzt alle Rechner übernommen? Also hätten sie die Domains jetzt irgendwie so strategisch gekauft? Das ist alle nur noch, dass das Botnetz quasi von Symantik betrieben wird? Dann gäb's ja auch keine Gefahr mehr eigentlich, oder?
Na ja, du kannst was mit sein machen. Das ist ja mal dieses Problem, das gibt es ja durchaus so in den Fällen, dass dann haben sie das komplette Botnetz unter Kontrolle, könnten theoretisch auch sogar die Software deinstallieren, was ja auch schon in einigen Fällen gemacht ist, dass dann Rechner...
Sie könnten sogar ihr komisches Antivirus-Programm auf den Rechnern dann automatisch installieren.
Ja, aber das ist...
Das sollst du doch bezahlen. Aber sie können natürlich einen Dialog aufmachen.
Bei irgendeinem haben sie es mal im Hintergrund, den Bildschirmhintergrund ausgewechseln, haben drauf geschrieben, du hast übrigens ein Virus, deinstallier den. Aber es ist natürlich auch Hölle, also was ist, wenn da jetzt, also erstens Dialoge, hey, sie haben ein Virus, klicken sie hier, um den wegzumachen, gibt es ja nun im Netz auch mehr als genug, die dir dann erst recht die Scarby installieren. Dieses ganze Zeug mit dem, und natürlich was ist, wenn du da mal eben 20.000 Rechner abschießt und die danach vielleicht nicht mehr hochfahren oder so was, wer haftet dann für den ganzen Scheiß? Du darfst ja auch nicht einfach so auf fremde Rechner drauf und denen dann mal eben Software unterscheiden.
Das war ja auch nur ein Witz. So, jetzt meine eigentliche Frage ist, also meine eigentliche Frage beim letzten Mal ist auch immer noch nicht beantwortet worden. Gibt es da irgendwelche Erkenntnisse? Habt ihr irgendwas gelesen? Gibt es da irgendwas Glaubwürdiges, was so eine hohe Infektionszahl jetzt verursacht hat? Weil das Ding ist ja so gebaut, dass es eben bei infizierten Webseiten quasi was injiziert. Zehn Prozent der Mac installt Base, surft alle über die selbe Webseite?
Nee, das sind ja keine sechs Millionen Rechner nur. Es gibt schon ein paar mehr.
Entschuldigung, ein Prozent.
Ein Prozent.
So, ja.
Aber trotzdem ein Prozent, das ist viel. Also ich meine, wo haben die sich das Ding eingetreten?
Ja, da gibt es keine Informationen dazu.
Warum soll ich das auch erzählen? Weil dann würde man ja eventuell drauf kommen, dass ist alles ganz schön erblöd, was sie da erzählen.
Na wieso? Ich meine, du infizierst hinreichend viele Webseiten und bügelst denen da irgendwie.
Du musst nur die richtige Webseite infizieren.
Du findest eine WordPress-Sicherheitslücke und suchst per Google oder per Suchmaschine nach entsprechend anfälligen WordPress-Installationen. Schmeißt da dein Code rein.
Ein Prozent der Installed Base surft doch dann nicht auf diesen Blogs rum.
Nächste Variante ist, du buchst irgendwo billige Werbebanner und packst das in Werbebanner rein. Dann bist du plötzlich auch auf Zeit Online oder Ähnlichem. Da passen sie mittlerweile ein bisschen auf, aber passiert ist es ja gleich schon.
Das wäre aber bestimmt auch rausgekommen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob darüber jemand großartig...
Es ist schon verdächtig, dass die Virenfirmen genau nicht erzählen, wo man sich den hätte einfangen können. Die Quelle erzählen die einfach nicht. Das müssten die auch langsam rausgefunden haben.
Dann gibt es natürlich noch die Möglichkeit Pornosites. Ich denke, da gab es ja jetzt vor zwei Wochen so einen schicken Artikel, wie viel Petabyte irgendwas an Traffic einer der größeren Netzwerke da ausliefert. Das würde ja nicht weiter auffallen. Das sind massive Zahlen. Das würde mich nicht wundern, wenn ein Prozent dahinsurfen und sich das einfangen.
Also Porn hast du nur noch auf dem iPad angucken, ne?
Also möglich wäre das.
Ja, es geht nicht zwischendurch.
Ich hab nur mal was geredet, das man nicht sieht.
Das machst du auch.
Homebutton immer nach oben.
Geh aus meinem Kopf raus! Also ich find das erstaunlich. Also wenn diese Zahlen stimmen, find ich es trotzdem erstaunlich, dass man nur durch Infektionen von einigen Webseiten, ich meine im Vergleich zu allen möglichen, die so angesurft werden, ja, ist das schon viel.
Ja, möchtest du infizieren, das ist noch eine weitere.
Die haben mobilemax.de infiziert, das ist es.
Also hier im Chat geht es auch gerade rum, dass es wohl im Wesentlichen WordPress-Blocks waren. Hier haben wir ein Artikel. Infektet WordPress-Blocks Blame for Flash, McFlash, Big Trojan. Da haben wir auch einen auf mobilemax.de. Aber es war ja im Wesentlichen nur in USA und Kanada, so die Verbreitung ganz groß und anderen nicht. Schon strange.
Aha, Bogus und Domi Flash Player.
Ja, aber möchtest du denn implizieren, dass es noch einen anderen Ausbreitungsweg gab?
Ich will überhaupt nichts implizieren. Ich frage mich wirklich jetzt nur, wie das jetzt wirklich eine ernst gemeinte Frage gewesen ist. Also was kann jetzt wirklich so, wie muss man das einschätzen? Weil ich meine, der Fehler, der große Fehler, der hier gemacht wurde, ist von Apple gemacht worden. Sie haben einfach ein halbes Jahr, fast doch, ne?
Na nicht ganz, aber fast.
Also auf jeden Fall viel, viel, viel, viel zu lange diese Java-Lücke drin gelassen. Und sie waren ja noch zuständig für dieses Java. Das wird künftig halt nicht mehr so sein und weiß ja gar ja, ob sich die Situation dadurch dann wirklich verbessert. Naja, ja, all diese Karpersky-Jungs, die nerven auch. Seitdem schicken die mir jetzt die ganze Zeit irgendwelche Newsletter zu und so, die ich nie haben wollte. Seitdem das hier mit dem Flashback losgeht. Jaja, schicken das auch hier mal gleich an Boba Max und so. Ja und jetzt machen wir auch irgendwie eine Konferenz. Oh nein, noch mal zwei Tage verschoben und hier. Und jetzt können wir aber auch hier unseren Antivirus kaufen und so. Geht's weg. Geht weg. Ja, sind irgendwie auch unangenehm. Ich meine, irgendwie tun die ja auch Gutes, aber unangenehm finde ich sie trotzdem.
Wer tut Gutes?
Na, die Security Researcher. Ich meine, das ist ja jetzt auch nicht so, dass das jetzt alles nur...
Der Researcher tut mir gut, aber die Virenprogramme, wenn man liest auf dem Windows, wie oft auch die Virenprogramme selbst schon wieder machen Fehler und zeugliche Sachen, da ist doch das Ergebnis plus minus null, dann lass ich die doch lieber gleich weg. Vor allem, wenn man auch dafür bezahlt.
Ja gut, aber ich meine, die Virussoftware, da bin ich ganz deiner Meinung, aber es gibt ja auch wirklich jetzt die Leute, die solche Malware überhaupt erst mal erkennen.
So, ja, auseinandernehmen.
Das ist ja nicht so, dass das, keine Ahnung, die Computerbild dann mal so nebenbei veröffentlicht. Da müssen schon echt Leute mit Plan vor allem auch die ganze Zeit auf der Hut sein, weil ich meine, sowas muss ja auch erst mal entdeckt werden. Gar nicht so einfach. Ich hab da mal einen tollen CRE zugemacht hier mit Thorsten Holz, der mal so ein bisschen erklärt hat, wie man so Botnetze entdeckt und auch wieder lahmlegt und so. Das ist der Spaß, den sich jetzt Apple auch gönnen darf.
Ja, doch, da passiert auch mal was. Vielleicht ist ja in dem nächsten Update hier 10.47, ist ja auch bald mal fertig, vielleicht ist ja da noch mal ein bisschen was drin und vielleicht sterben dann ja noch mal ein paar mehr irgendwie Bot-Installationen, weil die Leute dann auch eher updaten. Vielleicht, ich weiß ja auch nicht, was die Leute, keine Updates klicken. Ich bin immer so Updategeil, ich zieh mir da mal gleich alle rein und vielleicht gibt's ja so ein paar Schlafmützen.
Ja, aber ich meine, wenn du keine Updates hast, die du anwenden kannst.
Aber es gibt doch dieses Java-Update von Apple. Wie oft kam es? Drei Mal?
Ja, aber das kam halt Monate zu spät.
Ja, aber es ist doch jetzt da. Warum gibt's angeblich immer noch irgendwie hier 744.000 User, die irgendwie das Ding haben?
Weil die Leute ihre Software nicht aktualisieren.
Versteh ich halt nicht.
Ich versteh's auch nicht, aber das machen die Leute nicht. Also ich kenn auch einen Freund von mir, der ist selbst, also der ist iOS-Entwickler und der hat, ich weiß nicht, wie lange der gebraucht hat und damals, auf iOS 5, das ging jetzt relativ flott, aber damals, auf iOS 4, hat er sich ein halbes Jahr Zeit gelassen mit. Weißt du ja toll, warum?
Also die Apple-Updates hau ich schon immer.
Die Leute stecken das teilweise nicht an die iTunes ran.
Ja, aber auch so die App Store, also diese App Store.
Hat er sein iPhone nicht geupdatet, meinst du?
Ich hab mal, ich hab ne List, ja genau, der hat sein iPhone nicht geupdatet. Ich hab mal auf Twitter eine Diskussion mit jemandem geführt. Du diskutierst auf Twitter. Ich diskutiere auf Twitter. Und der meinte, der hat sich darüber beschwert, so bei iTunes, so im App Store, wenn dransteht, wir aktualisieren häufig. Oder hier, unsere App wird häufig aktualisiert. So nach dem Motto, wer soll das denn kaufen, wenn das häufig aktualisiert wird? Dann hab ich gesagt, na willst du lieber Software, wir haben die schon lange abandoned und kümmern uns nicht mehr um die Fehler. Und das war so wirklich so, ja ne, ich möchte nicht ständig was Neues installieren müssen, es nervt doch, und darüber kamen dann so, da haben sich dann noch ein paar andere mit eingemischt, die haben gemeinten, ja, sie kennen AppStore, Leute, die im AppStore-Icon dreistellige Notifications-Icons haben, dass so viele neue Updates da sind. Also, dass die über 100 Apps nicht aktualisiert haben. Und es gibt einfach viele Leute, die installieren das nicht.
Oh, was hätte ich einen Spaß, diese iPhones irgendwie da hinzulegen, Update All, und dann zuzugucken, wie da alles gleichzeitig leuchtet. Das wär so ein Spaß, ist doch wie Weihnachten!
Auf Twitter kommt die berechtigte Frage, ob denn nicht diese ganze Sandboxing-Geschichte, die jetzt eingeführt wird, da nicht helfen sollte, bei dem ganzen Virenbefall künftig.
Also da bin ich ja auch noch geteilter Meinung, weil auf der einen Seite denke ich schon lange irgendwie, alle Apps gehören in ihr eigenes Jail, weil für mich sind das ja nicht mehr meine Tools, sondern eigentlich sehe ich das inzwischen so. Das ist fremder Code auf meinem Rechner, der da mehr oder weniger machen kann, was er will, und ich finde das überhaupt gar nicht mehr gut. Also ich hab da echt so, noch nicht so richtig Schiss, aber kein gutes Gefühl mehr inzwischen. Also seit die der Adressbuchgeschichte und so, ich hab ja nicht mehr das Gefühl, gerade auf dem Mac, dass irgendwie ich Herr über diesen Rechner bin, weil alle Tools alles machen können. Ich weiß, es war schon immer so, aber jetzt tun sie es auch irgendwie, hab ich zumindest das Gefühl. Und ich finde, das gehört alles in irgendwie einen Jail rein, wo ich selber bestimmen kann, wie weit die Rechte sind, und das hätte ich gerne.
Denn es hat Angst.
Ja, und auf der anderen Seite aber endet das natürlich so, weil Apple wird es da so machen, weil eigentlich am Ende ist es auch in deren Interesse, nämlich auch die Kontrolle über meinen Rechner zu übernehmen, dass mein Rechner so endet wie so ein iPhone. Also du kannst halt nicht mehr selber booten, nicht mehr selber machen, was du willst, weil anders kriegen sie eventuell das System gar nicht mehr dicht. Ich weiß noch nicht, ob ich es toll finde oder nicht, aber es wird so den Weg gehen, würde ich mal sagen.
Ja gut, aber Sandboxing ist halt jetzt nicht so ohne Weiteres einführbar auf dem Mac. Das hat sich ja allein schon dadurch gezeigt, dass es nicht so ohne Weiteres eingeführt wurde.
Also ich sag mal so, dieser Flashback-Trojaner ist, glaube ich, der Sargnagel für die Hoffnung, dass Sandbox noch mal verschoben wird. Ich denke, die ziehen es jetzt durch, weil sie gesehen haben, was das für Folgen haben kann.
Da haben die gar keinen Bock drauf. Die wollen nicht so ändern wie Microsoft, weil es hat Microsoft, ich meine, die machen plus irgendwie immer noch, aber es hat die bestimmt richtig viel Geld gekostet, irgendwie dieses Windows jetzt doch so mal hinzukriegen, so sicher wie es ist, weil sonst wäre noch alles viel schlimmer und das war bestimmt nicht billig.
Es gibt Leute, die überhaupt wissen, wer so verkackt war, weil sie XP so viel patchen mussten und deswegen keine Zeit mehr für Vista hatten. Gut, das ist vielleicht eine Extremposition, aber...
Ist das nicht vielleicht die Frage, ob das nicht der Sargnagel für Java auf dem Eck ist, dass die Installation noch schwerer wird?
Ja, aber nicht der erste. Das ist so der 25. oder 26. Sargnagel. Also ich meine...
Ja gut, aber derzeit ist es so, du hast keinen Java und dann will irgendwas Java und dann steht ja so, ah, du brauchst Java, drück hier auf installieren, zack, return, dann hast du Java und es läuft.
Aber das wird doch mit Mountain Line eh nicht mehr so sein.
Das weiß ich gar nicht, wie es da aussehen wird.
Das ist, Apple kümmert sich nicht mehr um Java und die haben... Da haben wir doch hier schon mal drüber geredet.
Da haben wir schon mal drüber geredet, aber ich weiß nicht, wie es in Mountain Line jetzt konkret aussehen wird.
War das nicht in Mountain Line? Dass Apple in Zukunft kein Java mehr mitliefern wird und sich auch nicht mehr darum kümmert und dass der Code übergeben wird an eine externe Community, die sich dann darum kümmern darf, will, soll. Und wenn jemand Java haben will, dann lädt er sich das da runter und installiert es. Und ich finde das eine okaye Lösung, weil jetzt brauche ich erstmal... Wobei eben gerade als sich Erlang installiert hat, da lief da die ganze Zeit der Java-Compiler im Hintergrund. Keine Ahnung warum.
Also ich denke, dass sie auf jeden Fall auch ein Sicherheitsupdate in Java für Java machen müssen. Das müssen sie machen. Aber sie werden sicherlich die Schwelle erhöhen, das zu installieren.
Wieso, wenn sie keinen Java mehr mit ausliefern? Warum müssen sie denn Updates dafür liefern?
Dann werden sie das nicht mehr tun.
Dann machen sie es nicht mehr.
Ja, aber Java ist doch was, was sich so tief ins System einklingt. Na gut, dann können sie sagen, hey, wenn du Java installierst, ist das dein Risiko.
Wo ist das denn? Es gibt eine Java Runtime irgendwie. Auf allen anderen Plattformen wird doch Java nachinstalliert. Das ist doch nur bei Mac OS so, dass es mit ausgeliefert wird. Das ist doch die letzte Plattform.
Das ist die letzte Plattform, wo der Betriebssystemhersteller das selber noch mit ausliefert.
Und das kann man doch problemlos.
Solaris ist es, glaube ich, auch standardmäßig drin.
Das ist ja auch der Hersteller.
Aber bei den ganzen Linux-Distributionen ist es nicht mehr dabei, beziehungsweise da war es am Anfang sogar relativ schwer.
Kann sein, kann ich nicht beurteilen.
Das zu installieren bei Windows ist es nicht dabei. Also es ist schon bei genug Betriebssystemen nicht dabei. Und da lässt sich das auch problemlos nachinstallieren.
Habt ihr denn verstanden, was dieses Flashback genau eigentlich tut, nachdem es diesen exploit genutzt hat? Also erzeugt es neue Prozesse? Oder läuft das einfach im Java-VM alles innerhalb von Java, dieser ganze Botnetz-Kram?
Also so wie ich es verstanden hab, ist ja diese Java-Lücke ja nur ein Dropper gewesen. Also sprich, eine Möglichkeit Flashback zu installieren. Das Ding heißt ja nicht umsonst Flashback, weil es sich vorher ja als Flash-Installer getarnt hat. Und damit ja nichts mit Java zu tun hat.
Aber was läuft denn dann konkret Böses?
Also ich glaube, dass sie eine Kernel-Extension installieren. Ja, die installieren eine Kernel-Extension und machen... Ja, hab ich irgendwo gelesen. Also es ist nicht so ein ganzes, aber so ein halbes Root-Kit. Also du bist so... Also sie tauschen dir nicht direkt den Kernel aus, aber sie installieren, glaub ich, irgendwie eine Kernel-Extension.
Die wollte ich auch noch durchlesen. Die Tiefenanalyse der Flashback-Trojaner hier bei Mack & I.
Erzähl mal weiter.
Und dann keine Ahnung. Also ich denke, das ist halt so wie eine moderne Malware. Das ist halt so ein Baukastensystem. Du versuchst erstmal irgendwie auf den Rechner zu kommen und dann hast du da deinen schlafenden Agenten, der irgendwie auf das Command- und Control-Center lauscht und guckt, was denn jetzt der Master so will, was er jetzt böses anstellen will.
Und die User muss natürlich ihr Passwort eingeben, dass der dann eine Kernel-Extension installieren kann. Richtig. Und haben es natürlich gemacht. Weil der sich ja als Flash-Update getan hat.
Genau.
Und die kam halt ins Fensterchen. Wenn wir das jetzt hier updaten sollen, dann brauchen wir aber mal halt hier dein Passwort. Ich kann nur nochmal an alle Admins irgendwie appellieren, dass wenn die halt irgendwelche El-Chipo-Tools irgendwie verteilen, was überhaupt gar kein Admin-Passwort benötigt, dass sie auch nicht danach fragen. Weil die User werden halt echt, die geben das halt einfach mal so locker ein. Und wenn halt einfach gar keiner danach fragt und dann plötzlich mal so einer nach dem Admin-Account fragt, dann sollte das halt auffallen. Aber so viele danach fragen, ist es halt schon so normal. Also macht euren Installer mal ohne Admin-Passwort, wenn es geht.
Fragt der nach einem Root-Passwort, der hier?
Ja, sonst könnte er doch keine Curdle-Extension installieren. Außer da ist halt bei Apple noch eine Lücke, aber die hätten sie ja dann wohl auch mal gefixt.
Aber wenn du ein Flash-Update oder wenn du ein Flash überhaupt mal installierst, dann gibst du natürlich auch ein Admin-Passwort ein. Also bei den meisten Programmen, wo ein Installer dabei ist, gibst du auch ein Admin-Passwort ein. Das ist ganz normal.
Nee, das ist halt nicht, warum das so ist.
Also der installiert sich auch ohne dieses Administrator-Passwort.
Okay, also dann hat er dann auch seine Sicherheitsvorsorge.
Er hat zwei verschiedene Strategien, mit und ohne. Und ehrlich gesagt ist hier nicht so richtig von Ruth die Rede und Colonel Extension. Ich hab bisher auch noch nichts gefunden. Das geht hier irgendwie auf... Ja, so viel zu unseren umfangreichen Kenntnissen, solcher Dinge. Ich hab diesen Artikel leider jetzt das erste Mal gesehen. Sehr ausführlich, aber ich find jetzt grad nicht so wichtig.
Ja, aber wenn er nicht nach einem Adminpasswort fragt, müsste das doch heißen, dass entweder das Teil nur mit Userrechten läuft oder sie eine Privilege Escalation-Löcke gefunden haben.
Ich meine, wenn im Nachhinein...
Ja, aber das ist doch etwas, was Apple dann noch mal getrennt fixen muss.
Ja klar, aber wenn du nach einem Adminpasswort fragst, ist doch logisch. Also wenn du auf eine Webseite gehst, da ein Java-Applet läuft, das sagt, hallo, gib mir dein Adminpasswort ein, und dann hat das Applet Adminrechte und kann alles machen, was sie willst, dann hast du ja keine Sicherheitslücke mit dem Sinn.
Also weiterhin ist es vielleicht auch mal ein guter Warnschuss, der noch vielleicht glimpflich ausgegangen ist. Jungs, also gebt nicht einfach so leicht, glaube ich, Adminpasswort ein, so oder so, ob sie es jetzt nur benutzt haben oder nicht. Ladet möglichst irgendwie nicht, weil er nur gerade auf irgendeiner WordPress-Seite plötzlich Flash-Updates runter, sondern wenn er Flash-Updates haben wollt, dann geht es Adobe-Kommen.
Das sind ja keine Flash-Updates, das sind Live-By-Downloads. Du kriegst es ja gar nicht mit. Wenn du Java anhast und du hast es installiert, dann passiert gar nichts, sondern dann installiert sich das, ohne dass du was von merkst und du kriegst es nicht mal mit.
Ja, der ist einfach direkt dann durch den Safari in die Shared Libraries gekrochen.
Dachte noch über ein Flash-Update.
Nee, nee, das war die erste Variante, die über die er sich nicht verbreitet hat.
Der Flash-Installer, nicht das Update, Installer.
Ja, aber das hat er nicht mehr gemacht, sondern dann haben sie diese Java-Lücke gefunden.
Verstehe, verstehe.
Ach so, dann hat er Zugriff wie ein User gehabt und dann hat er noch eine...
Gebt euch keine Mühe, wir kriegen das jetzt hier nicht...
Na, was ich noch gelesen habe, dass er mittlerweile so sich nicht mehr installiert, wenn man solche Sachen wie Little Snitch und sowas drauf hat.
Ja, das hatten wir in der letzten Sendung schon. Da haben wir noch so grob irgendwie. Und Xcode komischerweise auch, das heißt alle Developer. Also alle, um es mal ganz ehrlich zu sagen, alle Leute, wo der Bot-Programmierer dachte, dass sie so ein bisschen Ahnung haben könnten, da lieber nicht, weil sonst merken die das zu früh. Und das ist schon gar nicht so schlecht, weil...
Und dann aber trotzdem 600.000? Also ich meine...
So viele Entwickler gibt es halt nicht.
Es hat ihnen halt ein paar Tage Vorsprung gebracht, bis sich das Botnet auch groß genug war irgendwie.
Ich dachte, dass mit dieser Little-Snitch-Variante, dass er sich da nicht installiert, also dass er diese Blacklist-Liste erst in einer neueren Version hatte, die jetzt noch unterwegs ist.
Na ja, wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall muss ich mal ein bisschen an die Glocken fassen und mal schauen...
An die Glocken?
So und jetzt? Jetzt will ich mal.
Ich will auch mal!
Darf ich? Und zwar, wahrscheinlich werd ich jetzt gleich wieder gekält. Also ich hab hier so ein neues Game entdeckt.
Boah, das ist doch schon total alt!
Das ist allerdings wirklich total alt. Das heißt, Shadow City. Und das Wichtigste sag ich jetzt gleich mal zuerst. Und zwar, jetzt hat er mich gleich umgehauen. Ich hab mir so viele Feinde gemacht, die mögen mich nicht mehr. Das heißt, Shadow City ist von Ende 2010, wenn ich es jetzt richtig verstanden hab, ist aus Finnland.
Auf dem iPad.
Auf dem iPhone. Das gibt's wohl auch nur auf dem iPhone, auf dem iPad. Macht's wohl Ärger, meint ein Kumpel von mir. Ich hab das am Wochenende entdeckt. Ich spiel das irgendwie, glaub ich, seit Freitag oder so. Ich hab's zwischendurch auch schon einmal gelöscht, weil ich dachte, was für ein Scheiß. Hab dann aber doch noch mal angefangen. Und zwar ist das so ein Game, also ja, Rollenspiel nennt es manch, aber ja, weiß nicht, du bist so ein Magier. Es gibt zwei Fraktionen, Orange und Grün. Ich bin Grün, Quatsch, Quatsch, Quatsch, halt, stopp. Ich bin Orange. Und Orange ist auch gerade wenig. Also wenn Leute was Neues anfangen, sollten sie auch Orange machen, damit das Spiel mehr gebalanced ist. Und man muss bis Level 18 irgendwie hochkommen und das kann man erreichen, indem man halt so kleine Aufgaben erfüllt. Und das Witzige an dem Game ist halt, dass es halt geo-based ist. Das heißt, die Karte in diesem Spiel ist halt mehr oder weniger die echte Welt. Du erscheinst, wenn du das Spiel startest, an der Stelle, wo du halt physikalisch auch gerade so rumstehst. Und du siehst dann, das haben die halt so autogenerierungsmäßig gemacht, in der Gegend so Gates. Und zwar bei mir zu Hause in der Nähe ist der Nordbahnhof, Brandenburger Tor, Potsdamer Platz und so weiter. Und diese Gates kannst du dann mit so einem Dominator dominieren, wenn sie neutral sind oder schon, wenn sie deiner eigenen Fraktion entsprechen. Also meine Fraktion ist halt orange. Wenn die orange sind, kann ich da auch einen Dominator ranklinken und dann so Energie abzapfen und die dann irgendwann ernten. Es kann aber auch sein, dass dieses Gate irgendwie dem Gegner gehört, weil der da seinen Dominator dran hat. Und dann kannst du versuchen, wenn du den siehst, den zu zerstören. Es kann aber sein, dass dieser Dominator sozusagen hinter diesem Gate ist jetzt so und du da nicht rankommst und dann müsstest du physikalisch dich so ein bisschen in der echten Welt bewegen, damit du rankommst und denen dann kehlst. Und man kann sich später natürlich auch anders auf der Karte bewegen, ohne dass man sich wirklich auch in der echten Welt bewegt, indem man halt so zu so Beakens von Freunden springt und so weiter. Deswegen sind Freunde wichtig. Aber man kann natürlich auch, wenn man das gerade alles nicht so hat oder wenn es einem Spaß macht oder man sowieso den ganzen Tag unterwegs ist. Ich glaube der perfekte Job für dieses Spiel ist Taxifahrer. Fahrradkurier, ja. Dann kann man auch eine Menge Spaß haben. Und du machst gerade eine Taxifahrerausbildung. Nee, aber ich bin immer, weil ich zu einem Kumpel fahre, letztens halt auch irgendwie bin ich erstmal nördlich vom Nordbahnhof hingefahren, hab da irgendwie einen Dominator weggekloppt. Dann bin ich nachts zu einem Kumpel gefahren, hab schnell an der Leipziger Straße angehalten, hab geguckt, ob da was ist, auch weggekloppt und bin dann weitergefahren. Und das geht immer so 2-3 Minuten und musst jetzt nicht da stundenlang auf der Straße rumzupfen.
Dennis, you're doomed. Ich erinnere mich noch, wie du bei World of Warcraft mehrere Wochen damit verbracht hast, die ganze Zeit nur von dem Wald zu einem anderen Wald zu laufen und so weiter. Wenn du das jetzt in der echten Welt auch machst, dann ist ja hier total sportlich und jetzt gerade so im Sommer rum.
Ja, dann kommt man mal aus dem Haus, ich find das witzig. Und ich hab schon gemerkt, mit dem Motorrad ist es ein bisschen blöd, weil ich muss zum Anhalten Handschuhe ausziehen, iPhone rauszuholen, tippen tippen. Okay, hier ist das Ding gar nicht, Handschuhe wieder rein, also iPhone wieder rein, Handschuhe wieder anziehen, losfahren. Also mit Fahrrad ist besser.
Meinst du, der richtige Kick, der kommt dann erst, wenn du so in der vorpommerschen Seenplatte dann irgendwie rumguckst und so?
Ja, das gibt's auch Drive-By-Rates. Dann sind da mehrere Leute, die irgendwo hinfahren und die die Gegend platt machen und sich danach wieder...
Da ist aber niemand. Da ist einfach leer. Da gibt's wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal Netz.
Doch, das Game ist irgendwie so, dass diese Gates, das sind halt besonders viele Gates in so innen steht und dann sind die Bereiche, die du siehst, auch klein. Und wenn du irgendwo rauskommst, wo wenig los ist, dann siehst du trotzdem Gate, weil sie einfach den Bereich, den du sehen kannst, vergrößern. Also du siehst halt immer so die entsprechende Menge um dich, sodass du mindestens immer einen oder zwei Gates irgendwie, also ein Gate siehst du auf jeden Fall immer irgendwie wohl. Wie es so ganz genau läuft, weiß ich nicht, weil ein paar Sachen sind auch so im grau Bereich, wo die es halt nicht so genau erklären. Aber ich hab da eine Menge Spaß. Ich heiße in dem Game Denisio, bin bei den Orangen. Also wenn da Leute noch irgendwie mich befrienden wollen, damit man besser hin und her hüpfen kann und ich irgendwie vielleicht noch ein paar Leute haben, die mir helfen, weil ich hab grad mich mit zu vielen 18ern angelegt, die mich hier irgendwie dauerkehlen, weil...
Auch nichts Neues, oder?
Mir hat schon einer gesagt, dass ich ja hier in Mitte nicht so gute Karten entbreche, weil er hier so der King ist und ich könnte entweder zu seiner Seite wechseln oder er könnte so ein Peace-Abkommen mit mir machen und ich könnte dann so eine Ecke irgendwie haben, aber ich fand das halt nicht so gut, weil ich denke mal, so ein Spiel spielt man ja, damit man sich gegenseitig kloppen kann. Und deswegen verhaut er mich jetzt immer, weil der ist schon Level 18 und ich noch nicht. Aber so ist das halt.
Das ist ja wie im richtigen Leben.
Ja, so ist es halt, ja, aber klein beigeben ist nicht.
Die Gangs kontrollieren da halt so die Stadt.
Ja, aber es ist voll witzig. Und genau, diese Gates, diese Software-Bude, finde ich auch ganz witzig, die nennen die Gates halt. Also Brandenburger Tor ist halt Potsdamer Platz, Checkpoint Charlie. Aber dann gibt es auch welche, hier Friedrichstraße zum Beispiel, können die ja nicht Friedrichstraße nennen, weil gibt es ja auf der Welt tausende Friedrichstraßen. Deswegen heißt es dann teilweise Friedrichstadt. Oder sie hängen halt irgendwie so Namen dran oder Friedrichvorstadt, damit es irgendwie was hat, was halt ein eigenständiger Name ist. Und man kann für diese Gates, man kann die wohl auch kaufen.
Aber Friedrichstadt ist doch so ein beliebter Fehler bei so irgendwelchen, ich weiß nicht, bei Google Maps oder so was. Da heißen auch so Bezirke, ich glaube, gibt da so ein Prenzelhain oder irgendwie so was, so ganz merkwürdige Mischform.
Ich glaube immer, wenn die irgendwie so eine Art Gate machen, wo es den Namen schon gibt, dann hängen sie einfach hinten was anderes dran, damit sie irgendwie einen eigenständigen kriegen. Und jedenfalls kann man diese Gates auch kaufen. Und natürlich ist der Potsdamer Platz, weil der Name so berühmt ist. Der ist halt richtig teuer. Und dann sind die Leute, die da Energie saugen, weiß gar nicht, ob die da irgendwie ein bisschen mehr Energie bekommen, aber dann wird sich halt besonders doll um diese coolen Gates irgendwie geprügelt. Und ja, das ist halt ganz witzig. Und das zocke ich gerade. Ich weiß nicht, wie lange es noch anhält.
Wie ist denn das kostenlos, das Game?
Das ist kostenlos, weil wenn man da natürlich so rumzaubert und seine Sprüche macht und so weiter, das kostet halt Mana. Die Mana, wie bei WoW und anderen Games, erholt sich mit der Zeit halt von alleine. Dauert aber auch manchmal zu lange. Gerade so im Kampf, wenn dir der Mana ausgeht, stehst du halt so mit runtergelassenen Hosen da und du weißt nicht, was du machen sollst. Und dann kannst du Mana kaufen. Und sieben Mana-Pötte oder Potions, heißt das ja so, kosten halt irgendwie 80 Cent. Ist nicht so billig. Also ich hab jetzt noch keins gekauft, aber ein Kumpel von mir, der ist schon auch irgendwo physikalisch hingelaufen, um den Gegner platt zu machen und dann hatte er keinen Mana und ich dachte, scheiße, jetzt bin ich hier schon hingelaufen. Dann kann ich jetzt auch mal schnell Mana kaufen.
Mit BVG-Muners-Card und dazu ein bisschen Mana kaufen.
Naja, so hat jeder sein Geschäftsmodell.
So hat jeder sein Geschäftsmodell. Das Schenk hab ich auch erst wieder gelöscht, weil ich dachte, alles klar, es geht ja nur, egal was du machst, wenn der Gegner dich platt machen will, dann kauft der sich einfach Mana und kann dich voll ärgern. Aber gut, wenn die das dann halt so machen, dann machen die das halt so. Aber noch macht es erstmal Spaß für eine Runde. Und da wo ich jetzt gerade bin, ich könnte hier eigentlich so einen Bickel machen, an der Stelle, wo wir hier gerade physikalisch sind, dass hier Leute herkommen könnten im Spiel. Nee, nee, nix. Aber das geht halt auch nicht, weil, wenn ich hier aus dem Game rauskomme, da ist sofort einer, der mich killt, die warten schon immer auf mich und naja.
Du hast dir wieder mal zu viele Feinde gemacht.
Ja, mein Vorteil ist halt, die gehen irgendwann schlafen, ich nicht. Na gut, so viel dazu. So, und hier jetzt ballert er schon wieder auf mich, genau. Und bumm, weg bin ich. Könnt ihr ja später mal gucken, ich werde ja nachher noch mal eine Runde spielen.
Dann kann ich jetzt mal erzählen hier, von der ersten App, an der ich so richtig fett mitgearbeitet habe, ist in dem Store.
Abteilung Eigenwerbung!
Haben wir heute das Screenfeeder.
Ihr praktischer kleiner Desktop.
Jetzt bin ich auf dem Konzept.
Du hast mal wieder eine Twitter Vault programmiert.
Und das war nicht meine Idee.
Das war nicht bestimmt. Das ist ein Twitter, Instagram, Foursquare und Dribble-Client. Dribble war mein besonderer Wunsch.
Ich muss sagen, dass ich bis dahin noch nie was von Dribble gehört habe.
Was ist denn Dribble?
Dribble ist so mit 3B eine Design-Community. Hast du es gelockt?
Haha, Tim zeigt das hier gerade auf seinem iPad, hat aber die Drehung nicht richtig im Griff. Wenn du auch die Flasche wegnimmst, die ist zwar durchsichtig, aber ich bin...
Was halt der Unterschied ist zu diesen anderen Kleistern rummonieren, wer hat sich denn dieses Icon da ausgedacht?
Das Screenfeeder-Icon, das ist tatsächlich das meist kritisierte an den ganzen Apps. Das wird ziemlich geliebt, aber das hat die Agentur. Also wir haben das ja zusammen gemacht mit Eden Spiekermann. Die haben auch das ganze...
Sieht so ein bisschen aus wie dieser Zahntanz bei Monty Python.
Ich hab an dieses Monster gedacht aus diesem japanischen... Wie heißt dieses japanische Monster? Nee, so ein kleines Fernsehwerbe-Monster. Pokemon. Nee, du weißt es einfach nicht. Das hat so einen Namen. Das ist ja so ein Fernsehwerbe-Maskottchen. Und die haben das ganze Design gemacht. Die haben auch den ganzen Rest, die Twitter-Alkons aussehen, die ganzen Schriften und so. Dieses ganze Zeug haben sie gemacht. Und unter anderem eben auch das Alken. Es sind halt diese Zähne, weil es Screenfeeder...
Kann man das ausschalten, dieses hässliche Alken, der immer steht und diese Linie weiß, dass man Strom braucht?
Das kannst du ausschalten. Das kannst du in den Advanced Settings ausschalten. Dann kannst du die Power Warning abschalten. Und...
Schauen wir mal auf dieses Ding da.
Jaja, dann ist es weg. Dann ist es jetzt, geh mal wieder raus. Und jetzt, genau, jetzt ist es einfach weg. Und jetzt ist der Bildschirm schön leer und man sieht wirklich nur den Tweet und immer dazu den passenden Hintergrund von dem jeweiligen User. Was mich dazu geführt hat, dann doch irgendwann mal ein neues Hintergrundbild für mich anzulegen. Normalerweise sieht das ja niemand. Und dann kann man das so neben seinen Rechner stellen oder sein, oder was auch immer. Gernot stellt das gerne mal neben den Fernseher, während er Tatort guckt. Dann kann man auch Hashtags tracken und das danach gesucht wird. Und dann kann man so ein bisschen hin und her swipen und das ist also so quasi so ein Nebenher-Ding, wo man so nebenbei so ein bisschen die ganzen Dienste mitverfolgen kann. Und ja, kostet 1,59 Euro. Und jetzt würde ich gerne hier noch irgendwie fünf Gutscheine verlosen. Wir machen was am besten. Ich schmeiße dir einfach ein Chat. Soll ich dir einfach ein Chat schmeißen? Dann schmeiße ich ein Chat.
Dann haben wir es ja jetzt für live.
Genau.
Dann würden die Sendungen eh nicht überstehen.
Alle auf einmal, nicht in den Hintergrund.
Ja klar, alle auf einmal. Hier, schlagt euch drum. Und, ähm, achso, und es gab noch die Frage auf, auf Twitter hat jemand gefragt, so ich soll dir doch mal erzählen, wie wir es geschafft haben, diesen unglaublichen Buster rum zu erzeugen, weil wir hatten auf TechCrunch hatten wir einen Artikel, wir hatten bei Heise einen Artikel, wir hatten jetzt bei Fritz hat das einen Beitrag über uns gemacht, also dieser Radiosender hier in Berlin Brandenburg und Fritz.
Über diese App.
Genau.
Wieso das denn?
Na die stellen auch, du hast das wahrscheinlich so genauso lange nicht mehr gehört wie ich oder noch länger als ich, die stellen da halt Apps vor und die durften nicht iPhone sagen, das war sehr lustig, das hat man so in dem Beitrag gemerkt, dass die so so ja für euer Smartphone und das ist für euer Smartphone, wenn ihr auf eurem Smartphone installiert, durch Screenfeeder und irgendwann wird das nochmal versteht, dass das öffentlich-rechtliche Sender, die dürfen bestimmt nicht so eine Markennamen sagen. Auf jeden Fall haben die die ganze Zeit immer nur Smartphone gesagt.
Wenn sie die Apps vorstellen, dann sagen sie auch die ganze Zeit Markennamen.
Ja keine Ahnung, war halt so, die haben halt nicht iPhone gesagt. Ich nehme an, dass das irgendwelche...
Wenn das Programm jetzt Screenfeeder vor iPhone heißt?
Vor allen Dingen, es gibt das nur fürs iPhone und fürs iPad.
Ja, das ist lustig.
Achso und was noch toll ist, man kann's auch, es gibt's nicht nur quasi fürs iPad und fürs iPhone, sondern es gibt's auch für ein Apple TV, also es läuft nicht direkt auf ein Apple TV, aber mit diesem AirPlay Screen Sharing, nee Mirroring heißt es, AirPlay Mirroring, kann man's auch auf dem Fernseher schön darstellen, dann sieht's richtig schön groß aus und wenn man HDMI-Kabel hat oder irgendein Kabel dran, dann kann man's auch so anschließen und dann hat man's schön groß auf dem Fernseher drauf. Also wenn man mal so spontane Twitter-Wall braucht, dann ist das genau das Richtige.
Schön. Schön einfach.
Und kostet 1,59.
Kann man irgendwie zumindest... Wie viel Historik, wie weit...
Nicht so wahnsinnig viele. Das wird aber noch mehr werden. Wir sitzen immer noch dran. Das ist jetzt die... Das ist aber auch Read-Only, man kann jetzt hier nicht twittern. Man kann retweeten, man kann faffen. Das ist so die Interaktion, die es gibt. Und du kannst halt deinen eigenen Twitter-Client in den Einstellungen angeben und dann kannst du oben auf die Twitter-Batch tippen. Und dann kann er eben im Twitter-Client deiner Wahl auch den Tweet öffnen. Also wenn du da jetzt irgendwie feststellst, ah, da würde ich jetzt gerne drauf antworten, dann kannst du das auch machen. Und jetzt ist gerade die Version 1.0.1 im Store, weil da hatte ich so einen kleinen Fehler drinnen, dass das Onboarding mit bestimmten Diensten nicht so hundertprozentig funktioniert hat. Das Onboarding.
Was ist denn Onboarding?
Na, Onboarding, das ist, wenn du die App erst mal startest, dann kommt da halt, hallo, bitte richtet deine Accounts ein. Und dann kannst du auch... First Startup. Genau, so dieser Prozess des Einrichtens.
Das heißt, bei euch Onboarding.
Weißt du das irgendwo nicht so?
Ich hab den Ausdruck noch nie gehört.
Nee, ich hab den Onboarding. nutzt diesen Begriff relativ selbstverständlich.
Aber okay, ja. Und...
Genau, und... So als nebenbei Twitter Client. Braucht man nicht, ist aber sehr, sehr hübsch.
Wenn man noch mehr Ablenkung braucht, wird man da fündig.
Genau.
Schön, Max. Hast du gut gemacht.
Ja, hab ich gut gemacht, ne?
Super.
Endlich ne Twitter-Wall. Wie ich vorhin schon erwähnte, ihr könntet da mal Pinterest einbauen.
Ja, Pinterest ist... Facebook wird natürlich massenhaft nachgefragt. Facebook hatten wir auch schon... Also, jetzt seh ich jetzt einfach mal aus dem Nähkästchen ein bisschen. Facebook hatten wir in der Entwicklung schon mit drin, haben wir dann wieder rausgeschmissen, weil das einfachen... Facebook ist ein eigenes Biest. Das muss man unter Kontrolle kriegen. Also, ich würde sagen, wir hatten mit Facebook mehr Arbeit als mit allen anderen Diensten zusammen. Weil Facebook ist so komplex. Bei Twitter hast du halt... Du hast einen Tweet, du hast einen Retweet. Bei Instagram hast du ein Bild. Bei Dribble hast du ein Bild. Bei Foursquare hast du ein Check-In. Foursquare sieht auch sehr schön aus. Da sieht man im Hintergrund die Karte, wo sich derjenige eingecheckt hat. Wenn man näher dran ist an dem Ort, wo er sich eingecheckt hat, wenn sich hier jemand in Berlin eingecheckt würde, dann hättest du einen relativ hohen Zoom-Level auf der Karte. Wenn er sich irgendwo in Amerika eingecheckt, dann siehst du im Wesentlichen, dass er jetzt wahrscheinlich in San Francisco ist. Das ganze Universum. Foursquare macht Facebook. Die haben unterschiedlichste Typen von Arten. Die haben Posts, Pictures, Comments, weißte Teufel was. Dann haben sie irgendwelche Videos drin, wo dann plötzlich so ein Flash-HTML-Code drin steht, mit dem man natürlich überhaupt nichts anfangen kann. Und dieses ganze Zeug, das ist ganz furchtbar. Und die API von Facebook, ich bin wirklich der festen Überzeugung, wenn Facebook eine Achilles-Ferse hat, dann ist es ihre unglaublich beschissene API. Die haben...
Ich kenne die von eBay.
Okay, das weiß ich nicht. Aber bei Facebook, Facebook hat drei unabhängige APIs. Nur? Die Facebook-App auf dem iPhone nutzt alle drei. Also das sind zwei offizielle und eine inoffizielle, die offensichtlich nur sie haben. Und du kannst mit der einen API Sachen machen, die du mit der anderen nicht kannst. Und du kannst, du kriegst unterschiedliche, also du kannst unterschiedlich viele Rechte anfordern von einem User, worauf du zugreifen willst. Und du kriegst komplett unterschiedliche Datensätze zurück, je nachdem, welche Rechte du angefordert hast. Und wenn du, du erfährst nicht mal, dass es diese anderen Datensätze gibt oder diese anderen Eigenschaften der Datensätze, bevor du nicht die Rechte angefordert hast, was du, du liest irgendwo, ja, wenn du das und das machst, dann siehst du folgende Daten und du siehst die einfach nicht. So, das ist ein ganz großer Penis erst und dann sind so, die sind einfach unglaublich unvollständig. Also zum Beispiel gibt es so eine Sachen, wenn, der schönste Fall wie ich fand, die Nachricht, also du kriegst so eine Timeline rein, die streamt halt schön vor sich hin und wenn jemand ein Foto von jemand anders kommentiert hat, dann kriegst du die Nachricht, sowieso hat ein Foto von jemand kommentiert. Die kriegst du einmal mit User-ID, einmal mit... und du kriegst einmal den String, sowieso hat ein Foto kommentiert, damit du dann auch direkt den String anzeigen kannst, ohne nochmal was machen zu müssen. Du kriegst aber weder einen Link zu dem Foto, sodass du mal eben rasch das Foto anzeigen kannst, noch kriegst du irgendwie einen Hinweis, was war denn eigentlich dieser Kommentar. Das heißt, wenn du jetzt daraus eine sinnvolle Information machen willst, musst du erstmal das Original Foto nochmal nachladen, hinten drum, und den Kommentar nachladen und dann kannst du langsam anfangen mit anzuzeigen. Und das ist wirklich, also ich hab wirklich noch, also es ist so ein Pain. Das ist wirklich schlimm.
Ok, eBay ist vielleicht doch nicht ganz so krass, obwohl die haben irgendwie, ich glaub, 5, 6 oder 7 APIs haben die irgendwie. Ok, das ist auch eine, und natürlich, je nachdem, was du machen willst, und Paypal ist ja nochmal ein eigenes Ding. Aber die haben aber nur eine API.
Aber die Paypal-API, da ist ja deren Sandbox. Die ist ja so lang, also ich weiß nicht, ob es immer noch so furchtbar langsam ist. Ich hab mal, wenn man gegen deren Sandbox entwickelt, Vormittags geht's.
Nachmittags ist es meistens nicht mehr möglich. Aber vormittags ist es okay. Nachmittags, wenn dann langsam die Amis aufstehen, dann wird es schwierig.
Ja, obwohl das bei Test-Flight mittlerweile genauso ist. Kannst du abends auch nicht mehr nutzen. Und was wollte ich jetzt noch zu Facebook, irgendwas wollte ich noch zur Facebook-API sagen? Dass es scheiße ist. Ach so, ja zum Beispiel diese Cover-Bilder, die man jetzt überhalten hat. Es gab eine Methode, mit der man die Cover-Bilder laden konnte. Die war einfach kaputt. So, die hat einfach nichts zurückgeliefert. Hier sind getreue Facebooks Motto Move fast and break things. Die hat einfach nicht funktioniert. Dann gab es da einen Haufen Bugreports, dass diese dämliche API nicht funktioniert. Was haben sie gemacht?
Die API gelöscht.
Also den Endpoint gibt es nicht mehr. Du kannst halt dieses Informationsstück nicht mehr... Das wäre natürlich schön, wenn wir da bei so einer App, die so verschiedene Sachen anzeigt, im Hintergrund irgendwie noch das Cover-Bild des Users anzeigen können. Nö, können wir nicht, weil wir haben bisher noch keine Möglichkeit gefunden, wie wir das Cover-Bild rauskriegen. Schlimme, schlimme, schlimme Schmerzen.
Hätte ich auch rausgeschmissen.
Aber die Leute wollen es natürlich.
eBay geht da den anderen Weg. eBay geht nämlich den Weg, du forderst eine Information an und kriegst ein massives Objekt zurück, von dem nur die Hälfte ausgefüllt ist. Und du musst dann rausfinden, mit welchem Call du dieses Objekt anforderst, sodass die Information ausgefüllt ist, die du eigentlich brauchst.
Ach so, du musst...
Also du kriegst immer das gleiche Objekt zurück, also so eine Auktion, ein wichtiges Item, kriegst immer ein Item zurück. Aber je nachdem, mit welchem API du dieses Item anforderst und mit welchem Call du dieses Item anforderst, kriegst du halt manche Dinge ausgefüllt, andere Dinge nicht ausgefüllt.
Aber immerhin, das ist ja schon mein Vorteil, du weißt, dass sie da sind. Das ist halt bei Facebook, du weißt nicht mal, ob du an der richtigen Stelle gerade suchst. Und dann krieg mal im Nachhinein noch raus, du willst ja nicht, ich kann für dich Freundschaftsanfragen stellen in deinem Namen und kann da deine Wordposts, das wollen wir alles gar nicht. Wir wollen ja eigentlich ein absolutes Minimalset an Rechten einfordern und krieg dann mal wieder, wenn es dann irgendwann mal geht, raus, welche Rechte du jetzt problemlos abschalten kannst und es immer noch funktioniert. Das ist wirklich schmerzerregend. Und natürlich sagenhaft schlecht dokumentiert, selbstverständlich.
Ja, du sollst dich ja auch bei Facebook anmelden, wenn nicht irgendwie die Daten von Facebook rausziehen.
Aber es ist sehr lustig, Buckreports kannst du liken. Und das ist dann quasi angeblich deine interne Priorisierung, wenn du abarbeiten willst. Also kannst du Facebook-Like und dann Buckreport runterpacken.
Das ist dann ja wenigstens konsequent.
Unglaublich.
Gut, weil wir hier schon bei Marantan sind, wollte ich mal Valve und deren Steam beraten.
Dann können wir ja noch kurz über dieses, muss ich jetzt mal kurz vorschieben, da gab es doch dieses Gerücht, dass Olle Tim Cook bei Valve irgendwie mal vorbeischaut. Aber war nicht, hat sich als Gerücht herausgestellt. Aber da gingen auch schon die Gerüchte los. Apple will irgendwie eine Spielkonsole machen, Apple will irgendwie das Valve Game des Debütens zentraler kaufen.
Was ich gehört hab, ist, dass Valve es nicht ausschließt, selber Hardware zu bauen oder bauen zu lassen, wenn es ihnen irgendwas bringt.
Aber was in den Konsolen oder in den Rechnern?
Keine Ahnung, so genau haben sie es nicht spezifiziert. Sie haben nur gesagt, wenn wir das machen müssen, dann bauen wir auch Hardware.
Ist der Laden denn so groß? Also haben die denn ordentlich Masse?
Sie sind wohl scheinbar von der Firmenkultur so, dass sie halt sagen, wir bauen jetzt nicht nur Spiele, wir machen jetzt noch ein Spiele-Content-Laden-Delivery-System auf und das nennen wir Steam und dann verkaufen wir für andere Leute Spiele. Was ja auch super geklappt hat.
Wir haben ja zwei Businesses. Einmal haben sie ja Codendier-Spieler. Half-Life 2 ist das berühmte richtige.
Portal.
Portal. Wobei Portal ist auch eher eingekauft von denen, oder? Waren es nicht? Echt?
Also Portal läuft auf jeden Fall auf der Half-Life-Engine.
The Cake is a Lie.
Genau. Meines Erachtens war Portal...
Das ist auch so ein Satz, den man immer bringen kann.
Zwei, drei, genau. Keine genug Gramm, aber der Cake ist a Lie. Und dann in Half-Life mit eingebunden als Minigame und später noch ein eigenes Game draus gemacht, ein richtiges.
Das kann durchaus sein, aber es läuft also auf der Half-Life-Engine.
Okay, also jedenfalls machen die Spiele und dann haben sie aber auch hier diesen Steam-Shop, kann man ja sagen, da ist ja ein Game-Shop, wo man halt alle möglichen Spiele kaufen kann. Und womit verdienen die mehr Geld?
Ich nehme mal an, dass sie mit dem Shop inzwischen sehr, sehr gut verdienen. Aber sie haben den Shop, glaube ich, auch nur an den Start gebracht, weil sie halt die eigenen Spiele hatten.
Hat sich aber dann doch gut durchgesetzt, weil da verkaufen sie inzwischen alles Mögliche drüber, nicht nur eigene Spiele, ne?
Jaja, die verkaufen sehr viele Spiele von Ubisoft. Und da komme ich jetzt...
Jetzt darfst du loslegen.
Da komme ich jetzt nämlich hin. Und zwar, das Spiel Assassin's Creed kennt ihr ja vielleicht. Also Assassin's Creed 1 gab es nie für einen Mac. Also angeblich gab es es auch mal für einen Mac, aber Assassin's Creed 2 gab es also tatsächlich auch oder gibt es immer noch im Mac App Store. Und ich wollte es dann spielen, habe dann geguckt bei Steam, hat es irgendwie weniger gekostet. Ich glaube nur zwei Drittel oder so. Und dann habe ich halt gesagt, naja gut, dann kaufst du es halt bei Steam. Kaufte das Spiel und es geht nicht. Auf Anhieb erst mal nur gecrashed. Ich habe diverse Dinge versucht, gecrashed. Ich habe dann gefragt, ob ich einen Refund haben kann. Das wollten sie nicht. Irgendwann war es mir zu blöd. Dann habe ich es im Mac App Store noch mal gekauft. Im Mac App Store hat es halt runtergeladen. Ich habe es gestartet, es ging. Habe es dann, naja gut, drei, weiß nicht, wie lange es gedauert hat.
Du hast jetzt zweimal dafür bezahlt?
Ja, ich hatte keinen Bock. Das war halt über die Weihnachtsfeiertage. Ich wollte es halt spielen, weil ich da Bock drauf hatte. Und dann habe ich es halt noch mal gekauft, weil es irgendwie halt nicht ging.
Jetzt weißt du, warum die so viel Geld verdienen. Durch schlecht sein doppelt so viel verdienen.
Irgendwann haben sie ja so ein Update gebracht und dann lief es auch unter Steam, aber dann hatte ich es eigentlich auch schon durch. Also das war dann auch egal. Assassin's Creed 2. So und dann wollte ich den Nachfolger spielen. Assassin's Creed 2 Brotherhood heißt der.
Und wo hast du zuerst gekauft?
Im Mac App Store gibt es es nicht.
Nochmal Steam probiert.
Nochmal Steam probiert, habe ich es nochmal gekauft. Ging wieder nicht. Dann habe ich ein bisschen geguckt. Das Spiel läuft nämlich nur auf 10.6. Auf 10.5 und 10.6. Aber es läuft nicht unterline. Also habe ich, um das Spiel zum Laufen zu kriegen, habe ich gedacht, naja, hast du noch dein Mac Mini rumstehen, da ist ein 10.6 drauf, dann machst du Firewire Target Disk Mode und bootest den halt auf 10.6. Also das MacBook Pro auf der Platte von dem Mac Mini. Hab das gemacht. Jetzt ist es so, dass es unter Steam gibt, es gibt irgendwie so eine Funktion, dass man ein Spiel archivieren kann. Der legt das dann irgendwie in CD- oder DVD-Größen Chunks ab und dann kann man das archivieren und man kann es auch wieder zurück spielen. Da habe ich gedacht, naja, dann archivierst du es halt schnell, bootest um auf das andere System, spielst die ganzen Chunks wieder ein und dann geht das alles flott. Hat nicht funktioniert. Dann habe ich das, also diese, ich glaube, sind 8 Gigabyte oder so, noch mal runtergeladen.
Noch mal?
Ja, noch mal. Und dann startest du dieses Spiel. Ich meine, allein Steam zu starten dauert irgendwie schon länger als dieses Assassin's Creed aus dem Mac App Store, bis es läuft. Also dieses Steam, das dauert ja ewig, dann connectet er sich. Letzte Woche war irgendwie Steam down, da konnte man sich gar nicht connecten, da ging überhaupt nichts. Also dann startest du dieses Steam, suchst das Spiel aus der Bibliothek runter, dann startest du das und das erste, was du kriegst, ist so ein Requestor, da steht drin, also das ist ihr CD-Key. Und dann kommt da so ein komischer CD-Key und dann gibt es da so zwei Button. Copy to Clipboard und Run. Und dann kannst du dein CD-Key ins Clipboard kopieren und dann Run drücken, weil dann wird es nämlich gestartet und das nächste, was du kriegst, ist dann eine Box, wo du diesen CD-Key wieder eingeben kannst.
Das ist ja mal bequem gemacht. Muss man nicht mal ausdrucken.
Ja, aber warum muss man diese CD-Key eingeben? Furchtbar.
Das wäre nicht mal ein Aufwand da irgendwie.
Es ist echt schlimm. Dann geht der nächste Request da auf, von Ubisoft, dass jetzt das Spiel geladen wird. Dann will er erst irgendwas updaten. Dann datet dann natürlich noch mal irgendwas ab. Und dann geht zum Schluss bei Ubisoft so eine Art Launcher auf, was wohl irgendwie so eine Copy Protection ist, die immer übers Netz guckt, ob du noch usw. das nicht doppelt spielst oder so. Und dann geht das Spiel los. Und dann hast du von Steam noch mal so ein komisches Overlay drüber. Über das Spiel noch mal so ein Here und da unten noch so ein Hinweis-Button und so. Und drück irgendwie Shift-Tab. Dann kannst du die und die Message sehen. Und damit die dann weggeht, dann drückst du da drauf. Dann wird der Bildschirm grau. Sie ist im Hintergrund noch das Spiel. Und hast dann dieses Zeug da irgendwie auf alles, was man nicht sehen will. Und das war echt ein Krampf. Und wenn das Spiel dann endlich läuft, hast du eigentlich überhaupt keinen Bock mehr, das zu spielen. Mich hat das total erinnert an dieses Ding. Der Unterschied zwischen einer gekauften DVD und wenn ich den Film von Pirate Bay gerippt hab, da hat mal so ein Typ so eine Grafik gemacht, wo du also siehst Dinge, die du nicht überspringen kannst. Völlig sinnfreies Menü und dann nochmal drei Werbefilmchen und so weiter. Anders hat mich das erinnert. Also das ist echt schlimm.
Da hab ich jetzt einen passenden Spruch dazu. Der Installer ist das Game. Passend zu, der Weg ist das Ziel.
Ja, aber da sieht man nochmal, wie bequem man auf dem iPhone ist. Da gibts ja noch 70 Cent aus, lädst das runter und hast dann keinen Bock mehr, das zu spielen.
Der erste Level, den du überhaupt erstmal schaffen musstest, das Spiel zu installieren und laufen zu lassen. Also, Assassin's Creed 2 Brotherhood kann ich empfehlen. Sehr schöne Grafik, super Spiel. Wenns geht. Aber alles, was außenrum ist, ist so zum Brechen. Es ist echt schlimm. Also irgendwie, vor allen Dingen dieses, kaum geht dieses komische Ubisoft-Loader-Ding los. Das ist auch so ein völlig kleinteilig zugepflastetes Ding. Du hast so das Gefühl, du bist da bei YouPorn oder so gelandet. Das heißt auch YouPlay, keine Ahnung. Also das ist irgendwie... Nee, also, ganz schlimm. Wenn es es im App-Store gegeben hätte, dann hätte ich es auch im App-Store gekauft bei Apple. Auch gerne für 20% mehr oder für 30% mehr, kein Problem. Aber nachdem das natürlich unter Leihen nicht läuft und überhaupt irgendwie tausend solcher Probleme hat und Ubisoft hat diese komische Copy-Protection mit ich muss die ganze Zeit im Netz online sein und so weiter, hat Apple wahrscheinlich gesagt, oh, nö, danke.
Was wird eigentlich mit dem Steam passieren, wenn Apple mal irgendwie anfängt, alles irgendwie in eine Sandbox zu packen und ihren eigenen Store zu pushen und so? Eigentlich müssten ja aus Eigeninteresse, wir versuchen dieses Steam von ihrer Plattform runterzukriegen, auf lange Sicht. Erstmal nicht, weil das natürlich auch die Plattform fördert, aber auf lange Sicht wollen die natürlich ihre Games über ihren eigenen Store verkaufen, weil die wollen ja 30 Prozent haben.
Du kannst das Steam wahrscheinlich, du kannst es sowieso nur quasi Third-Party installieren, also runterladen von der Webseite und installieren. Und wenn du da nicht in deinem unter Mountain-Line, da bei deinem Finanzheim Kreuzberg, da wie heißt das Ding, dieses Programm mit dem Turm, wo du einstellen kannst...
Gatekeeper?
Gatekeeper, genau. Wo du einstellen kannst, was du jetzt laufen lassen kannst oder nicht, keine Ahnung. Da musst du wahrscheinlich entsprechend die Sachen runterdrehen, dass es überhaupt geht. Also, naja, ich weiß nicht. Aber es war ein hochgradiger Krampf und ich kann echt irgendwie... Ich hab nicht Lust nochmal ein Steam-Game zu kaufen. Es macht überhaupt keinen Spaß.
So richtig schön ist es Steam nicht, aber dass es grundsätzlich funktioniert, finde ich schon eine gute Sache. Weil man kann da jetzt halt... Sonst wäre so was wie Portal ja nicht möglich gewesen. Dann würde es jetzt keinen Portal geben. Und auch die ganzen anderen Games, die jetzt alle so rüber schwappen langsam.
Wieso wäre das nicht möglich gewesen?
Na, möglich schon, wenn sie es halt gemacht hätten. Aber so sind sie jetzt auch tatsächlich bei diesen ganzen PC-Games, die vorher halt immer so ein bisschen fehlten, sind jetzt über die Steam-Plattform kommen die alle. Und zwar auch die älteren teilweise.
Ja, aber die müssen doch die Games trotzdem portieren. Also ich mein, Steam ist ja nicht die komplette App Store.
Ja, aber Steam ist ja auch so eine Art Game-Framework, oder? Und das nutzen halt viele Spieler.
Glaub ich nicht. Also wenn du das...
Wie heißt die? Wie heißt diese Engine?
Source?
Ich glaub es war Half-Life Source und Counter-Strike Source nochmal irgendwie.
Ja, das ist die 3D-Engine.
Ja zum Beispiel, da nutzen ja auch viele Games.
Ja, bei Assassin's Creed, die Engine heißt Scimitar. Beziehungsweise der Nachfolger heißt irgendwie anders, weiß ich nicht.
Meinst du, dass die alle da portieren nicht?
Und, und, und... Und jetzt Software mit ihrer, mit ihrer... Weiß ich nicht, Rage, wie auch immer dies für Engine jetzt gerade heißt. Und dann gibt's noch die Unreal Engine und so. Diese ganzen Engines, die musst du alle auf die Mac-Plattform erstmal ordentlich portieren, bevor du da anfangen kannst.
Ich dachte, dass Steam halt auch gleich schon so eine Art Framework mitbringt, dass du bestimmte Sachen dich gar nicht mehr kümmern musst, was ja auch Sinn macht.
Ja, das ist halt nur das DRM und das Verteilen der Inhalte. Mehr ist das bestimmt nicht.
Das heißt, wenn ich Portal über Steam runtergeladen habe, könnte ich dann nach Steam wegschmeißen und Portal laufen lassen? Ich glaube, das geht nicht. Es läuft nicht mehr ohne Steam.
Ich glaube auch. Das weiß ich nicht genau. Aber es ist auf jeden Fall so, dass das Programm selber, also jetzt mal abgesehen davon, dass da Steam DRM drin ist, müsste auch von Valve relativ einfach euren Make-App-Store zu tun sein. Also wie gesagt, mit Assassin's Creed 2 ging es ja.
Da haben die natürlich kein Interesse dran, weil die wollen Apple keine 30% nochmal überschieben.
Ja, klar. Aber ich meine, sie hätten natürlich darüber halt auch eine größere Audience. Na gut, für die Hardcore Gamer ist es dann auch schon egal. Aber so ist es halt. So ist es halt. Ich verurteile das. Ja, wahrscheinlich liegt das Problem auch mehr bei Ubisoft als bei Valve. Aber so diese Kombination aus Valve, Steam und Ubisoft ist glaube ich, das will man nicht.
So, wollen wir mal ein anderes Thema ansprechen? Haben wir noch welche?
Ich hab mal so kurz als Auflocker, habt ihr dieses Default Subject von diesem einem AT&T Telefon gesehen. Ich schmeiß das hier mal kurz in den Chat. Da hat jemand einen Screenshot von veröffentlicht. Und zwar so unten drauf steht, beim iPhone steht ja drin das Send from my iPhone. Da steht darunter Send via the Samsung Galaxy S TM2 Skyrocket TM, AT&T 4G LTE Smartphone.
Was soll man dazu noch sagen?
Ja, fand ich sehr... Ich glaube, das ist der Grund, warum es so lange dauert, bis neue Software-Updates rauskommen für...
Also alle so viel Zeit, das ist wahrscheinlich ein halbes... Den Namen immer komplett auszusprechen.
Das ist doch garantiert ein halbes Marketing Team.
Das erinnert so ein bisschen an diese Unterschriften unter den Filmplakaten, wo ja angeblich auch irgendwie Dutzende von Leuten solange feilschen, bis sie rausverhandelt haben, wessen Namen an welcher Stelle stehen darf.
Oh ja, diesen Kampf hab ich mal in Aktion erlebt.
Und das ist wahrscheinlich so die Bildunterschrift des Kinoplakats für gesendete SMS.
Das ist so ein typisches Meeting. Wir wollen da ein Subject drin haben. Ja, dann schreiben wir da Samsung Galaxy S rein. Ja, aber es heißt jetzt 2Sky Rocket. Ja, und dann kommt noch LTE dazu. Aber wir haben doch ein 4G-Netzwerk. Ja, aber wir haben das 4G-Netzwerk, was eigentlich nur ein 3G-Netzwerk ist. Und wir haben echt das LTE. Ja, gut, dann schreiben wir dann auch LTE. Da müssen wir noch hinterschreiben, dass es ein Smartphone ist.
Blablabla.
Dieses TM, dieses Thema an dem S, bezieht sich das nur auf das S, also das S, ein eigener eingewahrene...
Dann wären noch zwei TMs da, Mensch.
So, haben wir denn noch hier so Themen irgendwie auf der Karte?
Ja, ich hab noch Non-News zum Thema Apple Store und Apple Store Berlin.
Das dauert doch alles viel länger. Lass mich raten.
Nichts geht voran.
Wieso das denn?
Also bis vor wenigen Wochen bestand dieser Apple Store Berlin im Wesentlichen aus Baugerüsten. Da ist noch nicht eine Wand bemalt, da ist irgendwie nichts, da ist keine Treppe in Zelt, da ist kein Glas zu sehen, es ist einfach nur Gemäuer und Baugerüste und Gemäuer und Baugerüste. Scheint wohl nicht ganz so einfach zu sein, dieses Gebäude. Ich würde nicht unbedingt Geld drauf wetten, dass das Ding auch echt noch zu Weihnachten aufmacht. Ist jetzt schon noch ein bisschen hin, aber ich glaube, die müssen sich sehr anstrengen.
Von jemandem, der da vor Ort irgendwie...
Keine Ahnung.
Obligatorische Vögelchen wahrscheinlich, oder?
Das Wartkoll portiert.
Es gibt einfach Dinge, die werden im Äther...
Die sickern durch.
Die sind einfach dann... Die erscheinen auch. Auf irgendeine Art. Also manchmal träume ich das.
Manchmal hat er eine Erleuchtung.
Manchmal öffnet sich auch einfach ganz klassisch der Himmel.
Manchmal einfach nur der Stoff schlecht.
Wo ich mir denke, nicht der schon wieder. Das sind so die Quellen. Den kann man jetzt auch glauben oder nicht glauben.
Aber Gründe zum Beispiel hast du irgendwie nicht so. Also Apple hat ja wohl Interesse daran, dass das Ding mal irgendwie aus dem Moos-Topf kommt.
Ob die Gründe in der Form immer noch gelten, weiß ich nicht. Aber ich hatte ja schon mal davon berichtet, dass es halt da generelle Probleme mit der Statik und vielleicht auch mit den Nachbarn gab.
Nachbarn!
Wir werden nicht in diesem Sommer da irgendwie unsere kaputten iPhones auf den Tisch hauen, sondern später.
Aber wo soll ich denn mein iPhone 5 verausuchen?
Ich hab das ja immer damals nicht gewusst.
Also warten mit dem Kaputtmachen, das iPhone.
In der letzten Sendung schon mal angesprochen hab, aber das ist ja Haus Wien. Ich konnte damit nichts anfangen. Aber das ist das, was ich als Berliner so als Filmbühne Wien kenne, dieses Kino, richtig? Das ist dieses Kino, wo du reinkommst, wo dann gleich so zwei Treppen, glaube ich, so nach, zwei Rolltreppen so nach oben gingen, korrekt?
Genau.
Du hast unten deine Karte geholt und konntest dann so entspannt dich da hochfahren lassen. Ja, da war ich früher öfter mal, das war eigentlich ein ziemlich cooles Kino.
Ach, dann haben die die Rolltreppe rausgerissen und nicht eingebaut.
Genau, die haben die Rolltreppen alle rausgerissen.
Da, daaa, doch keine Rolltreppe.
Also, ich kann nicht sagen, dass es keine Rolltreppe geben wird, aber ich halte es für sehr wahrscheinlich, dass es keine geben wird, sondern es ist einfach die klassische...
Es sei denn, Johnny Ive hat die Gläser eine Rolltreppe.
Und was ich auch weiß, ist, dass Tim Cook selbst vor Ort war.
My heart's my trouble.
Dann wird's noch was vor.
Wäre ich hier nicht vorbeigekommen bei uns irgendwie?
Bei euch nicht, nee. Ja, nur für namens Vetter. Der war wohl vor Ort nicht sehr lange. Das war so einmal aha, aha, aha. Und weiter. Aber er hat ja neulich so eine Europa-Tour gemacht.
Echt? Kurz vor oder kurz nach seiner China-Reise da?
Ich kann das jetzt zeitlich nicht mehr einordnen gerade, aber es gab da mehrere Stationen.
Und hatte auch wie der Typ in meinem Game hier, ist da auch zum Beispiel zu Gravis hin und hat gesagt, Jungs, ihr habt ja demnächst auch eine schwere Zeit.
Ich glaub, das wissen die schon.
Nochmal so alt, auf die Schulter geklopft.
Ja, ich bin sehr gespannt, was Gravis Strategie ist.
Ich denke, die können ganz locker parallel im Wasser fahren. Das ist gar kein Ding, oder? Der Fluss ist breit genug.
Ich bin mir absolut sicher, was sie machen werden, was jegliche Konkurrenz von Apple macht. Sie werden am Anfang sagen, dass das überhaupt kein Problem ist, und dass man durchaus seine eigene Lebensberechtigung hat. Dann werden sie anfangen, Panik zu schieben. Aber ich glaube, Gravis geht es jetzt schon nicht so gut.
Dieser Apple Store kann ja nicht ganz Berlin abdecken. Ich glaube, Gravis doch, den geht es auch gut.
Aber Gravis geht es nicht gut.
Aber jetzt sind nämlich zu viele andere Läden gekommen. Früher war Gravis ja immer so ein Exklusiv-Ding. Da ist man hingegangen, wenn man Apples haben wollte. Inzwischen gibt es ja Apple bei... beim Döner jetzt nicht, aber bei... bei Santon und Zeugs oder gibt es jetzt... der ganze Apple-Kram, den gibt es doch jetzt auch. Und so Mini-Apple-Stände und so haben die dort auch.
Ja, aber das gibt es auch schon lange. Aber das stimmt, also bei Mediamarkt haben sie ja hier diesen Store-in-Store-Dingsbums.
Ja, aber jetzt gucken sie dir nicht wie ein Alien an, wenn du sagst, du hättest gerne einen Mac so im PC laden, sondern dann sagen sie, ja, klar, Martin ist da so. Früher musste es halt zu Gravis oder zu so Special-Läden.
Und der Graves, ich finde, der am Ernst-Reuter-Platz, früher sah der ja mal richtig schick aus. Und ich finde, der ist irgendwie ein bisschen aus der Form gegangen. Ich weiß nicht, ob es runtergerockt jetzt ist oder so was, oder ob man jetzt mittlerweile auch Besseres gewöhnt ist. Aber das ist schon, wenn ich den von draußen sehe, das sieht schon irgendwie so ein bisschen, naja, da könnte man schon mal nochmal eine Farbe überkippen.
Ich muss ganz ehrlich gestehen, dass ich da noch nie war.
Die haben einen Freiterplatz, der sieht ja runtergekommen aus.
So von draußen, also wie der Apple da so irgendwo, die haben so einen leuchtenden Apple da lieblos reingestellt, den sie nicht mal irgendwie an die Wand gepappt haben. Oder irgendwie auf einen... Und irgendwie, ja, ich finde das sieht irgendwie so ein bisschen, könnte ruhig...
Ich war da schon sehr lange nicht.
Also du bist wahrscheinlich mittlerweile wirklich total, wie sagt man, verzogen.
Verwöhnt.
Verwöhnt, ja.
Jaja, klar, also ich meine, früher war das ja so eher, da hat Gravis ja konkurriert mit diesen Kistenschiebern. Und da war es glaube ich nicht so schwer, ein bisschen gut auszusehen, aber jetzt mit den echten Apple Stores zu konkurrieren, das ist glaube ich schon hartes Brot.
Ja gut, derzeit konkurrieren sie vor allem nach wie vor mit den PC-Läden. Und ich glaube, da sind sie doch deutlich vorne.
Na also wenn du dir Cyberport anguckst, ich glaube die sind gut dabei.
Ich weiß nicht, da war ich noch nicht. Wie sieht der Laden aus?
Ja, sieht jetzt kein Design Store so, aber ja.
Ist aber schon schick irgendwie gemacht. Ist aufgeräumt schick. Es ist nicht so, dass ich da irgendwelche Boxen stapel wie bei so einem PC-Schieber, sondern ist alles schon im Lager. Und du kannst da irgendwie per Web vorbestellen oder irgendwie so. Und dann kannst du dann auch zum Express-Schalter und sagen, du willst nur abholen hier schnell, schnell. Und ansonsten haben die da alles Mögliche ausgestellt und haben irgendwie, ich würde mal sagen, ein Drittel des Lages ist irgendwie Apple-Stuff.
Also so 50-50 ziemlich exakt. Ich hab da ja in der Nähe gearbeitet und war dann da öfters mal. Und gerade das mit diesem Express, das fand ich immer ganz furchtbar, weil das ging nämlich überhaupt nicht, weil die hatten so im besten Fall drei Kassen. Von den zwei, also das war nicht so, dass eine Expresskasse dabei war, sondern es waren zwei Kassen, die gleichzeitig Kasse und Beratung waren. Und dann stand da irgendjemand vor dir, der sich ausführlich über eine Kamera beraten ließ. Und schon absolut klar war, dass du stand da und wolltest einfach nur was bezahlen, irgendwelche Scheiße. Also ich hab da wirklich teilweise 20 Minuten, eine halbe Stunde gewartet, bis ich endlich mal dran war. Das war wirklich schlimm. Und dann hinten bei dieser Lieferkasse, so richtig schnell geht das da auch nicht.
Ich hab da mal was irgendwie, hier so eine Grafikkarte zu Bitcoin-Zeiten, da war irgendwie eine Grafikkarte gerade hier refurbished oder was auch immer. Hab ich gesehen, war billig, hab ich gleich geklickt, bin hin, die ist kurz nach hinten, ist wieder nach vorne gekommen, hier, zack, unterschreiben, Geld, fertig.
Hab ich auch schon öfter gemacht.
Wenn du Glück hast, klar, dann wenn gerade niemand vor dir ist, dann geht das. Aber wenn da irgendwie, also ich hab auch öfter so gerade in der Mittagspause quasi, wenn dann kommen auf uns relativ viele vorbei, dass ich da auch schon wirklich, also nicht so lange, aber doch ganz schön lange gewartet habe.
Ich weiß nicht, ob der Huckel von seinem K&M-Stunt schon mal erzählt hat, hier wahrscheinlich schon, aber ich erzähl's nochmal, weil's halt so cool ist. Er war irgendwie bei K&M, die Schlange war lang und er dachte, so eine Scheiße jetzt hier so stundenlang warten, hat irgendwie sein iPhone, glaube ich, oder was auch immer, oder seinen Rechner rausgeholt, keine Ahnung, wie er es genau gemacht hat, oder telefonisch, hat jedenfalls irgendwie was vorbestellt zum Abholen bei K&M aus der Schlange raus. Und die haben gesagt, ja, okay, ist dann aus der Schlange rausgegangen, zum Express-Schalter gegangen und hat gesagt, ich würde gerade mein Stuff abholen und war dann halt sofort dran, hat sein Zeug bekommen und ist gegangen.
Das sollte man eh bei viel mehr Leben machen, sowas. McDonalds hat ja teilweise dieses am Bildschirm irgendwie, kannst du ausfüllen, brauchst du nur noch zur Kasse vorzugehen und das Zeug abzuholen. Warum muss man da noch ein Bildschirm haben, die nicht eine iPhone-App in der Hand vorbestellen kann?
Das ist halt schon fies, weil dann werden noch mehr Verkäufer entsorgt. Bei McDonalds brauchst du ja bald gar keinen mehr. Dann sind nur noch die Küchenleute da, die dann die Produkte in die entsprechenden Teile schieben und für dich geht dann irgendwie so eine Klappe aus, wenn du mit dem richtigen RFID, was auch immer, Zettelchen kommst oder Barcode, der dir gedruckt wurde. Bezahlen kannst du dann auch selber mit deiner Karte irgendwann.
Bezahlt hast du schon. Bezahlen geht da sowieso noch mit der Karte.
Das ist wie bei der Bahn.
Da gibt es diese Angestellten, die dann fragen, ob sie hier zum Essen oder zum Mitnehmen. Hier gibt es dann nicht mehr demnächst. Und schwuppst uns weg.
Gibt es die noch bei der Bahn, diese Automaten, wo du erst so deine Fahrkarte so zusammenstellst, dann drückst du, jo, und dann kommt unten halt der Zettel mit dem Barcode raus und mit dem gehst du dann irgendwie an den Automaten, wo du das Geld reinwerfen kannst. Scans das Teil, irgendwie schmeißt dein Geld dann da rein oder bezahlst mit der Karte und dann kommt die Karte raus, die Fahrkarte. Gibt es die noch, die Dinge?
Keine Ahnung, ich fahre solche Ahnen keine Bahn mehr, weil ich hab ja Motorrad.
Ich war neulich bei der Bahn, ja. Muss mir neulich einen neuen Führerschein holen. Weil ich meinen alten Führerschein...
Bei IKEA ist das glaub ich so, wenn du da so Support-Gramme kaufst, da gibt es so einen Bezahlautomaten.
Also auf jeden Fall war das beim Verkehrsamt und da kann man sich online, zumindest in Berlin, kann man sich da einen Termin reservieren, was ich glücklicherweise gemacht hab. Weil ich kam an, setzte mich dahin mit meinem Terminnummer, kriegte mit wie um mich rum sich so ein leichter Aufstand, wie dann so einer so aufschaut, ist ja noch jemand, der eine Nummer so und so hat, ich sitze hier seit vier Stunden rum und nichts passiert und so was. Und während der sich noch aufregte, bing, leuchtete meine Nummer und ich bin reingegangen, war eine Viertelstunde später wieder draußen und dann haben die mir einen Ausweis zugeschickt.
Hättest du dem Opa mal gesagt, hast du kein Internet, wa?
Der war kein Opa, der machte aber ein bisschen aggressiven Eindruck. Ich dachte, den der mit sein mit war...
Vielleicht hat der schon einmal rum, weißt du so, einmal den Overflow des Zählers mitgemacht an dem Tag.
Das ging auch wirklich in dem... Also da war es nicht sonderlich voll in dem Raum und die machten auch nicht mehr lange auf, soweit ich das verstanden habe. Also es schien da eher gemütlich voran zu gehen. Wollen wir nicht mal über dieses Ikea-Link da reden?
Oblijava.
Ja, jetzt, ihr könnt es alle nicht aussprechen, oder?
Das ist wirklich...
Strange.
Da hab ich echt einen Hut gezogen vor Ikea.
Das ist eine geile Idee.
Ja, bei Ikea muss man auch echt sagen, das ist eine Firma, die hat man normalerweise irgendwie nicht so...
Auf dem Radar.
Auf dem Radar. Aber irgendwie alle zwei Wochen oder vier Wochen, wenn man dann doch da einfach ganz automatisch mal hinfährt...
Alle zwei bis vier Wochen?
Weil...
Hast du zu viel Geld?
Nee, ich hab jetzt nie mehr zu viel Geld, weil ich bin alle zwei Wochen bei Ikea. Es gibt da eine Menge Leute, die sind da häufig. Ich bin nicht alle zwei Wochen bei Ikea. Aber es ist bei mir schon so. Und jetzt könnt ihr alle mit dem Finger auf mich zeigen, aber ich garantiere euch, bei euch ist es genauso. Du denkst aber nach so, ich könnte hier nochmal irgendwie so eine Lösung brauchen für Problem X in was auch immer.
Da noch was an die Wand spachsen.
Ja, und vielleicht wenn ich hier noch ein Regal oder da noch irgendwie einen Schrank hätte und so weiter. Das erste, wo du guckst, ist irgendwie Ikea. Weil, und jetzt ist nämlich die große Frage, warum macht man das eigentlich? Du hast so viele Gründe, warum man das macht. Also erstmal natürlich die Vielfalt, die du da hast, dann diese häufig vorzufindende exzessive Modularität und Kombinierbarkeit mit anderem Scheiß, den du auch schon kennst. Dann dieses Prinzip, also warst du mal einmal bei Ikea, kommst du mit jedem Ikea auf dem ganzen fucking Planeten klar. Das ist ein bisschen wie mit McDonalds. Du weißt, wie es läuft. Du kommst rein, dann kommst du dadurch durch diesen Zauberwald von Wohnsituationen. Den musst du dir dann irgendwie geben und wenn du keinen Bock hast, dann weißt du auch, dass irgendwie alle 50 Meter eine Abkürzung lauert. So und dann das Tralala durch und dann darfst du irgendwie so the full shopping experience bis auf zwei, drei Sonderangebote einsammeln und wenn du es richtig hart gibst, dann hast du halt auch noch irgendwie die dicken, fetten, mega Lagerregale, wo du diesen Großscheiß rausziehst oder noch was.
Du hast was vergessen. Zwischen dem man rennt durch die Wohnsituationen und geht runter ins Kauflager, gibt es noch die Schött-Boulard und die Snickers-Torte.
Also die Schött, wie auch immer diese Dinger heißen, diese kleinen Fleischkügelchen mit hässlicher Soße.
Schött-Boulard. Angeblich ja, aber ich bin auch kein Experte.
Die fand ich, ich hab die einmal gegessen und fand sie furchtbar. Aber es gibt ja Leute, die fahren die...
Ich hab das jetzt nur gesagt, weil jeder genau weiß, was ich meine, wenn ich Schött-Boulard sage. Klar, da gibt es auch andere Sachen und ich ess die eigentlich auch nicht, aber naja.
Aber es ist vor allem, der Scheiß ist auch, also jetzt nicht billig, aber im Vergleich zu anderen Möbelhäusern, wenn ich mir irgendwie so Möbelhübner angucke, wo alles aussieht wie eine 60er Jahre Schrankwand und dann aber irgendwie ein Vermögen. Oder wenn es nach was aussieht, dann kostet es gleich 5000 Euro für einen Stuhl oder sowas.
Aber was das eigentlich geile ist bei IKEA, ich meine, da gibt es eine Menge Scheiße. Aber dann gibt es auch immer wieder so ein paar Sachen, wo man sich denkt, meine Güte, da hat mal endlich jemand über dieses Problem nachgedacht. Das ist etwas, was mich zumindest häufig beschleicht. IKEA macht sich schon wirklich einen Kopf. Und vor allem Design spielt immer eine verdammt große Rolle. Teilweise stellen sie auch die Designer da ins Rampenlicht. Das ist bei ihnen auch so ein Prinzip. Und die sind sicherlich auch jetzt nicht unbedingt gerade im verschlavten Zustand, diese Leute. Sondern das spielt für diese ganze Idee IKEA eine verdammt große Rolle. So, und jetzt haben sie das Problem erkannt. Die Leute kriegen ihren Scheiß Fernseher nicht kombiniert mit den Möbeln. Die wissen immer nicht, was sie kaufen sollen. Wahrscheinlich haben die dieses Problem weltweit die ganze Zeit, dass irgendwelche Leute da in dieser Wohnzimmerabteilung stehen und sich stundenlang irgendwie Diskussionen darüber anhören müssen, wo jetzt die Kabel langgelegt werden, wo man jetzt dieses und jenes Gerät reinkriegt. Und es ist immer dieser austauschbare Trash, der sowieso immer total Scheiße sich bedienen lässt, immer scheiße aussieht, auch immer gleich aussieht. Ja, gut, der eine Bildschirm ist 3 Millimeter dicker als der andere. Das war es dann im Wesentlichen. Aber überfrachtete Fernbedienung und du willst irgendwie deinen Blu-Ray und deinen Porn und deinen Avi und so weiter abgespielt bekommen und mehr interessiert die Leute nicht.
Und du möchtest den Scheiß eigentlich nicht sehen.
Genau, und du willst ihn nicht sehen und du willst auch irgendwie keinen Stress haben beim Anschließen voneinander, wo die Leute auch regelmäßig vollkommen überfordert sind. Und wahrscheinlich spielen solche Szenarien auch bei Apple am laufenden Meter eine große Rolle. Diese ganze Apple-TV-Überlegung der letzten Jahre dreht sich im Wesentlichen um die Vereinfachung dieses Prinzipes und mit weniger Kabel usw. ist ja Apple auch relativ weit vorne mit diesem ganzen WLAN-Klimpe. Jetzt kommt IKEA auf einmal von hinten und kündigt an, dass sie ab sofort selber diese Elektronik verkaufen, was auch irgendwie echt naheliegend ist, weil das ist so, wie sagt man, so commoditize. Ob da nun Samsung draufsteht oder keine Ahnung, ist alles dieselbe Suppe.
Alles gleich Scheiß. Vor zwei Jahren war ich das letzte Mal auf der IFA und da war gerade dieses 3D unglaublich neu.
Boah, furchtbar.
Ja, jetzt abgesehen davon, dass es furchtbar ist. Was ich eigentlich sagen wollte war, die hatten alle die gleichen Brillen. Du bist da von Halle zu Halle gerannt.
Es gab nur einen Hersteller im Wesentlichen, der so...
Es gab wahrscheinlich nur einen Hersteller für diese 3D-Panelen und es gab nur einen Hersteller für diese 3D-Brillen. Und in jeder Halle hast du den gleichen Scheiß gesehen. Die Rahmen, die waren mal ein bisschen dicker, mal ein bisschen dünner, mal silbern, mal schwarz, aber im Prinzip haben alle das Gleiche verkauft. Also diese Commoditization von diesem Markt ist so dermaßen weit fortgeschritten. Damit reißt du niemanden mehr vom Hocker. Das ist alles das Gleiche.
Es sei denn, du gehst halt wirklich das Problem an, was das eigentliche Problem ist. Nämlich, dass du nicht weißt, wie du die Scheiße in deine Schrankwand kombiniert bekommst. Und das ist genau das, wo IKEA jetzt...
Die Schrankwand mitverkauft.
Genau, die Schrankwand zum Fernseher verkauft.
Aber es ist doch eigentlich...
ZB den Fernseher zur Schrankwand. Je nachdem, wie rum man das sieht. Das ist eigentlich mehr der Fernseher zur Schrankwand. Weil der Fernseher ist so egal. Die Leute halten von der Marke IKEA genauso viel, wenn nicht sogar noch mehr, als von...
Gut, das bleibt abzuwarten.
Ho Chi Minh. Ich glaube, das Ding wird einschlagen wie eine Bombe.
Ich bin mal gespannt darauf, wie das von der Bedienung wird und sowas. Also das müssen sie auch noch alles auf die Reihe kriegen.
Also ich zweifle auch nicht da dran, dass sie das Teil loswerden. Also da zweifle ich überhaupt nicht dran. Ich denke nicht, dass sie bei den, sag ich mal, nicht Möbelfeatures so ein polishes Produkt rausbringen werden, wie Apple das tun wird. Sollten sie es je tun. Aber ich denke, sie kriegen das verkauft, auf jeden Fall. Natürlich. Ich würde wahrscheinlich aufgehen.
Hat die jemand im Kopf?
Nö.
Also zwischen 400 und 600 Euro, glaube ich.
Die waren so... nach erstem Dafürhalten waren die realistisch.
Das nimmst du mal eben mal mit.
Naja, mal eben mitnehmen, vielleicht nicht, aber...
Doch, doch, doch, doch, doch. Weil, wer geht zu Ikea? Also ich meine, viele Leute gehen zu Ikea, aber was ist so eins der typischen Szenarien ist, Kind zieht aus.
Leute ziehen um.
Nee, Kind zieht aus. Du startest deine erste...
Hatte ich jetzt noch nicht, aber...
Wohnung. Nicht dein Kind zieht aus, sondern du bist ein Kind und ziehst aus.
Ach so, ja.
Das meine ich jetzt. Also du ziehst aus bei den Eltern. Leere Wohnung, dein Besitzstand, außer vielleicht zwei, drei Items, die du tatsächlich von zuhause mitnehmen willst, ist eigentlich gleich null. Weil du willst natürlich jetzt nicht die Schrankwand der Eltern mitnehmen, sondern du willst weg. Du willst, dass es anders ist.
Und du hast kein Geld.
Du hast keine Kohle. Du gehst zu Ikea und das Erste, was du siehst, ist hier 300 Euro dein ganzes Wohnzimmer. Diese ganzen billigen Kombos und so weiter. Und was braucht so das ausziehende Kind natürlich auch? Fernseher!
Also ich seh's ja eher umgekehrt.
Und den kaufst du einfach gleich mit. Du kaufst einfach die ganze Wohnung, einschließlich Fernseher und demnächst sind vielleicht auch noch ein paar ganz andere Sachen dabei.
Also ich seh's ja eher umgekehrt. Ich seh's eher so, Kind zieht aus. Ich geh, als geht mit meinem Kind in Ikea, sage oh, weißt du was, nimm den scheiß Fernseher mit, ich hol mir das Ding hier.
Aber...
Das kann auch sein, ja.
Was nimmst du mit?
Dass ich mir dann den Fernseher hole, nicht das Kind. Warum soll ich denn da Kabel hinten rumhängen haben an meinem Fernseher?
Ich im Sinne von...
Als Elternteil.
Ja, wenn du Ikea-Eltern bist oder hast, dann ist das einsehbar. Ich hatte Ikea-Eltern. Weiß nicht, also... Nee, aber ich glaube, es sind auch... Komisches Bratzen im Stream, sagt der Chat. Bratzen.
Ja, das ist aber schon wieder... Timmer gibt sich wieder die Koffein-Dosis.
Ich weiß auch nicht, was sie reden. Redet einfach weiter, lasst euch nicht...
Also, es gibt halt auch immer noch die Leute, die jetzt irgendwie dieses ganze Flachbildschirm-Zeug beäugt haben, kritisch. Und irgendwie, es wurde immer größer, es wurde immer billiger. Und irgendwie haben sich die Formate ständig gewechselt. Und die so und so Ready-Aufkleber wurden auch immer mehr. Und ich kann mir vorstellen, dass diverse Leute einfach irgendwie so auch verunsichert sind. Was passiert da? Ständig werden einem die nächste Revolution verkauft. Und dann kommt dann IKEA an und sagt, Fernseher. Sonst haben sie ja noch nichts dazu gesagt. Sie sagen einfach nur Fernseher. So groß, so viel Geld. Das ist doch mal ein aufgeräumtes Angebot. Da muss ich mich nicht darum kümmern, ob das Skat oder HDMI hinten dran ist. Oder weiß ich nicht.
Nur Rahmenfarbe?
Sondern nur, da ist das Möbel-Skölpfel-Pröp oder wie das dann heißt, unten drunter mit Rahmenblöda.
Oder wie auch immer.
Und dann kauft man das. Und dann tut das einfach. Und die Kabel sind auch weg.
Ein Lego-Fernseher wär's doch.
Uplever.
Hätten sie auch anders nennen können.
Uplever ist nicht mein neuer Name. Das ist nicht mein neuer Name. Die haben schon Uplever jetzt schon. So heißen deren Fernsehtische und sowas schon jetzt.
Ach so, ja, siehst du mal genau, wie ich schon sagte, der Fernseher zur Schrankwand.
Genau, das ist Teil des Möbelstücks. Jetzt muss man den blöden Fernseher nicht mehr selber oben drauf stellen, sondern den packen wir mit in die Kiste rein. Ob dann auch so ein Fernseher dabei ist und man hat dann diesen kleinen, muss ja eigentlich, das ist ja bei jedem Ikea-Möbelstück dabei.
Ich glaube, das ist so für Leute, die, weißt du, so alle halbe Jahr verkauft Aldi wieder einen neuen PC und wenn ich einen neuen PC kaufe und Aldi verkauft gerade einen, dann kauf ich den. So, für solche Leute ist das genau richtig. Ich will einen Fernseher, die ganzen Details, egal. Ah, von Ikea gibt es einen, der passt sogar zu allem anderen.
Den nehm ich.
Genau, weil du den Christen einfach, wie sagt man so schön, in Wagenfarbe lackiert, in Wagenfarbe lackierte Außen...
Hammerschlag, grün.
Spiegel und wie heißen die Dinger? Stoßfänger.
Ob man dann auch so Späße machen kann, wie... Also ich meine, die Fernbedienung von dem Ding, die sah jetzt auch nicht unbedingt hübsch aus, oder? Ich meine, bei IKEA kann ich mir...
Das geht.
Kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen, dass die das ganze Prinzip auch übertragen auf so dieses ganze andere Zeug. Also die bieten ja den eigenen Blu-ray-Player dazu an und sowas, das machen sie ja. Und dass sie dann halt sagen, dass sie dann in einer Kasse so mit der, oh, kauft ihr jetzt noch so einen neuen Couch, den passt eine Fernbedienung dazu. Weil ich meine, das ist ja nun wirklich, man kauft sich irgendwie ein neues schönes Wohnzimmer und dann hat man da diese gleiche Riege an hässlichen, schwarzen oder silbernen Fernbedienungen rumfliegen, die alle viel zu groß sind und eh immer an der falschen Ecke liegen. Wahrscheinlich wird es dann auch Sofas mit eingebauten Fernbedienungen geben oder irgendwie sowas.
Das glaub ich nicht. Aber es gibt vor allem nur eine.
Doch!
Machen sie bestimmt.
Fast.
Aber dass es nur eine gibt, also das davon gehe ich auch fest aus.
Also, I applaud this move und ich glaube, das ist so ein bisschen auch...
Sie haben das Problem erkannt.
Sie haben das Problem erkannt und da werden sie auf jeden Fall...
Sie haben es auch so perfekt für ihre Branche gelöst. Sie haben gedacht, wie geht ein Möbelbauer an dieses Problem ran, indem man Möbel draus macht? Das kann denen keiner nachmachen. Das ist, stellt euch ein Samsung-Möbelstück vor.
Das wird er...
Und sie haben vor allem Retail. Ja, und sie verkaufen auch im richtigen Moment. Nämlich, wenn dann diese ganzen Elternflüchtlinge da aufkreuzen und sagen so, oh, meine Wand ist nur 3 Meter mal 1,20 und ja.
Ich weiß nicht, ob sich das so sehr an die Kinder wennt, aber so...
Nicht nur an die Kinder, aber das ist doch dieses Ding irgendwie. Jeder hat das schon mal gemacht. Du ziehst in eine leere Wohnung so, du hast nichts. Ich meine, irgendwann nach 10, 20 Jahren...
Also ich ziehe eigentlich...
Nee, das ist das Problem, dass du zu viel Zeug hast.
Ja, ja, ich kenne das. Aber sie haben das auch so, die haben ja so diese Küchenlösung. Das ist ja immer so, wenn man den IKEA-Katalog durchblättert, die haben ja auch immer so extrem viel. Und da irgendwie was hinpacken und da eine Kabelkiste und da die Spielzeugkiste und hier ist das, wo das ganze Küchenzeug reinpackt. Und jetzt haben sie das Ganze einfach noch für das Wohnzimmer gebaut. Und hier ist deine Kiste, wo du die Kiste reinstellst und dann packst du unten deine HDMI-Scheiß dran.
Ja, aber was ich, um mal ein bisschen rumzumeckern, noch an IKEA, wo ich ja wirklich echt enttäuscht bin, das ist so ihre elektronische Präsenz. Also außer diesen Flash-basierten Küchenplaner und einer wirklich hochgradig peinlichen iPhone ab, die im Lesen nichts anderes macht als ein übergewichtiges PDF mit dem Katalog-Inhalt runterzuladen.
Ich hab das nur einmal gemacht und ich fand das so geil, wenn man diesen Katalog runtergeladen hat, dann gab es einen Dialog, da stand drauf, Deutschland wurde heruntergeladen.
Ich spucke jetzt nicht den Kaffee um.
Das war einfach großartig.
Das hat für einiges entschädigt, finde ich.
Oh Gott, das im Rahmen der aktuellen Ureberrechtsdebatte. Deutschland hat heruntergeladen.
Klingt so ein bisschen wie Deutschland halt fertig. Deutschland wurde heruntergeladen.
Wurde heruntergeladen, ja.
Was ist denn da los bei diesem Fußball? Es ist total spannend.
Es ist 2-1 und geht jetzt in die Verlängerung. Und zwar deswegen, weil im Hinspiel die Bayern 2-1 gewonnen haben.
Es ist jetzt komplett ausgeglichen 3-3. Jetzt ist Verlängerung und danach gibt es vielleicht noch 11 Meter Schießen. Wenn es 11 Meter Schießen kein Ergebnis bringt, dann gibt es freies Duellieren.
Oh mein Gott!
Freies Duellieren?
Ja klar. Da freu ich mich schon drauf.
Wird dann die Münze nochmal geworfen?
Nee, die schießen dann so mit Feuerwerkskörpern auf.
Keira spielt hier bei den Spaniern, ja? Verstehe.
Und Özil.
Woher wusstest du denn jetzt, wie es gerade in dem Spiel steht?
Er ist ja einer der Schauspieler von der WF.
Ach du gehst einfach auf Spiegel. Dein Fußballwissen lädt sich gerade auf Spiegel online.
IKEA findet er nicht so spannend. Bist du nie bei IKEA?
Dann war ich jetzt schon seit neun Jahren nicht mehr.
Also wenn ich in der IT von IKEA was zu sagen hätte, dann vielleicht ist das ja so, vielleicht sind sie ja schon auf diesem Weg, aber ich würde mir dieses iPad nicht entgehen lassen. Das iPad mit so einer interaktiven IKEA-Anwendung, was mich in diesem Scheiß-Laden mal so richtig strategisch durch die Gegend navigiert.
Bist du verrückt? Nee, abgelehnt.
Was?
Da bist du ja viel zu schnell durch den Laden raus, weil du den Ausgang finden könntest.
Hast du mehr Zeit dir andere Scheiße einzuladen.
So Augmented Reality-Scheiß. Das sag ich mir sowieso, so eine App, du druckst dir irgendwie so ein...
Augmented Reality, bitte dich, 3D-Brillen.
Nee, du druckst dir irgendeinen Code für zu Hause aus, hängst den einfach dahin, wo du das Möbelstück nachher haben willst, und dann können wir das einfach als entsprechendes Möbelstück einblenden und du kannst mal gucken, wie würde es denn ungefähr hierhin passen und würde es denn überhaupt hierhin passen und würde es denn gut aussehen überhaupt. Und das dann noch so im Laden, dass du einfach so vor den... da siehst du den Schrank und dann gibts noch in 500 anderen...
Aber warum sollte ich dann noch zur Ikea laufen, wenn ich das doch auch schon zu Hause machen kann?
Dann bestellst du es halt nach Hause. Also ich meine, das interessiert nur... Also das ist ihm glaube ich auch recht. Oder eben du stellst es, gehst damit durch den Laden und dann steht da, ja, das ist der Schrank, davon gibts noch 528 andere Paneele und dann hast du halt dein Iphone-App und dann kannst du es davor halten und dann kannst du es mal mit den anderen Panelen angucken. Wär doch ja nicht so schlecht.
Okay, das ist interessant, aber erstmal müssen sie dir andere Hausaufgaben lösen. Also du kannst jetzt noch nicht mal dir irgendwie das zusammenklicken und dann sagt der dir auch genau, wo die Scheiße steht, im Ikea in Lichtenberg.
Du meinst im großen Hochregall Lager in welchem...
Ja genau, also du musst da an Bildschirme rangehen, wo du da vor Ort eingibst, la la la, wo ist denn, hmmm. Oder du kannst an so einem Infostand hingehen und so weiter.
Ja, das ist natürlich lame.
Ja, ich meine im Apple Store kannst du schon irgendwie auf deinem eigenen Telefon bezahlen. Das ist irgendwie noch mal ein ganz anderer Freiheitsgrad. Und die versuchen das ja auch so mit, sei dein eigener Sklave und scanne deine eigene Artikel ein, was für dich eine extrem erniedrigende Erfahrung ist, aber leider trotzdem schneller ist als die andere Kasse.
Oh, bei Real gab es so eine Selbstscan-Kasse.
Kann natürlich auch geil bescheißen, aber was soll's.
Die hat... Ich war schon seit bestimmt einem Jahr nicht mehr bei Real, aber früher war ich da relativ häufig und hab so im Vierteljahrestakt dann auch mal diese Selbstscan-Kasse ausprobiert. Und das wurde dann irgendwann mal besser.
Das ist dann alle zwei Wochen Real.
Jetzt ja nicht mehr. Jetzt geh ich wie sich das für einen Prenzlberger gehört, zur LPG.
Und sprichst mit den Bio-Schweinen noch persönlich?
Selbstverständlich. Aber damals war das dann... Und diese Kasse, das ist so bei jedem, bei jeder Bierflasche, die man drüber geschoben hat, 69 Cent, 9 Cent Pfand.
Und das musstest du bei jeder...
Du konntest es auch nicht abbrechen. Du musstest diesen ganzen Schlamassel jemals fertig... Und irgendwann ging es dann, dass du es direkt nachscannen konntest. Aber am Anfang, der hat treu seinen Spruch aufgesagt, auch nach dem 20. Bier, wie viel das jetzt gekostet hat. Also da ist IKEA wahrscheinlich schon deutlich weiter. So eine einfachen Beep-Scan-Kasse.
Hier wird gerade korrekt angemerkt, dass früher ja in den IKEA-Katalogen immer Max standen. Das haben sie dann irgendwann mal sein gelassen.
Als es dann zu schlimm wurde.
Ja.
Na irgendwie hat es sich Dell eingekauft oder HP oder so. Als sie haben sich eingekauft? Bin ich mir ziemlich sicher, klar. Wenn das keine Werbung ist.
Aber auch die Zeit, wo das alles nicht mal anders aussah.
Der IKEA-Katalog war eine Zeit lang das Print-Produkt mit der höchsten Auflage der Welt. Ich weiß nicht, ob es dann noch so viel kann sein. Ich weiß nicht, also es war auf jeden Fall mal so.
Da schmeißen die nicht immer noch hier jedem irgendwie einen neuen Katalog in den Briefkasten, der sich nicht dagegen wehrt.
Ich hab schon lange keinen mehr gehabt. Na, bei dir wissen sie mittlerweile, dass du eh nicht vorbeikommst.
Das ist Verlängerung.
Dann gehen wir auch in die Verlängerung, oder?
Können wir machen. Haben wir noch was?
Keine Ahnung, hat jemand dieses Google Drive schon ausprobiert?
Ich hätte es ja gerne ausprobiert, aber...
Das Logo erinnert mich immer an eine Bank hier in Deutschland, oder?
Von Google Drive?
Ja, bisschen schon.
Oder was, die Dresden mit dem grünen Band der Sympathie? Irgendwie sowas.
Ich weiß nicht, irgendwie sowas.
Kann mir das mal einer kurz pitchen, weil ich hab das ehrlich gesagt nur am Rande mit...
Es gibt eine Webseite, da steht drauf, dass bald Google Drive kommt und das hast du noch.
Google Drive ist noch nicht bereit, steht hier. Und you need to upgrade your Adobe Flash Player to watch this video.
Also ich hab ja da nicht mehr so großes Vertrauen in Google Produkte nach diesem Google Wave Desaster.
Das stimmt auch wieder mit irgendwie, wir indizieren erstmal hier alle deine Files und laden das zu Google hoch.
Na jetzt zu Google hochladen, darum geht's ja. Also das ist ja der Sinn der Sache, dafür installierst du es ja.
Was ich letztens gemacht hab, ja meine Mama war zu Besuch. Nur mal jetzt um Google, weil die indizieren alles. Hab ich meiner Mom irgendwie, die meinte, eine Bekannte von ihr sagt, sie hätte Spamprobleme, meine Mutter nutzt aber Google Mail. Ich konnte es ja nicht ausgehen, oder? Ich hab ihr sogar eingeredet, weiß ich gar nicht. Jedenfalls hab ich ihr meine Test-Mail geschickt und da hab ich auch irgendwas von Ratz-Fatz reingeschrieben und dann kam gleich bei ihr das an, aber natürlich mit Werbung gleich über Ratz-Fatz und irgendwie Rohrreinigungsprodukte. Und da mein ich, ihr seht ja, deswegen ist Google-Mail eigentlich scheiße, weil die lesen die Mail mit und geben dir dann die passende Werbung. Das wollte meine Mutter nicht so richtig glauben. Dann hab ich gesagt, okay, dann lass uns ein Experiment machen. Dann hab ich ihr noch eine Mail geschrieben, wo ich so getan hab, als wenn wir uns zum Reiten verabreden, weil mein Pferd ist jetzt wieder gesund oder tralala hab ich reingeschrieben. Irgendwie sowas. Und dann kam tatsächlich bei ihr die Mail an und dann kam Pferde, Futter und Scheunen-Werbung oder was weiß ich nicht. Alles passend zum Pferd und dann meine Mutter so, aha Tatsache. Also Jungs, die bei Google, die gehen in eure Mails rein.
Gnadenlos.
So, jetzt kannst du bei Google Drive weiter machen. Weil da machen die das dann natürlich auch. Also nicht, dass sie die Menschen von Google irgendwie dann den Inhalt lesen, aber die Agents, so wie die früher mal hießen, lesen das schon und passen dann ihre Werbung für die Werbekunden an.
Also im Wesentlichen ist Google Drive ja ein Angriff auf Dropbox.
So könnte man es sagen, ja.
Ja, ist ja alles so die gleiche Ecke. Ich wollte ja nur ein bisschen rumstehen können.
Na, man muss da schon ein bisschen...
Also es gibt jetzt auch dieses Microsoft Sky Drive, wohl irgendwie eine neue Version, was jetzt auch so ist wie...
Oh, ich kriege gerade Feedback von Panic. Ich habe Twitter, über Twitter habe ich Panic irgendwie...
Gedisst.
Entschuldigung, ich wollte den nicht hinterbrechen. Wir können ja gleich drauf eingehen.
Bei diesem Microsoft SkyDrive, wo man auch irgendwie relativ viel Speicher kriegt, bei Google kriegt man jetzt auch...
Was kriegt man da?
25 Gigabyte oder sowas? Nee. Fünf? Fünf Gigabyte? Was ist der Standard bei Dropbox? Zwei. Also ein bisschen mehr als bei...
Ja, also zwei Dollar fünfzig kriegst du pro... Warte mal, wie war das?
Pro Monat. Kriegst du dann 25 Gigabyte.
Ja, mit einem Upgrade auf 25 für weniger als zwei Dollar fünfzig...
Sind zwei neunfünfzig.
Das heißt...
So 30 Euro im Jahr.
30 Euro für 25 Gigabyte und ich zahl bei Dropbox 50 Euro für 50 oder so.
Kann das sein?
Ich dachte, das wäre schon deutlich günstiger gewesen, aber mal gucken, was bei Dropbox so ein Upgrade kostet.
Na vergiss das immer so. Aber ich hab mir das ja mal wirklich gekauft, ne?
Ich hab ja da über Affiliate Links hab ich mir das auf 7,5 Gigabyte ausgebaut.
Und das funktioniert ganz.
Ich hab hier nicht mal ein Upgrade-Button. Die wissen, dass ich da so unglaublich wenig belege, dass ich gar nicht kaufen brauch. Pricing, da ist Pricing. Pro 50 kostet 100 Dollar pro Jahr. Also schon deutlich teurer.
Viermal so viel für doppelt so viel. Also das doppelte, genau. Also sie haben quasi den Preis.
Sie haben sozusagen schon einen billigen Einstiegspreis und dann geht's aber nach oben anstatt herunter mit den Preisen pro Gigabyte. Also es wird nicht billiger, sondern eher teurer. Sozusagen der Anfängspreis ganz unten.
Ja, ich meine gut, ich glaub Dropbox wird sich... Na das ist die Frage, was sie sich leisten können. Weil Dropbox nutzt ja Amazon-Storage. Das heißt, sie zahlen da schon ganz ordentlich. Und ich glaube für sie ist dieser...
Haben die noch keine eigenen Rechenzentren?
Keine Ahnung, ehrlich gesagt. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass sie ohne so ein größeres Cloud-Backend da bestehen können. Ich weiß nicht, wie groß Dropbox mittlerweile ist. Das ist ja schon eine Firma mit Kunden, die auch zahlen. Ist ja schon mal nicht schlecht.
Bei denen würde ich ja schon vermuten.
Aber ich kenne ihre Zahlen nicht. Ich weiß nicht, wie gut es denen jetzt wirklich geht. Tatsache ist, dass es mit Google mitzuhalten nicht so einfach ist. Das ist schon eine Infrastruktur, die hat sich gewaschen. Da fällt mir noch ein Thema ein.
Ich hatte ja schon die Überlegung, es gibt jetzt so viele komische Cloud-Drive-Systeme. Warum schreibt man nicht einfach mal ein Cloud-Rate-Programm? Das irgendwie die Daten nicht nur verschlüsselt, sondern auch so auf die verschiedenen Dienste aufteilt, dass wenn einer down geht, man trotzdem noch alle seine Daten hat.
Das ist eine lustige Idee.
Cloud-Sync.
Cloud-Rate.
Cloud-Rate. Oder eben, kannst du entweder auf Redundanz auslegen oder auf höhere Geschwindigkeit, weil meistens sind die ja auch nicht so rasend schnell.
Dass er dann gleich von mehreren parallel runterliegt. Metacloud.
Wie auch immer du es nennen willst.
Geile Idee, will ich haben.
Make it happen! Es wäre ein Rake. Ein Redundant Array auf Independent Cloud.
Inexpensive Cloud.
Array trifft es nicht so richtig. Was wäre denn das? Ein Redundant Arrangement auf Independent Clouds. Ach ja.
Aber Dropbox ist doch inzwischen schon riesengroß, oder?
Die müssen schon, glaube ich, relativ groß sein.
Die müssen ja schon eigentlich genug Power haben, um irgendwie sich durchzurechnen und auch ein paar Leute einzustellen, um irgendwie ihre eigenen Rechner aufzusetzen, oder? Und das ohne Amazon zu machen. Wobei die natürlich auch bei Amazon anrufen können.
Die kriegen wahrscheinlich schon andere Tarife von Amazon als andere Leute. Auf der anderen Seite, ich meine Google, denen gehört YouTube. Wenn die nicht Speicherplatz haben, dann weiß ich nicht wer.
Ja, die kann ich auf jeden Fall auch aus.
Content Delivery, das kriegt Google ganz gut hin, glaube ich.
Ja, irgendjemand meint, dass cubby.com sowas sei, hier was du gerade anmahnst.
Aber das ist eher so bei Freunden, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Ehrlich gesagt sehe ich das nicht so richtig beschrieben. Cubby, C-U-B-B-Y. Aber zum Thema Google und so habt ihr das mitbekommen, dass Google seine komplette Infra, also seine Backend-Infrastruktur auf ein anderes Protokoll umgestellt hat. Google? Google ist Data Center untereinander. Also im Wesentlichen gibt es so zwei große Infrastrukturen bei Google. Das Netzwerk, was sie mit den Usern verbindet und das Netzwerk, was alle Data Center untereinander verbindet für ihre internen Backups und etc. Und sie haben jetzt in der letzten Zeit, in den letzten Monaten, auf ein anderes Protokoll umgestellt, mit dem sie diese ganzen Ausgleichsmaßnahmen machen. Und zwar nennt sich das OpenFlow und wie der Name schon assoziiert, handelt es sich bei OpenFlow um einen offenen Standard, der, ich hab mir das ehrlich gesagt im Detail noch nicht genau angeschaut, wie OpenFlow genau funktioniert, aber im Wesentlichen löst es eben dieses Problem, dass du Datenströme mit verschiedenen Prioritäten und Bedürfnissen so in so einem Netzwerk routest, ohne dass die Intelligenz im Router liegt. Also bisher war das halt immer so, dass die Bedürfnisse quasi sich dadurch zum Ausdruck gebracht haben, dass die Bedürfnisse einfach Aktionen ausgelöst haben. Sprich, ein Backup liegt an, das Backup wird durchgeführt und über die Effizienz entscheidet letzten Endes der Router oder das gesamte System von Routern, so wie man das eben so kennt im Internet. Sprich, das funktioniert so gut, wie du eben deine Router im Griff hast. Nur, dass eben die Performance dann sozusagen über jeden einzelnen Hopp hin immer wieder neu entschieden wird. Es gibt keinen Metaplan, es gibt kein Konzept, wie du eben von oben diesen Flow realisierst.
Entschuldigung, wenn ich dich unterbreche, sprechen wir von etwas, was auf IP aufsetzt oder was unter IP drunter ist oder IP ganz gesetzt?
IP, aber das Konzept ist im Wesentlichen so Dump-Routing. Und dass die Routing-Entscheidung quasi auf dem High-Level beschlossen wird. Kann ich nicht genau jetzt sagen, wie das greift, aber im Wesentlichen geht es darum, die Details, die Intelligenz des Routings aus den Routern rauszunehmen. Die Router, also Google hat sich eigene Firmware, hat sich eigene Router gebaut. Ohnehin schon immer. Und jetzt für diesen Fall auch nochmal ganz konkret, weil, wie sie meinen, die Router, die sie brauchen für diese Anforderungen ihrer Data Center untereinander, gibt es auf dem Markt einfach nicht zu kaufen. Und jetzt zeigen sie hier auf OpenFlow, das haben sie jetzt gerade in so einer kleinen Präsentation, Pressekonferenz bekannt gegeben, haben gesagt, ja, hier, wenn Cisco und so weiter gerne so etwas bauen möchte, was den Anforderungen von OpenFlow entspricht, bitte schön, kaufen wir sofort. Bis dahin bauen wir unseren Scheiß selber. Und OpenFlow, also sie wollen sich da einfach auch lösen aus der Problematik der Router, die einfach an vielen Stellen Ineffizienzen bringen. Vorher war es wohl so, dass sie ungefähr so 40 bis 60 Prozent Performance aus ihren Netzen rausbekommen haben. Also das, was quasi die Leitungen böten an Performance, kriegen sie effektiv zu 40 bis 60 Prozent raus. Und jetzt haben sie auf OpenFlow umgestellt und sie meinen, jetzt würden sie ungefähr 99 bis 100 Prozent aus ihrer Netzwerkinfrastruktur herausbekommen. Das heißt, allein dadurch, dass sie das Softwareprotokoll geändert haben und die Router entsprechend verdumisiert haben. Und die Entscheidung einfach an einer anderen Ebene, nämlich, ich weiß nicht, ob das zentral, also das ist das, wo ich jetzt ein bisschen unklar bin. Ich habe jetzt noch kein White Paper durchgelesen über OpenFlow, ob das jetzt irgendwie ein ein Aushandeln im Netz ist und die dann dezentrale oder vielleicht sogar zentrale Entscheidungen fällen. Das weiß ich nicht. Auf jeden Fall fällt diese Entscheidung darüber, was gerautet wird, nicht da. Im Wesentlichen ist es so, den Rautern wird gesagt, hör mal, da kommt jetzt Strom X. Der hat Priorität sowieso, den leitest du jetzt mal nach da um. Und nicht hier, ich bin der coole Router von Cisco und ich weiß voll Bescheid, oh, da kommen ja irgendwie Pakete ganz schnell. Da schalte ich mal besser um, das wird wohl wichtig sein. Weil diese ganzen dezentralen Entscheidungen an der Stelle die Sache einfach nur aufhalten. Weil er eben Sahaya Concept nicht versteht. Der Router weiß nicht, was da passiert. Der weiß nicht, welche Bedeutung das hat. Und du kannst da nochmal irgendwie deine IP-Pakete taggen mit irgendwelchen Priorisierungs Quality of Service Scheiß. Am Ende weiß er nicht, dass da gerade ein wichtiges Backup von Datenzentrum sowieso und zu Datenzentrum sowieso geht, was jetzt einfach wichtig ist und so und so zu laufen hat. Also ich schätze mal, es hat viel was mit Bandbreitenreservierung, mit Kanalreservierung und mit Durchschaltungen von Wegen über mehrere Router zu tun. Das ist aber jetzt nur eine Vermutung von mir. Aber immerhin, sie meinen 100 Prozent, wo sie oder 99 Prozent, wo sie vorher halt 60 bis 40 Prozent hatten. Das heißt, allein dadurch, dass sie eine andere Software zum Einsatz bringen und eine andere Firmware auch auf den Rautern. Ohne irgendeine Leitung neu gelegt zu haben, haben sie quasi die Kapazität ihres Netzes locker verdoppelt. Scheint mir eine sehr interessante Geschichte zu sein. Irgendwie das Ergebnis von Research bei Stanford oder so.
Das ist aber jetzt auch keine Google-Geschichte, sondern das sehe ich auch hier.
Nein, nein, nein. Google meinte, sie hätten ohnehin in diese Richtung bereits gedacht und geforscht. Und dann seien halt da diese Akademiker von Stanford irgendwie mit diesem OpenFlow gekommen und sie hätten sich das angeschaut und gesagt, ja genau, das geht exakt genau in die Richtung, wie wir uns das auch schon immer gedacht haben und haben dann entschlossen, darauf zu gehen. Das ist die Ersten, die das jetzt deploit haben.
Das heißt also andere werden das auch machen, also so ISPs untereinander und so weiter oder wo setzt man das dann genau hin?
Genau, also was weiß ich, so Content Delivery Networks. Also ich denke alles, was in irgendeiner Form ein großes Netzwerk ist und das Problem hat, dass die ganze Zeit Datenströme hin und her geschoben werden müssen. Also wenn du jetzt hier, was weiß ich, Akamai oder so, oder hier auch T-Entertain, viele andere sind ja alles live.
Das heißt es kommt am Ende allen zugute.
Zumindest denen, die es einsetzen.
Wem das jetzt wirklich...
Also Akamai schiebt ja auch dann halt das, was ich brauche. Das heißt die kommen eventuell auch dann datenschneller bei mir an am Ende.
Open Networking Foundation nennen sie sich jetzt hier und OpenFlow News berichtet von HP, OpenFlow, Capable Firmware etc. Also jetzt kommen wohl diese ganzen Switches hier auch. 10 Gigabit Ethernet OpenFlow Switch. Das scheint so ein bisschen der heiße Scheiß zu sein. Und die Ankündigung von Google wird sicherlich dazu führen, dass das jetzt hier richtig thermisch ist.
Wenn ich das so richtig sehe, dann ist es tatsächlich was, was eher auf IP aufsetzt.
Ja, es ist immer noch ein IP-basiertes Netz.
Und was alles, was man so gemeinhin nicht so genau kennt, weil das alles irgendwie in den größeren Layern passiert, also alles, was außerhalb des eigenen Halbnetzes passiert, das scheint wieder abzuhaken. Was ich ja so lustig finde an diesem ganzen Netzwerk-Topologie-Kram, es erinnert mich immer so an die Relativitätstheorie. Weil dadurch, dass sich im Netzwerk Informationen immer mit der gleichen Geschwindigkeit ausbreiten, also auch Meta-Informationen über das Netzwerk breiten sich genauso schnell aus, wie Informationen in dem Netzwerk. Deswegen sind so Sachen wie Gleichzeitigkeit und man müsste eigentlich, wenn man das hier abschickt, dem Router dahinten schon sagen, was er tun kann, kann man aber nicht, weil die Information, was er zu tun hat, genauso schnell ist, wie die Information, die er eigentlich bearbeiten soll. Hat das alles so, ist diese Gleichzeitigkeit, ist alles so relativ, das erinnert mich immer an die Relativitätstheorie.
Danke Roddy, dass du diesem Podcast einen akademischen Anstrich verpasst.
Keine Ursache.
Mist, ich hab mich zugehört.
Aber wahrscheinlich habe ich auch totalen Unsinn erzählt.
Das ist egal, Hauptsache, es klingt akademisch, ja. Die anderen wissen ja jetzt auch nicht, was du gemeint. Das ist nicht witzig. Relativitätstheorie neu aufgeworfen.
Was hast du da gelesen? Hast du auch den Golem-Artikel gelesen? Oder wie kommst du da gerade drauf, weil der ist nämlich hier von ein paar Tagen.
Nee, ich guck gerade in die OpenFlow-Spec-Version 1.2.pdf.
Ja, ich hab den, ja, Urs Hölzle ist ja ein Deutscher, das ist so der Head of Google. Da gibt's so einen kurzen Vortrag von ihm im Netz, den hab ich gesehen.
Verstehe, verstehe.
So, wie spät ist es denn überhaupt? 23 Uhr, die sind hier immer noch nicht fertig mit dem Fußball.
Ja, wir können aber langsam hier mal Ende machen. Wie steht's denn?
Es steht immer noch 3 zu 3, sozusagen.
Ach Leute, ach, dieses Fußball ist doch langweilig.
Ja, deswegen haben wir jetzt hier auch, ne? Ich hab das Gefühl, wir haben irgendwas vergessen.
Echt? Ach, wo ist denn denn der berühmte Liste hier?
Mal sehen, ob ich noch was hab.
Na, da steht jetzt nicht so viel drauf, was wir nicht schon besprochen haben, außer dass irgendwelche Leute der Meinung sind, man sollte sich darüber unterhalten, dass iPads rot, gelb oder blaustichig sind.
Das hatten wir doch vor vier Wochen schon, oder?
Ach, schnarrig. Nee, was, was, was?
Was ist denn mit den Netzwerkproblemen im iPad? Da wird doch gerade angeblich geforscht, oder?
Was ich lustig fand, war die Meldung, dass Microsoft aus dem AOL-Patentportfolio die Hälfte verscherbelt hat. An Facebook.
Ach so, genau.
Für den, was war das für den Preis von, ich glaub, einer halben Milliarde oder irgendwie sowas? Völlig, völliger Unsinn.
Halbe Milliarde.
Naja, so ein halbes Instagram halt.
Das ist eine gute... Oh man, habt ihr diesen News Clip gesehen mit dem Interview von dem Instagram-Chef?
Achso, nee, da steht nur, dass die angeblich so viel Wert sind, weil sie ja eine Milliarde für das Portfolio von AOL, halbe Milliarde bezahlt haben, um es von AOL bekommen zu haben. Und jetzt haben sie davon etwas über die Hälfte verkauft. Ich glaube, der Preis ist nicht bekannt.
Na ja, Facebook, die müssen sich langsam auch warm anziehen. Die wollen ja an die Börse und die kriegen jetzt wahrscheinlich auch so massenhaft Patentklagen gerade reingedrückt.
Ich frage mich, ob dadurch, dass das Facebook an die Börse will, die einfach noch mal hingehen und sagen so, ey, wisst ihr, wir können es uns leisten, da mal so ein beklopptes Instagram für eine Milliarde zu kaufen, weil wir sind so viel Geld wert, wir haben so viel Geld.
Haben wir da eigentlich drüber geredet, über diese Instagram-Pflichter?
Ja, haben wir drüber geredet. Jetzt kaufen sie da noch so ein paar Patente, noch mal für eine halbe Milliarde, weißt du so, dass die Börse so merkt, die schmeißen mit Geld um sich, die müssen ganz, ganz viel wert sein. Wahrscheinlich sind sie jetzt pleite.
Ach, die sind doch nicht pleite. Nee, Instagram haben die schon, das hat schon seinen Grund gehabt, warum die die gekauft haben.
Ich nehme an, dass das einen Grund hat, dass sie nicht pleite sind. Sonst hätten sie nicht kaufen brauchen.
Ich würde sagen, weil sie bei dem Mobile so unglaublich scheiße sind, wie ich schon vorhin gesagt habe. Weil Instagram Konkurrent ist und wesentlich schneller wachsender Konkurrent.
Na ja, also irgendjemand meinte, ich glaube in einem Hypercritical Podcast hatte ich das gehört, dass Facebook ja versucht, das neue Internet zu sein und dass die wahrscheinlich jeden Montag in ihrer super Top-Besprechung da sitzen und sich fragen.
Ich hab's auch gehört, aber ich glaube, das war mit Bild-Einerlass.
Auf jeden Fall, dass die sich dann halt jeden Montag in ihrer Top-Besprechung überlegen, was können wir noch machen, damit wir das Internet sind und bleiben und irgendwie die Leute noch weniger Gründe haben, nach draußen zu gehen.
Und Instagram gehört dazu, glaube ich, für viele. Das ist schon...
In diesem News-Clip, das war so großartig. Da hatten sie irgendwie den Typen da unskrieren und so. Ja, und ich weiß nicht mehr genau, wie die Formulierungen waren, aber so im Kern ging es so, ja, eine Milliarde Kaufpreis und so. Was sagen sie denn dazu? Und er so, ja, eigentlich wollten wir ja zwei Milliarden haben, aber manchmal ist das Leben einfach gemein zu dir. Und danach bricht er ins Gelächte aus. Einmal ist das sicherlich unerwartet. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich das jetzt letztes Mal schon gesagt habe, weil ich mich gerade an diese ganze Debatte nicht so richtig erinnern kann. Aber ich denke, der Preis ergibt sich schlicht und ergreifend aus der Tatsache, dass Zuckerberg eins nicht wollte, nämlich, dass er jemand anders kauft. Und dass es wohl sehr wohl auch Interessenten gegeben hat. Und das hätte zum Beispiel auch Google sein können, vielleicht. Also ich hab da keinerlei Wissen oder so.
Wie war das, Picasso, war das Google oder war das Yahoo?
Yahoo hat Flickr in den Boden gerammt.
Was Yahoo kauft, das ist egal.
Das ist eh verdammt.
Nee, nee, darum ging es ja auch nicht, dass ich jetzt hier eine Lanze für Yahoo brechen wollte.
Ich glaube, das wäre auf Facebook noch lieber gewesen, dass Yahoo es kauft.
Aber war noch nicht um welche News, dass es Yahoo jetzt einigermaßen wieder gut geht, also dass sie sich stabilisiert haben?
Sie haben gerade 2000 Leute entlassen.
Das ist doch immer ein gutes Zeichen.
Ja, das ist.
Frag mal so ein Aktionär, werden die bei so einer Bude läutert lassen, das ist immer ein gutes Zeichen, da geht die Aktie hoch, weil die wissen.
Ja, kurzzeitig.
Ja, die werden sich noch weiter stabilisieren, bis sie sich wirklich komplett wegstabilisiert haben.
Google und Instagram kaufen?
Google kauft ja auch jeden Scheiß.
Warum denn nicht? Wenn Google jetzt Instagram gekauft hätte, dann hätten sie es doch auch in den Boden gefahren. Vielleicht nicht so schnell wie Yahoo. Aber ich meine, was macht denn den Reiz von Instagram aus? Das ist ein relativ fokussiertes Produkt, dass du diese netten, völlig unsinnigen, aber irgendwie doch ganz nett aussehenden Filter da drin hast. Und dass du, ich sag mal, fast wie auf Twitter nicht viel machen kannst, aber das, was du machen kannst, ist einfach genau das, was du tun willst.
Vielleicht wollte ich nicht Google haben, vielleicht wollte Apple das haben.
Um es zu Ping dran zu basteln oder was?
Ping ist ja wohl fair.
Also Social, das ist nicht Apple.
Ja, ich meine, aber mal ganz ehrlich, Instagram war ja auch nur so, naja, war schon so ein bisschen Social, aber war irgendwie so... Also ich meine, das entspricht überhaupt nicht Google. Google ist immer so... Das war nicht, das ist noch. Wir können die Features noch alle reinbauen, weil wir sind so cool. Und dann kommt ein Google Wave-Ball raus, weißt du so? Und was hätte Google mit einem Instagram gemacht?
Kaputt? Na, Google kann auch kleine Sachen. Also ich meine, YouTube ist, na okay, ist auch nicht mehr wirklich gut. Aber das haben sie jetzt, also nach wie vor ist gewachsen relativ kontinuierlich und die haben da ein Geschäftsmodell draus gemacht aus YouTube.
Na ja, YouTube war jetzt auch irgendwie, ich meine, eine Seite, wo man Videos hochlädt und wieder abspielt.
Ja, total simpel, total simpel. Auf eine Aufgabe fokussiert ist es nach wie vor, hat eine starke Community, hat große Fans und wirft mittlerweile in Schweine Geld ab. Und wer hätte so, hätte doch auch für Instagram, also, dass sie da jetzt Interesse dran haben.
Und die brauchen halt irgendwas um die Leute auch.
Du zeigst die Fotos an und blendest Werbung drüber ein.
Ja, keine Ahnung, aber 30 Millionen Leute. Das ist einfach mal eine Zahl.
Innerhalb von zwei Jahren.
Ja, und das ist ein Wachstum, das muss Facebook in gewisser Hinsicht Angst machen. Und ob die jetzt sich aus eigener Kraft heraus irgendwo hin entwickelt hätten, oder ob es vielleicht jemand einen Käufer gab, aber das ist für sie natürlich schon eine Bedrohung, weil sonst schafft, hat dieses Wachstum keiner hinbekommen. Und sie haben dieses Wachstum in einem Segment gebracht, in dem Facebook einfach überhaupt nicht präsent ist. Sie machen zwar Fotos, aber mobile in dem Maße nicht.
Ja, aber ich glaube, die gehen davon falschen Voraussetzungen aus, weil ich würde ja sogar sagen, Instagram ist ja der Gegenentwurf zu Facebook. Und sie sind gewachsen, weil sie der Gegenentwurf zu Facebook sind.
Die Leute benutzen nicht Instagram, weil es nicht Facebook ist.
Nein, nicht weil es nicht Facebook ist, sondern weil es nicht das ist, was Facebook ist. Also über Instagram werden keine Flashmobs organisiert. Instagram speichert nicht tausend Daten von dir und du hast auch keine Pin-Mann, wo dir irgendjemand Sachen ranpinnt und so weiter. Facebook versucht irgendwie, das digitale Wohnzimmer der Leute zu sein und Instagram ist einfach fokussiert da drauf. Ich mach ein geiles Foto, ich stell es drauf und wer der Meinung ist, das ist geil, der drückt dann auf den Like-Button und dann ist die Sache gegessen. Das ist ein total fokussiertes Produkt und die Leute, die das nutzen, nutzen es, weil es so ein schönes, einfaches, fokussiertes Produkt ist.
Also ich glaub, die haben die für eine Milliarde gekauft, weil sie in einem halben Jahr zwei Milliarden zahlen müssen.
Das werden wir jetzt nicht geklärt bekommen. Aber ich würd gern das Thema Social Networks noch ein bisschen, ich bin ja auch, da lass ich ja auch häufig durchhängen, so Social Networks und so weiter. Da muss mich schon immer irgendwie was locken. Und ich weiß noch, was mich von Google Plus so abgestoßen hat, ist so, dass diese Art und Weise der Kommunikation mir irgendwie nicht gepasst hat. Ich meine, Google Plus hat so ein bisschen seine Nische gefunden. Das ist so das temporäre Block. Das ist so das 10-Minuten-Block. Wenn du mal was ausführlich diskutieren möchtest mit mehr als 140 Zeichen, da irgendwie so eine quatschfreudige Community mal dynamisch erreichen willst, dann postest du es am besten auf Google Plus, weil da hast du halt so diesen Facebook-Style eine neue Diskussionsflow oder ist er überhaupt Facebook-Style? Keine Ahnung. Auf jeden Fall hast du da so wie in deinem oder wie auch in deinem Kommentarfeld in einem Blog, kann sich da einfach so eine Diskussion entfalten. Und dann steht die so für sich und das hat irgendwie eine URL und dann kannst du dann später darauf referenzieren. Das ist prima und du musst aber jetzt nicht das Ganze im Kontext eines deines Blogs machen etc. Sondern du twitterst das kurz oder vielleicht verbreitet es sich auch über Google Plus. Keine Ahnung, nur dieses permanente Reihen. Ja, aber Facebook kommt ja mit diesen ganzen anderen Klumpfüßen. Ja, es ist nicht so offen im Web, es ist nicht durchsuchbar.
Das Google Plus kann man da auch rein ohne Facebook.
Wenn so ein Facebook-Link dann muss ich halt erstmal einloggen. Also wenn du keinen Account hast, dann kannst du solche... Meines Wissens nicht.
Ich weiß das nicht.
Du kannst zumindest Google Plus Seiten angucken, ohne dass du dich einloggen musst.
Du kannst da nichts schreiben, aber du kannst es halt lesen. Also es ist sozusagen wie eine Seite im Web. Korrigiert mich, wenn ich irgendwas Grundsätzliches missverstanden habe.
Nee, nee, seh ich auch so.
Gut. So, was mich aber immer extrem gestört hat an Google Plus ist, der Gedanke, das so zu benutzen wie Twitter, hat sich mir so richtig nicht erschlossen, weil es eigentlich erstmal nichts anderes macht. Außer, ich kann länger schreiben. Okay. Ich finde, in dir liegt die Würze. Twitter hat ja auch so einen Punkt damit, dass es so reduziert ist. Auch wenn es mich manchmal nervt, warum es nicht 160 Zeichen sind, aber würde mich die Grenze dann auch irgendwann wieder stören.
Ob die 20 Zeichen das jetzt rausreißen?
Weil, wäre es zumindest SMS-kompatibel gewesen.
Nee, aber deswegen sind es ja 140 Zeichen, damit es SMS-kompatibel sind.
Genau genommen ist das ja dann nicht der Fall. Das kriege ich da nicht rein.
Nein, weil du ja ursprünglich das mal über SMS so benutzen konntest, dass du halt... Username plus bla bla bla und dann hast du einen Tweet geschrieben und so weiter.
Ja.
Deswegen nur 140 Zeichen, aber ey pfff. Also 160 Zeichen ist...
Man hätte den Username auch einfach mitzählen. Egal, darum geht es mir jetzt auch gar nicht.
160 Zeichen der SMS ist ja auch so was.
Google Plus hat für mich so... Was war jetzt so der Selling-Point von Google Plus? Das sind diese merkwürdigen Circles. Und was mich von Anfang an gestört hat bei diesen Circles, ist, dass sie meiner Meinung nach die Sache falsch rum aufziehen. Du musst die Leute in diese Kreise reintun und dann sprichst du in diese Kreise rein und sagst, das ist jetzt für diesen Kreis. Und sprichst sozusagen explizit Leute ein. Aber Leute, die du da nicht reingetan hast, die werden nicht angesprochen. Das heißt, du musst eigentlich die ganze Zeit herumgärtnern in deinem Google Plus. Ja, du musst halt die ganze Zeit Unkraut, Jäten und irgendwie neue Blumenzwiebeln anpflanzen, damit diese kleinen Circles da, diese Blumenbete sich auch irgendwie korrekt bespielt finden. Weil was, wenn jetzt Person X was schreibt, was dich eigentlich interessiert, weil es über Thema Y ist, du bist aber nicht in dem Kreis Y, dann kommst du da ja auch nicht rein. Oder weißt noch nicht mal, dass du da drin bist, was auch immer, es ist irgendwie falsch rum. Und ich dachte mir so, eigentlich müsste es andersrum sein. So, fast forward. Pinterest. Habt ihr bestimmt schon mal gehört.
Ja, ja, ja, du sprichst ja seit...
Ach du bist jetzt auf dem Pinterest-Trip.
Ich bin auch auf gar keinem Trip, ich hab nur verstanden, dass Pinterest tatsächlich genau so rum funktioniert, wie ich das Google Plus immer gerne, wie es immer meiner Meinung war, wie es so hätte funktionieren müssen. Bei Pinterest, und zwar ist es das Board in dem Fall, du bist halt auf Pinterest und du pinst Sachen, das ist hier wieder die neue Sprachregelung. Pinnen besteht darin, dass du dir eine Webseite suchst oder auf eine triffst oder eine offen hast und da ist irgendwas Interessantes. So, das willst du jetzt sharen. Das alte Spiel. So, und dann hast du da irgendwie so ein Bookmarklet, Pinted und Pinted mehr halt, also früher diese Bookmark-Services, haben wir einfach die URL genommen und dann durftest du deine Tags eintragen. Und Pinterest ist halt einfach das Ding, dass du hier Bilder oder Videos auswählst, die sich auf dieser Webseite befinden, die dann für die ganze Webseite stehen. Trotzdem links du im Prinzip und shares im Prinzip die gesamte Webseite. Du kannst auch nicht einfach nur Bilder, einfach so eine JPEG-URL nehmen, das muss schon eine HTML-Seite sein. Und kriegst dann so einen Dialog, wo dann alle Bilder kurz aufgelistet werden. Das legt sich so drüber, dann wählst du das Bild aus, dann ist es gepinnt. Und du pinst es in ein Board. Du kannst beliebig viele Boards anlegen, wenn du dich einrichtest neu, werden dir so ein paar komische vorgeschlagen, die hab ich erstmal wieder alle gelöscht, weil ich mich von solchen Gedankenmatrixen da nicht prägen lassen will. Ich entwickel die quasi on the fly und du sagst einfach, ich pinn das jetzt hier in dieses Board rein. Und wenn jetzt mir jemand folgen will, weil er aus welchen Gründen auch immer meine Geschäre für interessant hält auf Pinterest, dann kann er allen Boards folgen oder eben auch nur einzelnen. Und auch jederzeit bestimmte Boards wieder deselektieren. Ich sage ich pinne irgendwie Fußball, ich pinne Autos, ich pinne Apple, ich pinne Memes, ich pinne Wahnsinn und ich pinne Diskordianismus. Dann kann er sagen, hier mit Autos und so weiter und Fußball kannst du mir gestohlen bleiben. Ja, mich interessiert jetzt hier nur die diskordische Klempe.
Du und Autos?
Das heißt, du folgst Aspekten, kulturellen Aspekten einer Persönlichkeit. Und das finde ich stark.
Die muss man erstmal haben.
Das ist das letzte Spiel. Da habe ich jetzt erstmal verstanden.
Timme, mach mal Fullscreen, jetzt kommt das Elfmeterschießen. Also wenn beim Fußball die Cherry auf der Torte ist, dann muss ich ja das Elfmeterschießen. Bayern hat erstmal einen versenkt, also rein gehauen.
Ah ja, okay, dann machen wir jetzt hier Live-Übertragung.
Das brauchen wir eigentlich nicht.
Der Typ schießt links, der Torwart springt rechts, so kann das nichts werden.
Also bei Pinterest gibt es auch noch ein paar anderes Schönes, was sich ja auch Flatter gleich geklaut hat. Wir machen jetzt hier keinen Fußball-Podcast drauf.
Was gibt es denn da? Erzähl weiter.
Na, diese Ansicht ist einfach sehr interessant. Also die haben so dieses Spalten-Modell. Und du kannst halt dann auch, wenn du dein Browser-Fenster... Oh, der hat ihn gehalten.
Fuck.
Die Bayern schaffen es am Ende doch noch, wa?
Die müssen jetzt noch einen reinkriegen und dann war's das.
Das war aber jetzt der erste, oder?
Nein. Spanien hat jetzt den zweiten verschossen.
Nee, nicht den zweiten.
Doch, hast nicht hingeguckt.
Wieso zeigen die das nicht an?
Nein, die waren jetzt nur erst mal dran wieder. Vorstand 2.1, weil die Spanier überhaupt erst nur einmal dran waren.
Da, zwei rote Punkte für die Spanier.
Achso, das heißt...
Zwei grüne Punkte.
Wir haben jetzt einen mehr. Zum Thema Pinterest. Ich bin ja gleich fertig.
Die auch.
Was cool ist, und deswegen hatte ich dir das auch für deine komische Gebiss-Applikation vorgestellt. Und die beiden haben auch einen verschossen, das bleibt wieder spannend. Entschuldigung, ich sehe bei diesem Logo nur Zähne. Weißt du überhaupt, was ich meine mit Multiplies, mit diesen Zähnen? Da gibt's diesen einen Cartoon, wo dann nur diese Zähne so hoch und runter geht. Genau.
Stimmt, den könnt man mal raussuchen.
Es gibt immer so Zwischenmovies.
Chad, such den mal bitte raus.
Das heißt, Pinterest verbindet zwei Sachen, nämlich auf der einen Seite dieser visuelle Q von Instagram. Aber trotzdem handelt es sich immer noch um URLs. Es geht nicht um die Fotos, sondern es geht um das, was hinter diesen Fotos oder Filmen sich verbirgt.
Erstmal gucken, ob SysSenseit überhaupt einen Pinterest-Filter hat. Auf dem iPhone?
Ja, nee, ich bräuchte eine App auf dem Mac, die mir diesen Strom irgendwie so durchlaufen lässt. Das find ich gut, wenn so die Pinterest-Bilder, sozusagen dieser Pins, wie so ein Banner unten einfach durchläuft. Und wenn ich dann irgendwie so ein Bild sehe, dann ist gut. Dann verschossen oder was?
Der Lahm hat verschossen, voll lahm.
Echt? Naja, so ist Fußball.
Ja, da brechen dann die Männer zusammen.
Ich mach das gleich aus.
Jetzt kannst du gleich rum.
Podcasting und Fußball, das verträgt sich irgendwie gar nicht. Wir werden furchtbare Kritiken einfahren.
Nicht das Fußballpodcaster, das hören.
Das ist mir total schnuppe.
Jetzt muss er nur noch reinhauen und dann haben sie gewonnen.
Nee, nee, jetzt ist ja wieder ausgeglichen. Spanier hatten ja auch schon zwei daneben.
Da hätten sie wieder gleich auf. Ich glaube, wir haben einen mehr weg.
Der betet noch, meine Herren.
Schießt du schon oder betest du noch? Na ja, aber ansonsten, ich weiß auch nicht, wo es mit diesen ganzen Social Networks hingehen soll. So viele Inspirationen kann man ja überhaupt gar nicht aufnehmen.
Ich habe hier die ganze Zeit eine Jodie McKee in meiner Pinterest-Timeline und jetzt habe ich die schon mindestens 200 Mal entfohleert und die ist immer noch da.
Voll auf den Mond.
Der kriegt so Prügel von seinen Jungs.
Der ist der Gerama. Jetzt kann ich ja noch mal kurz sagen, wo wir sowieso schon in dieser bedeutungsfreien Zeit hier sind, in diesem Podcast. Ich habe Panic irgendwie angetwittert, weil sie ja für ihr Transmit nur Sync gegenüber Mobile Me anbieten. Und jetzt habe ich gerade eine Antwort bekommen und sie klagen, We've been struggling epically with iCloud Sync in Coda 2. Hopefully that knowledge can be applied to Transmit.
Die sollen dieses iCloud lassen und einfach Dropbox machen. Dieses iCloud, das ist so beta, dass es fast noch Alpha ist.
Na gut, das wird ja auch irgendwann nicht mehr so sein. So was ist jetzt, wenn er jetzt reinhaut, ist alles gut oder was? Schweini macht es oder Schweini macht es nicht?
Der Druck ist zu groß.
Drinnen ist er.
Okay, ganz locker.
Und jetzt zieht er sich aus und jetzt haben sie es geschafft, oder was? Die Bayern sind durch, das ist ja geil. Der Traum ist erfüllt. Ich gönne es ihnen jetzt insofern, weil ihr wisst ja, das Endspiel ist in München. In München und das war sozusagen das Ziel überhaupt. Jetzt haben sie Real in München.
Aber das heißt, da kommt halt noch ein Game.
Ja, das Finale.
Gegen?
Gegen Chelsea.
Verstehe.
Ich glaube gar nicht, was ich hier mache. Wir machen hier einen Fußball.
Ja, nein, nein, nein.
Wir sind ja jetzt fertig. Du kannst das jetzt ausmachen, weil Fußball hat sich erledigt und wir haben uns auch erledigt, oder?
Ja, ich denke auch. Also wir haben gewonnen im Elfmeterschießen. Hat sich Movamex durchgehalten.
Aber soll ich dir was sagen? Ich glaube der Huckel, der war gar nicht bei der Erlang-User-Group. Der war Fußballgucken der Sack.
Das glaube ich auch.
Vielleicht hat die ganze Erlang-Group geschlossen Fußball geguckt.
Wahrscheinlich.
So sieht es nämlich aus. Huckel.
Und mal ganz ehrlich, unsere Leihführer haben noch heimlich auch die ganze Zeit Fußball geguckt.
Ja, aber ich glaube Huckel hat auch die ganze Zeit in Stream gehört.
Hättest du dir das angeguckt, wenn du jetzt heute nicht hier gewesen wärst?
Nee, hätte ich gar nicht gewusst. Und ich könnte auch gar nicht gucken, weil da habe ich gar keine Möglichkeiten zu.
Tja, haben sie Schwein gehabt. Aber es war eigentlich ein Endspiel. Die beiden. Naja, so viel dazu.
Das ist auch so ein Fußballsatz, den man immer sagen kann.
Was?
Nicht immer, aber eigentlich war das ja das kleine Endspiel. Die Engländer, das kleine Endspiel.
Aber Ramm kann man nicht mehr fahren. Wir machen jetzt hier mal den Fernseher aus. Das Rohrkitz oder so alles hier, das ist alles ganz furchtbar. Also ich hab nichts mehr hier. Wir können ja noch ein bisschen mit dem Chat reden, machen wir mal ein bisschen After Hour. Aber die Sendung ist jetzt vorbei, Leute. So geht's ja nun nicht. So, und wer hat das letzte Wort?
Wer?
Thank you for coming and we'll see you soon.